hey guys welcome back to another session
by simply learn
today's topic of discussion is java
versus python
so in this session we're going to
compare the two most prominently used
languages that is java and python we're
also going to help you choose the
appropriate programming language
depending on your requirements if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already i'd really suggest you hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update
all right i'm sure we've all been in
this position where we've had to choose
between java and python
and it was so
confusing so today let me help you
choose between the two languages and
look at what's in store for us
first we have an introduction to both
java and python
then we will compare the fundamental
concepts of both these languages
after that we will get to know the
various fields in which these languages
are being used extensively
then we will go through the current
industry trends and the salaries offered
to these developers
and finally we will reach to a
conclusion and decide for ourselves
which language is good for us according
to our requirements
so let's start the session by first
getting to know both java and python
java was developed by sun micro systems
it is a fairly robust and high level
language
it is an object-oriented language and so
adheres to all the oops concepts like
abstraction and encapsulation
it was originally designed for use in
small hardware like set-up boxes and
handheld devices but due to the
increasing popularity of internet in
those times it was very quickly modified
to be used in the world wide web
moving on what exactly is python
now you won't believe this but python
was created in the year 1989. like java
it is also object oriented and is a high
level language
it incorporates many english words in
its syntax as it was designed to be
significantly more readable than other
programming languages
it is mainly used for artificial
intelligence machine learning and web
development
so now that you've been introduced to
both java and python let's go ahead and
compare the fundamental concepts of both
these languages
first up is speed
java is a statically typed language
which means the syntax is checked at
compile time and so the execution speed
is faster
opposingly python is a dynamically typed
language so the syntax is checked at the
time of execution
this makes the execution speed slower
when compared to java
next up is syntax
python has a clear advantage when it
comes to the amount of code we have to
write for performing the same task
you can point out how simple it is to
print a hello world in python when
compared to java
python automatically sets the type of
variable according to its value java on
the other hand needs the type of
variable to be defined before the
compilation of the code
java is more commonly used for web and
mobile applications while python is
mainly used for data science machine
learning and internet of things
i'm sure by now you have a good
understanding of these languages so
let's go ahead and see where they're
used more commonly
first up let's see the use cases of java
it is commonly used for developing web
and mobile applications
java is extensively used in enterprise
applications because of its stability
and also because of the large number of
features that it provides for business
applications
android applications are mainly
developed using java
now let's see the use cases of python
python is very popular for the use in
the field of artificial intelligence
it is also used for web development
mostly for the back-end part of an
application
youtube is mostly written in python
moving on let's go through the industry
trends and salaries for both python and
java developers
the graph represents the growth of both
the languages over the last five years
we can make out that python has picked
up over time and has become more popular
than java in recent times
this is mainly due to the increasing
popularity of data science fields
moving on to the salaries
the average salary of a java developer
in india is around 4.5 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a java developer
in the us is around 80 000 us dollars
moving on to python the average salary
of a python developer in india is around
4 lakhs per annum
since people pursue python mostly
because they are interested in the field
of data science the salary dramatically
increases when they get a suitable role
say data scientist
data scientists get paid on an average
of 10 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a python developer
in the united states is around 76 000 us
dollars
if they get into data science roles
their average salary spikes up to around
110 000 us dollars
moving on to the last topic on our
agenda here we conclude as to which
programming language is suitable for you
depending on your requirements
let's now think about why we'd want to
go with one of these languages here are
some points to keep in mind
choose java if you are more into
software engineer roles and want to
handle systems for large corporations
java is extensively used for developing
android applications so if you want to
build an application for android os java
should be your clear choice
java is also suitable for building
various standalone end-to-end softwares
that run on the pcs if you are into this
sort of thing then java is the language
for you
on the other hand if you are interested
in the fields of artificial intelligence
data science or the internet of things
python is the go to language for those
sorts of technologies
python is very simple to understand so
if you're learning to code for the very
first time i'd suggest you go with
python
if you're interested in web development
python can be a good choice as it
provides excellent frameworks like
django and flask to facilitate web
development
in today's era the internet and
smartphones have become an integral part
of our lives we use our phones for
almost all of our day-to-day tasks
earlier we used to shop at malls queue
up in front of banks and make our travel
bookings at travel agencies but now we
can do all this in the comfort of our
homes using smartphones all of this is
possible because of a high level
programming language called java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object oriented programming
language java
java is an object-oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a
high-level language that is easy to read
and understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices
it is used not only in computers and
mobiles but even in electronic devices
like televisions washing machines air
conditioners and so on online forms
banking and shopping are possible
because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991. he had a
single motto while creating the language
it was right once run anywhere this
meant that the code would have to be
written only once but it could be used
anywhere they named this language oak
because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named to
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an oriented programming language
based on c and c plus however it is
improved and simplified to solve the
errors in programming java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the java
interpreter the whole java code is run
on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided into different sections in a
supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine it is a very secure
language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data
the next feature is inheritance as the
name suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so now let's download java let's go to
google and search for java download
we'll go to the link we see here
oracle.com so now here we have the web
page
here we can see java sc13 so this is
version 13 but this isn't the one we are
going to download we are going to
download the eighth version version 8
which is here now we're doing this
because 8 is one of the more commonly
used versions of java
so let's click this
and here we'll go down we need to accept
the license agreement before we can
download it
now we have two versions here x 86 and
x64 now you can download it depending on
what version your operating system is
now if you do have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this
so we've actually already logged in so
we just need to run the installer file
now let's go to downloads
and run the file
so here we have the installer we go to
the next step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed to
we'll go to next
now if you want to change where you want
to install java we can press the change
option i'm just going to keep it here
we'll press next and let's commence with
installation
and there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or api documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close
now to see if java is installed in your
system we can go to command prompt
and type the term java c
which refers to the java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates that
java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
java c is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now
and now we're going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a dot java
extension this environment variable
tells the computer that the java program
needs to be called to run this
particular file
so to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control panel
here go into system and security
go to system and select advanced system
settings and then this shows up now
before we go into environment variables
we'll need to go to where the java file
was installed so let's go to this pc
c drive
program files
and here let's go to java
so let's go to jdk which is the java
development kit let's go to bin here
and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here
and then press on new
paste this
and okay now we'll go back
and go to jre to the path of jre which
is java runtime environment we click on
this pin again
and copy this path
select this one
new
and paste that
and there we go the environment
variables are now set
now let's talk about running that simple
program i told you about now this is
possible with the help of an ide an ide
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code java we
will be using eclipse and intellij as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other ides
that are available in the market so now
let's work with eclipse let's go to
google and search for eclipse
we'll go to this link
press download and then this shows up
let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so i'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
downloads
and select eclipse with this you can see
that there are multiple options for you
to choose from so we're going to select
eclipse ide for java developers now you
have other options like for cnc plus
plus javascript php and so on let's go
to the first one and here you have the
details you can change them if you want
but i'm just going to go ahead with
installation now
you press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept
and then here as well we'll remember
accepted certificates select this one
and accept selected
and there you go the installation is now
complete
let's click on launch now
so here we are setting up a directory as
a workspace uh i'm not changing it here
so i'm just going to go with launch
here we have the eclipse workspace now
let's close this first and here we have
the package explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
show view
and select on package explorer
so now let's go to file
new and java project we need to set up a
project name i'm going to call it my
project
one
go to next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your
program is going to be stored then let's
finish and now we'll click on my project
one
go to source
i click new
and create a class
explain
i'll name the class my class
and create it and here we have it so now
let's write a simple program to multiply
two numbers
so now let's write the main function
open
bracket
now we're going to initialize the first
number
now the second one
and finally the output
and finally the variable that will store
the output
now we'll just give them a simple print
statement
now let's run the code by clicking this
option here
using my cluster java
and there we have it here the product is
shown to be 100 indicating that the
program is running successfully
now we're done with eclipse now let's
move on to the other ide i was talking
about which is intellij so for that
again we'll have to go back to google so
that we can download it how to install
eclipse ide on your windows 10 operating
system now an ide is an integrated
development environment on this computer
programmers can perform software
development now eclipse is one of
several in the market like intellij
bluej doctor java and so on now to
install eclipse first you need to
install java this is because if you try
to run the eclipse installer this shows
up this shows that you do need java
before you can install eclipse on your
operating system so first let's go and
download java now let's search for java
install
and then go to this link now here we
have the latest version which is version
13. we're not going to pick that one up
we're going to go to version 8. now
we're choosing version 8 because this is
one of the most commonly used versions
of java so let's select this so we'll go
down all the way here and here we can
see two options the 64-bit and the
86-bit so this basically represents the
32-bit operating system so if you do
have one you can select this option
since we have a 64-bit operating system
i'm going to select this but before the
installation you need to accept license
agreement and select this now i've
already logged in so i'm just going to
install now select this go to downloads
click on this and then this shows up
we'll go to next we'll go to next let
the install complete
so here we have another pop-up so if you
want to change the destination folder
you can select this option this is fine
with me so i'm going to go with next
that's it we'll let the installation
complete now so there you go the
installation is now complete so if you
want to look at tutorials or
documentation you can go to the next
steps i don't want to so let's close and
go back now just because we've installed
java we can't exactly run it yet for
that we need environment variables now
environment variables help the computer
understand that it needs to run java
when it sees a dot java file for that
let's go to the control panel
let's go to system and then let's go
here
and select advanced system settings and
then this shows up now before we can set
the environment variables we'll need the
path to where java is installed so let's
go to file explorer let's click c drive
let's go to program files so this is
where i install java let's go to java
first let's go to jdk and bin now let's
go back here click on environment
variables select a path here go back
let's copy that
and press on new and paste this now
likewise let's go back go to jre which
is the java runtime environment and jdk
which is the java development kit click
on this go to bin and select this path
go back go to path
select new and paste this as well and
there you go the environment variables
are now set let's click on ok and that's
done now let's install eclipse let's go
back again and search for eclipse
in here select this option click on
download select 64-bit so and this shows
up so i've already downloaded it so we
can directly go there i'm going to click
on this now so now we have the installer
show up so here you can choose from a
number of different options like cec
plus plus php and so on so you want this
one we click on this and here we can
just install we'll accept and there you
go the installation is going on right
now we'll remember accepted licenses
except this you need to accept these
certificates
except selected and there you go we're
complete let's launch
so now we need to set up a directory so
i'm okay with this so let's launch
and there you go here's the workspace so
let's run a very simple program now so
we'll close this and here you have the
package explorer let's open this up so
in case you can't access the package
explorer go to window click on show view
and select package explorer now first to
run a program you need to create a java
project click on this and let's name our
project let's go to next and here you
see src or source now this is where the
source code of your program is now we'll
just finish
and that's that now we go to source
right click new and create class now
let's create a class
class
1 and finish and now we should be able
to run any program we want let's look at
the very simple code of writing hello
world so let's open the main function
there you go let's open a bracket here
let's print
and that's that now let's run the
program by clicking on this icon let's
select the class and there we go we have
an output this means the program is
running successfully
let's begin with the fundamentals so the
first one in the fundamentals is the
data types so every programming language
has a data type so what exactly is a
data type so whatever the input you
provide in your program is a data type
for example if you provide numbers so in
that particular numbers we have a
different variety of numbers if you are
given just 1 2 3 so on without a decimal
number then that particular type of
input which is a number will be
considered as integer type if you
provide the same number with a decimal
point then that will be considered as
float and if you have the range greater
than float it will be considered as
double and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language so the most frequently used
data types in java programming languages
are as follows at first we have the byte
followed by that we have short end long
next float then double boolean and
finally care apart from this we also
have few other data types but these are
the most frequently used ones for all
the basic programmings so this is made
for beginners basically so you can take
a quick screenshot of this particular
slide so that you can have a quick
overview or reference to all the data
types in java programming language so i
hope you have taken a screenshot of this
now let's begin with the next concept so
in the next concept we have the keywords
and variables so all the programming
languages have variables and keywords so
variables are used to store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values that is 5 and 10. so in
order to do so you might want to create
a variable which stores them for example
you wanted to store the value of 10 in a
certain variable a and the 5 in a
certain variable b so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is a is equals
to a plus b
then the value of a which was previously
10 will be updated to 15. so here you
can see the value is varying and also it
is storing the result so this is why the
variables are used in a program in order
to store a value and this particular
term variable is used because the value
can change at any instance of time once
after a certain arithmetic or a logical
operation is performed on that
particular variable so similarly we have
keywords unlike variables keywords have
a special meaning no matter whatever you
try you cannot change the meaning of
that keyword for example consider main
so you cannot use the term main for
normal things
because the part or the term main is
dedicated for a different purpose so
whenever you try to execute your java
program the control flow will start
executing the program right when it
reads the term main
so it has a special meaning similarly
you have other keywords such as end so
that is dedicated for integer type of
values and float for float type of
values that is a decimal values and byte
for byte care for character type data
string for string so every keyword or
every term with special meaning which is
predefined and cannot be changed is
called as a keyword now let's see the
most frequently used keywords in java
programming language so similar to the
previous one we have a table here so in
this particular table we have the most
frequently used keywords in java so you
can see we have boolean final byte
native and we have void switch so switch
is a conditional statement so we have if
if it is also a conditional statement we
will go through this conditional
statements as we proceed in our tutorial
and you can also see the protected so
this term which is protected public so
this is basically the access modifier
even this particular keyword have
special meaning this public this
protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extends so
extends in this term comes in
inheritance so inheritance is one of the
crucial concepts of object oriented
program and you can also see abstraction
so this we will be dealing in the next
upcoming part where we will understand
the object-oriented programming concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some keywords like
through so throw will come in exception
handling so we will also learn about
exception handling in the upcoming part
so these are the most frequently used
keywords in java so now we will move
ahead into our next concept so the next
concept is the operators in java so to
understand operators let's go through a
table so on my screen you can see a
table which has some arithmetic
operators which are most commonly used
that is the plus for addition minus the
subtraction similarly we have star
forward slash double plus double minus
so double plus and double minus say they
are increment and decrement operators
respectively as you can see we have a
plus plus here which means the post
increment so the first
value will be read after that the value
will be updated next we have the
pre-increment
the value will be incremented first then
the updated value will be stored so
that's that's how the increment and
decrement operators work so we have the
modulus over here so to understand the
operators that we use in java in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program so on my screen you can see a
program which is based on operators so
we are currently on the eclipse ide
don't worry about the ids and java etc
etc so i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a very detailed way about how to
install java into your local system and
how to install eclipse ide in your local
system and also how to create your first
project how to create your package how
to create a new class how to write your
program and how to run that how to see
the output and a complete overview of
the eclipse ide how that works so
everything will be linked in the
description box below you don't have to
worry about that so right now to save
time i have created the text document
which has all the programs that we will
be executing today so i will also drop a
link for that particular file so that
you can have complete access to that
file so that you can run the programs in
your personal pcs or laptops and also
understand the programs in a much better
way so now let's begin with the program
so this particular program is basically
designed for automatic operations so you
can see we have the operators that is
the addition subtraction multiplication
division modulus and exit so basically
we will be taking input from mu so the
input will be taken by the user
that is we're using scanner class here
so scanner class takes the input from
user and that particular input will be
compared here so we're using the switch
case here so if you provide the option
as one then edition operation will be
run similarly second for subtraction
third for multiplication fourth for
division fifth for modulus and sixth to
exit so this is how the
loop or the program works for automatic
operations now let's quickly run this
program and see the output so you can
see the program got successfully
executed and we have the console asking
for the first input let's provide some
random number now
let's provide the second number so there
you go we have our options over here now
let's choose uh division operation for
that we need to provide the number four
so there you go we have the result over
here which is 4. now the loop has
started once again now it's in the
starting stage again it's asking for
numbers now let's provide a 25 and
five
now let's choose some operation that is
edition so for that you need to provide
one so we have the result again that is
30.
now
let's again choose some number 10
5 so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so i hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry i
have linked the
document in the description box below
you can take the access of that
particular document and you can check
the program and run in your local system
and also you can make some modifications
to it as you can see we don't have a
default case over here i've just placed
the case one two six and
i'm seeing the default because you can
see that the options are from one to six
what if the user provides the number as
seven right so the program might crash
over here so for that purpose you can
write in another case that would be the
default case so the default case will
check if the number is anything above or
out of the range of 1 to 6 then it
should be providing you with an output
saying a wrong input has been given or
check your input or something similar so
that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that so now let's quickly begin
with our next concept so in the next
concept we have the conditional
statements so what are the conditional
statements or the control statements so
basically these are some
yeah these are conditions so what
happens is just imagine that you wanted
to do something or if you wanted to
drive a vehicle or if you wanted to
drive a bike so the condition you will
apply on your mind is if i know driving
then i will do it if not i'll not do it
so that's what you do right so basically
you apply a condition on your mind and
you do it if it is capable of doing or
if you are capable of doing it so in the
same way the conditional statements play
a major role in computer logic so before
writing a code or before you start your
program you provide the condition
perform this particular operation if the
provided condition is satisfied so
similarly you have
these three conditional statements in
java which are if if else and nested if
so we use these conditional statements
in java to implement our logic so we
will understand the conditional
statements particularly if if else and
nested if in a much more detailed way by
practically running some programs based
on these three types of conditional
statements so now you can see that we
are back on the eclipse right now so
this particular code segment is based on
the if condition i hope the program is
visible let's try to increase the font
size so i think it's better now so
basically we have an input so we have
the integer type of input that is num
and we have the number as
100 so it is a negative number and after
that we have the if condition so this is
where the conditional statement is
provided so the condition is if the
number is greater than 0 if the provided
number is greater than 0 then the
control should enter the loop which is
this particular segment and execute the
statements present inside that
particular loop so here we have one
single statement that is a print
statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition fails then
what happens is that instead of entering
this particular code segment this
particular code segment the control will
skip and execute the next statement that
is another printf statement which we
have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block now since we
have provided a negative number the
second option should go ahead now let's
try to run this and see the output so
there you go as expected the program got
executed and we have only one statement
that is if condition is terminated
control is outside the block now let's
write otherwise let's just eliminate the
negative number and now check it again
there you go now you can see the program
got executed and now we have two print
statements you can see that the
condition here was true so the control
entered into the statement or the code
block and this particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printf
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first if condition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to zero if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else
else if this condition fails then what
you must do the control should avoid
entering this particular segment and it
should directly hit the next segment
where we have the else block which has
another statement which says the number
is negative so this is how the program
works so here we will be doing a little
modification over there instead of
taking an input which is previously
defined as it was in the previous
example where we had given -100
previously we are going to do it a
little differently this time we'll be
taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java.util.scanner
so this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program would
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user now
let's try to provide a negative number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that since we had given a negative
number the control did not enter this
particular code segment at all it
directly avoided to enter this code
segment and entered into the else block
and executed the statements present in
that particular else block which was a
simple print statement that had the
statement which read as the number is
negative now let's try to execute the
same program again and see what would be
the output so there you go now it's
asking for the input again now this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since we provided the number as a
positive number this condition was true
and this particular statement got
executed since one of the statements
executed there was no need for the else
block to be executed again so you can
see this particular code segment runs in
this way so once the condition is
checked so if the condition is true then
the true statement will be executed in
case if the conditions result is false
then the false statements will be
executed so you will be provided with
two options so one option for true
validity and another option for false
validity so this is how the if else
block works i hope you understood this
now with this let's continue with the
next type of conditional statement that
is the elsef ladder so on my screen you
can see there is a change of program we
have stepped into the next type of
conditional statement that is the lcf
ladder so basically everything will be
seen we will be provided with only one
condition so we will be checking the
validity of that particular condition so
if the provided condition is true then
the first one will be executed if it is
not then the second one will be executed
if the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed and the fourth and if
all the four fails then we will have one
last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
lc flatter works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and say the
output so basically we are going to
take an input from the user so we will
be entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else then one two three
four then we will be having an else
statement which says it's an invalid
input so the flow of this particular
relative statement is similar to the
switch statement having said that we
will also discuss something about switch
statement as well basically we'll try to
execute a program based on
switch statement and we'll also
understand the control flow of that
don't worry about it now let's quickly
execute this particular program first so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an input
let's select noodles that's how it works
we have the output nodals so the choice
is equal to is equals to one so the
first one was true so it executed the
first code segment and everything else
got suspended because this was not
necessary to be executed because the
condition was true over here and
according to that only this particular
statement was supposed to be executed so
that's how it works now let's switch
into the next conditional statement
which is the switch so you can see that
we have a program on my screen which is
based on switch case
so uh you can see that there is some
similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators so we
also have the default code segment over
here so this was what i was talking
about you can add a default code segment
in that particular program which is the
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there now
basically what happens in this
particular code segment is so we have
monday as the day one of a week tuesday
at the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on one two three four and so
on to seven and if you provide anything
else than one two seven you will be
provided with an message which says
invalid input so now let's try to
run this program and see the output so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now let's select
the weekend day so which would be
something between six and seven so six
is saturday and seven is sunday let's go
with seven so there you go sunday now
let's try to execute this program once
again and give a wrong input and see if
it works or not let's provide eight
there you go the program identified it
as a wrong input so it gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default code segment in switch case so
you can implement this in that
operator's program and check out how it
works can be considered as a homework
though not a problem now this is how the
switch case works so with this let's
move ahead into the next concept in our
java tutorial for today so the next
segment is about the loops so what are
loops
so conditional statements are
some statements which get executed based
on a condition if the condition is true
if not then that particular condition
will not be executed loops are a little
different from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement and you wanted
to execute that one single statement for
a particular number of times
so in that condition instead of writing
the same code segment for several number
of times you can just use a loop for
example consider that you wanted to
print numbers from 1 to 10. so the brute
force method or the simple or the first
method that fires to your mind is write
that print statement for 10 times that
is print 1 print 2 print 3 and so on to
print 10 but what if you had to print
100 numbers
okay doable you can write the same print
statement for 100 times but what if you
had to print thousand numbers
imagine 1 billion can you do 1 billion
print statements no right so in that
scenario you can use loops so you can
just write one condition
repeat this particular print statement
for 1 billion times then the interpreter
or the compiler will take care of that
so that's the reason why we use loops in
java so basically we have three loops in
every programming language that is the
for loop while loop and do while loop so
a loop statement in java execute a set
of statements until a specific condition
is satisfied so here the one billion
example so here you will start from the
zeroth count so that will be the counter
variable which counts the number of
repetitions and followed by the counter
variable you will be having the
condition so you will be having the
count of variable i i is less than or
equal to the number 1 billion so until
that you have to print this particular
statement and followed by that you will
be having the incremental decrement
operator in this case you need to use
the increment operator for the first
time once the print is done you will
increment the value to 2 and the loop
will be iterated once again so this will
continue the loop will iterate itself
until one two three four so on and until
it reaches one billionth number so
that's when the condition fails i is
greater than or equal to one billion so
that's when the condition fails the
condition was to be i should be less
than or equal to 1 billionth so when the
number increments above 1 billion then
the condition fails so the condition was
the number should be less than or equal
to billion but the number has exceeded
the billion so that's when the loop
terminates and executes the next
statement after the loop so i think this
was a little clear about the loop
workflow now to understand the loops in
a much more better way let's execute an
example for each one of these types of
loops so we have follow while open do
while loop let's execute the programs
for all of these three so you can see
that we have a program on my screen so
this particular program is based on for
loop so you can see that the code part
highlighted on my editor is the follow
so you can see int i is equals to 1 so
this is the counter variable so i is the
counter variable which stores a number
from where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose zero sometimes
one or the number of your choice so here
i've chosen the number one so after the
initialization part we have the
condition part so remember the one
billionth example we discussed before so
here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10. so this particular loop
segment will run until the condition
that is i value should be less than or
equal to 10 is satisfied once it turns
false the control will exit the for loop
so that's how it's designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator once the
condition is checked the control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator and it increments
the value of 1 to 2. so this is how the
loop works now let's try to execute this
program and see the output there you go
the program got successfully executed
and the output has been printed so
basically what was the statement to be
executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator here too
now in between the printf statements we
have the value of i so in the first
place i was equals to 1 once the
pre-increment was taken place the value
of i will be increased to 2. so there
you go you can see the number two over
there now in the second iteration we
print the value looped two times
similarly in the third iteration looped
three times so that's how it works until
the last iteration that is looped ten
times so once the condition is checked
here the control will enter into the
next part where the pre-increment takes
place so the pre-increment increments
the value of 10 to 11. now the control
will come back to the initialization
part here we have the new value for i
that is 11 now 11 will be checked
against the condition is 11 less than
or equal to 10
no right so the condition here fails
now the loop is terminated the control
will exit the loop so this is how the
for loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow for a better understanding
so in this particular program we are
going to print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having even numbers and odd numbers
for example consider that you have
provided the number as 5. so the numbers
in between 0 to 5 or 1 to 5 are 1 2 3 4
and 5. so the 4 is even number and apart
from 4 everything else are odd numbers
so odd numbers are the numbers which are
divisible by 1 or itself so now the sum
of odd numbers is 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3
is 6 6 plus 5 is 11 so that's how you
print the sum of odd numbers and the sum
of even numbers that is only four so
that's how the loop works here you have
the condition if else condition and out
of that if else condition you have the
for loop so this particular loop should
be running until a given number that
will be given by you so that's how the
program works now let's quickly execute
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed and now it's asking for an
input let's check out five itself now
you can see we have another program on
my screen which is basically based on
the same for loop so here we have the
for loop we will be providing an input
which is num and inside that we have
another condition that is the if else
loop so basically if loop is dedicated
to find out the even numbers and l slope
is dedicated to find out the odd numbers
now the whole motto of this particular
program is to find the sum of even
numbers and the sum of odd numbers
between 0 to the input number which you
provide for example consider if we
provide the number 5 as the input then
in between 0 to 5 we have odd numbers
and even numbers so the even numbers are
2 and 4 and the odd numbers are 1 3 and
5. so basically what happens here is we
are going to add up the numbers so the
sum of even numbers that is 2 and 4 six
and sum of odd numbers that is 5 plus 3
is 8 8 plus 1 is 9. so that's how it
should work now let's quickly try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for an input now let's enter 5
itself and see the output so there you
go the sum of even numbers up to 5 is 6
and the sum of odd numbers up to 5 is 9.
so this is how the program works now
apart from for loop we also have another
way to declare the same for loop so that
particular type of for loop is called as
the enhanced for loop or in some cases
it's also called as advanced for loop
let's see how the for loop is declared
in a different way so instead of using
the typical for loop which has the
initialization state then the condition
then the pre increment or post increment
or decrement kind of operations we
simply have declared the for and inside
that we have end arr which is the name
of the variable of array type and inside
that we have the array so our array
consists of 10 numbers followed from 1
to 10 and now this particular loop will
execute for 10 times or until all the
values in the array are printed so now
let's try to print this so there you go
the program got successfully executed
and we have all our values from 1 to 10
which were the input or the saved part
of the array now with this let's
continue with the next kind of loop that
happens to be the while loop so you can
see an example based on while loop on my
screen so basically everything is same
uh there is no much of a difference
between for loop and while loop but the
only difference is the keyword instead
of for we have a while over here so
so we have the while condition over here
which says i should be less than or
equal to num divided by 2 and if this
condition is true then the control
should enter into the conditional
statement
if
num modulus i is equal to equals to zero
flag is equals to true and prick so
basically the whole motto of this
program is to find out if the given
particular number is a prime number or
not now let's quickly try to run this
program and see the output now you can
see the program got successfully
executed let us try to provide a prime
number and see if the program could
identify it correctly as a prime number
or not there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number so that's how the while loop
works
now let's execute another program based
on while loop but this time we will
place the condition at the end of the
loop so yeah you guessed it right this
is do while loop the only difference
between while loop and do while loop is
that
before
the condition is checked in while loop
no statement is executed but it's
completely opposite when it comes to do
while loop first the program or the code
segment will be completely executed
after that the condition will be checked
surprising right let's check out the
practical part yeah we have our program
on my screen right now so
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here so what we are going to
do is we are conveying the compiler or
the interpreter to execute this
particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between while loop and while
loop so we have run the program
successfully and it got executed and we
were supposed to actually print the
values of i from 1 to 20 and they have
printed over here that's how it works
simple right choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
objects and classes in java this is a
part of our java tutorial series where
we will be covering everything you need
to know to master java let us look at
what we will cover today first we will
talk about objects and we will implement
two programs on intellij to learn about
objects then we will move on to classes
in java where we will see an advanced
program to learn classes more in depth
so what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object
the object dog has states and behaviors
we can have dogs with different breeds
sizes and colors these are considered as
the states of object dog on behavior
side dog has behavior like barking
eating and wagging tail so an object has
its own states and behaviors now let's
look at an example using java code there
are many platforms to run java program
so for this video i'll be using intellij
so let's create a new project let's name
it as project 1 and finish there we go
we have a new project with we have a
class with main and we have a main
function so the code that we write
should always be written in the main
function so let's create a new class to
understand how the object is used let's
name it as student we need variables so
that we can access the variables of this
class so i'm gonna use
student id with the integer type student
name
and student's age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created an object
as of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this i'll use id
and give a value similarly i'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
let's see what output will get
and there it is we have name
that's simply learn we have age and we
have id now let us see an example how we
can use multiple objects for a single
class so let's get started let's create
a new project and i'm gonna name it as
vehicles because i'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so i'm going to
use vehicles as a combined form and yes
here we have a class main and a function
main now i need two classes for this
program so i'm gonna create two classes
first i'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class i'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in cars first i need string
name
and i need the cost of the car so cost
can be in integer as well because i'm
gonna use dollar sign in that so i'm
gonna use string because of that so same
thing i'm gonna do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and i am going to name as car1
and yes we have created the first object
now to create the second object
similarly i am going to create five
objects of the class cars
and i'm gonna change the name for them
so i created five objects of the same
class so i'm gonna create five objects
of the bikes class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so i'm going to use
b1 till b5
and i'm going to name them to from b1 to
b5 so now i'm going to assign values to
the variables that i created in classes
bike and cars so first i'm gonna go with
cars and let's name it as lamborghini
similarly
car to ferrari
so i'm gonna use names of the cars that
are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car 3
i'm gonna name it as bugatti
similarly car 4
pagani and car 5.
now i'm gonna give names for bikes
i hope everyone will understand the
names that i give
b4
and b5
last one
yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000
same b2 so b1 goes for hale davidson b2
for ducati b3 for suzuki b4 for e cos
and b5 for yamaha i'm gonna assign
values for these values accordingly for
ducati 232 000
dollars
for suzuki 200 000
300 000
and the last one yamaha 500 000
now similarly i'm going to assign values
for
dot cost till card 5 dot cost
203 000
for
lambo i think i can copy paste these as
well
so
let's
copy paste a lot faster and easier to do
car 2 car 3
car 4 and car 5
we don't need this
as for car 2 let's take it as 252
000 and
let's make it it's 3 million
as per this let's keep it as
one million
four hundred thousand and lastly uh
let's see is 293 now that we have
assigned all the values for all this now
let's print it and get the value i'm
going to create a very simple program
but a very user friendly program so it
it's going to be interesting for you
guys so we are going to ask the users
what would they like either bikes or
cars so we need to give them the options
and our next program will be based on
the options that the user select not the
options we give as the command so let's
do it
let's give the options
one
[Music]
bikes
and two cars
i need to take the value that user gives
for this i'm gonna write this command
so i have not used scanner yet so let's
import
scanner
and let's create a object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
i'm using next int if the data type was
string then i would have used next line
so now that we have choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here i am giving options to the users so
that they can choose easily from number
one to five
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that i'm gonna ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice i'm gonna use one
more variable let's say n so i'm gonna
store n
if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
harley davidson then i'm gonna show the
cost of harley davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means ducati so we have
to show the rate of ducati or the cost
of ducati to the user
now similarly i'm going to do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and n is
equal to 5.
now i'm gonna do for n is equal to 4
and lastly n is equal to 5 that is a
last bike yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between 1 to 5. so for that i am
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and 5.
so now we have code for the bikes and
the same thing whatever the user selects
that he wants to find the car so for
that we have this the choice is equal to
is equal to 1 so the same thing we are
going to do for choice is equal to is
equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have 5 models
same names that i gave to variables i'm
gonna give this to here
second one ferrari
third book rt
fourth e cos
and the last one
posh
now we are going to ask the users their
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
i am going to use c
now if c is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of lamborghini that he puts the choice
as 1 so we're going to display this
message the cost of lamborghini
and we are going to use else if loop to
enter the next values for c from 1 to 5.
if c is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice
then we go for ecos
and the last one if user enters the
choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from one to five then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between
one to five now remember the first
choice that we wanted from user to enter
either bikes or cars so what if the user
do not enter either one or two so for
that we need one more else function to
tell the user that either enter one or
two
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus f10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program let's test this program now
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have five models harley
davidson ducati suzuki pagani and yamaha
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have a result the cost of
harley davidson is 130 000
so with this we have completed our code
and please feel free to type this code
in your own computer and try out all the
permutation and combinations that you
can with this program so with this let's
move on to classes and understand the
classes and their concept then we'll
have a new program on classes now let's
see what is a class a class is a
blueprint from which objects are created
a class describes state or behavior of
an object in this example dog is a class
the variables in this class are breed
and color the functions or methods of
the class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class
main now let's create some classes to do
code on
i'll create a new java class as cars
and then i'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so i'm gonna connect cars and bikes with
automobiles so that we can use that
program in maine and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles i need some variables
i'll take private double and let's say
fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string and brand now let's have
getters and setters for this so these
are used to get the value and set the
value for the variables inside the class
there we go
we have the getters and setters for it
now let's go to class cars
so public class cars extends automobiles
so in it i'm gonna create one more class
or a constructor
and i'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created
car has been created now the same thing
i'm gonna do with bikes let's go to
bikes and
i'm gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles this is because i can
inherit all the variables from the
automobiles class
so i created a constructor and i'm gonna
print a message
a new bike has been created
so i have created class cars bikes and
automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so i'm gonna start with the code
now it's a very simple code i'm gonna
first i'm gonna create
the variables or the objects of the
class with private
bikes bike so one is car and one is bike
both are objects for the classes so i'm
going to use these objects
bikes bike is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now i'm gonna run it
it'll take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that i typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes
so i'm going to bikes
so i'm going to create a new method or a
new function
public void kick for bike so i'm gonna
print message
the bike has been started with kick
bike has been started
with kick now the same thing i'm gonna
do with cars now how does a car start
with the key so i'm gonna make a
function public key and inside it i'm
gonna print the same message car has
been started with key i should write
void there to give the return value as
wide so let's print the message
car has been started
with key rotation let's write that as
well so in the main program i'm going to
use objects to use those functions and
let's see what changes they'll do to our
program
pike dot cake and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go first we used to have
this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked those functions and methods
that are there in class cars and bikes
so if i write bike dot key
or
car dot kick
this won't work
this is because key is not a method of
bike or kick is not a method of car so
that's why i gave private static for the
functions
so if i execute it these are the error
messages that i'll get cannot find the
symbol method kick or method key
what is an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object-oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract class or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirement so abstract class in java is
considered as a template of methods and
variables which are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly
now moving ahead we will next learn the
important features of abstract classes
so the first one is template
the main reason programmers prefer to
use abstract methods is because they act
as a predefined template for any future
specific class that you might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not the least
dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overridden method is resolved at runtime
this is how java implements runtime
polymorphism
when an overridden method is called by
reference
java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
all right let us go through the rules
one by one as mentioned below
the first one is
the keyword abstract is mandatory to
declare an abstract class followed by
that the next rule says that abstract
clauses cannot be instantiated directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods
next an abstract class
may also include non-abstract methods
it's not mandatory that an abstract
class should only include abstract
methods so the last rule says that an
abstract class
can include constructors and static
methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class
then after that
we declare the name of our class
the name of the class is up to the
user's choice
i have named my class as simply learn as
shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now i have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
choice as you can see i have used
simplylearn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstractlast method
the next one is by using an interface
method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary
between the method and the class
implementing it in java we use interface
to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax
to use an interface to achieve
abstraction in java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface followed by
that we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example i have named my class
as simply learn as shown below
as discussed earlier interface acts just
as a container that stores only the
signatures of the method we cannot have
a complete method defined inside it all
we can do is just declare an interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface
let us look into some example programs
based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
eclipse ide now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created
and inside the project simply learn we
have the source file and right clicking
the source file will give us a drop box
where you can just select new and inside
new you can select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class
and the name of this particular class
will be person
which will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person
and
this person class will be inherited by
the employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the run option
and select the first one that is java
application
now you can see we have the employee
name pavitra
and the gender is female and the
employee has logged in successfully so
these are the details which we were
expecting to be presented on the output
console
now moving ahead we shall execute our
next example which will be based on
students so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely raju pranita and punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student is being declared using the
keyword abstract and inside that we have
an abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are
raju pranita and punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract class named
loan and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes andra
bank bank of baroda idbc bank state bank
of india which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword
while we declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface
on the other hand when we declare an
abstract class we use the keyword
abstract
followed by that the second difference
is
when you use an interface the subclasses
basically implement an interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both is
interface is capable to support multiple
inheritance whereas on the other hand
abstract classes are not capable to
support multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes
the abstract classes avoid code
duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage
and finally the last advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract losses
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class and java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is
object relational impedance mismatch in
the case of rdbms and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of frameworks like
hibernate
so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield prevents
the data from being accessed by the code
outside this shield as you can see
variables and methods are defined inside
one class like a capsule
now the question is why do we need
encapsulation the main reasons are first
better control of class attributes and
methods second class attributes can be
made read-only or only third it makes
java code very flexible this means the
programmer can change one part of the
code without affecting other parts apart
from these encapsulation is mainly used
to protect data and increase security of
the code as you can see to protect the
data variables must be private and they
can only be accessed through methods now
let's see java code for encapsulation to
understand the concept better so now
let's create a new project
next
next and i'm gonna name it as
ncap one
so here we have a main class we can
write the code here so before i take the
code let me create a new class
right click new java class
and i'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employ using employee
name id and salary so in this class let
me create variables
first string name
then
[Music]
integer id
and then in salary
so i can easily use these variables in a
main program by creating object of the
class so let me just create the object
employee e is equal to new employee
now i can use e dot id name or salary
anything i need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured
so for that i'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so i
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if i write id
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see id has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need
getters and setters that are normally
methods that are used for these so right
click
generate
and here you can see getters and setters
so just select all of them
and okay
so now we can use these methods instead
of direct using the variables so we can
get in the starting then set then get
and again set so likewise it goes like
this
so now we have set here so
if i want to declare variable and if i
want to put some value inside my
variable so how can i do that
here you can see get id or get salary so
if i go for get id sorry if i go for e
dot set id and i set it as 6
so
this shows no error this means we can
use methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first i'm gonna
set everything
and lastly e dot
set salary let's get it as 30 000
maybe in dollars or maybe in rupees
let's just set it as 30 000 for now
so how i'm gonna print it for this i'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and e dot not set name but this time i'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that i have
given so in this case that's simply
learn
and next will be id
and e dot get id
and lastly
salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn id
6 and salary is 30 000
so i hope you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we use getters and setters that are
inbuilt functions for intellij or
netbeans or eclipse so with this let's
move on to our next program to
understand it better and how we can
manipulate these variables or methods
using program so again let's create a
new project
and this time i'm gonna name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program
now this time i'm gonna use an example
of cars so let me just create a new
class and i'm gonna name it as cars
so in this again i'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first i'm gonna get string name
then private string
price
that means price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but i'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so i'm gonna
create a constructor for the class cars
and inside i'm gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string price
and string top speed
and i'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it
so similarly i'm gonna give it as this
dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to
top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate
getter and setter
select all and ok
this is a great feature that we have in
java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first i'll
create object of the class cars
and inside this i'm gonna give arguments
or inside this i'm gonna give values
that i use in constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or c dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as bmw
the second thing was price so i'm going
to give it as 30 000
and the third one was top speed so top
speed i'm gonna give it as
200 kilometer per hour so we have
assigned all the values to the variables
and we have created object as well all
in the same line so this is another way
of creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private
so if i try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and c dot
so this time i'm gonna give get name so
it automatically gets the value that i
assigned to the variables through
getters and setters
after that price
price c dot price get price
and in the end
top speed
c dot get top speed
so if i print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name bmw price
and even the top speed now if i give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go
name bmw price 30 000 and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any getters or setters so in this
method we used only getters to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them
now for this again i can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is
so c dot set price
so price i'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand dollars
and c dot set top speed let me increase
it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that i'm so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old i'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if i print these values i'm just
going to copy paste it
so now if i print it let's execute it
and here you go
first we have name price and top speed
then stats after updations that means
after we set the value the value gets
overwritten on the variables and now we
have a new price and top speed and all
the details so this is how you can
manipulate variables or values inside
the variables
what is inheritance
there are two other key terms which are
not going to be in this agenda but you
should also
when you get to them make sure you
bundle them together as you're
understanding these structures and
that's the abstract class and the
polymorphism
so what is inheritance
inheritance is an act through which a
new class gets created by acquiring the
variables and methods defined in the
previous parent class
so we look at what is inheritance we can
take an example of say food we have
veggies noodles fruits
where food is the parent and your
veggies your noodles and fruits are all
subclasses of that they're all kind of
children of food
why do we need inheritance
we implement inheritance for multiple of
reasons like creating a possibility to
add or remove features
to reduce the code length as we reuse
the code
more comfortable to develop and maintain
the project
and so if we start looking at let's say
we have a cell phone we make calls we
have our sms texting our communication
on our phone we have our media we also
had a browser on there because now we
have a smartphone
and we look at that we have our phone
set up and then we have our
full smartphone media call sms and
browser and we start to kind of link
these instead of making them separate we
can have the call and the text
and then we can have them inherit we can
actually create a media that inherits
their quality so now you can texture
media now you can use the browser as
part of your call scenario
and i would even add one more example in
here and that is that all programming
languages that are object based
are built on inheritance
java python c plus plus so this concept
of building an object and then that
object then is inherited by everything
underneath of it is important to
understand even in these most even as
we're looking at more
specific cases
so take a look at the components of
inheritance
and the most important two components in
inheritance the two major components
that are mentioned are parent class or
the super class in the child class or
the sub class
and to see this let's go ahead and
jump into eclipse and take a look at
what the actual code looks like
so the first thing i want to do is go
ahead and add in a new
package
and we're going to go ahead and call
this package
inheritance because that's what we're
working with
oops
give me a default java tutorial in there
inheritance finish
and i started off with the java
tutorials just a um
went in and created a new project and
made sure it was java based
so we have our package inheritance right
here we're going to go and add in a new
class
and we'll go ahead and call this class
machine
now one of the standards when you're
creating classes to capitalize the first
letter so always remember to do that
in some places people like to have the
whole word capitalized it really depends
on who you're working with
but it is kind of if it starts with a
capital letter it's probably a class
and so once we have our inheritance we
have our public class machine
let's go ahead and give it a little bit
underneath there to do something and
we'll start with
a
protected
string brand
and so whatever machine we're working
with uh these particular machines are
going to be
um we'll call them it'll be a samsung
free uh
they get some free vocab free marketing
right there for samsung
so samsung machines
and we wanted to do something so let's
go ahead and put a procedure in there
and we'll make it public
void because it's not going to return
anything
and we'll call this
wash i guess they're all wash machines
there we go there's our brackets a
little trouble finding the bracket on
there and let's just have it during this
we'll just have it do a quick uh print
line
and we'll say um
initiating
cycle
there and then of course our semicolon
on the end
all right so now we have a public class
machine and we're going to get into
where we start working with the actual
inheritance
you can create an object with this
machine we haven't done anything special
to it it's like any other
class you might create in the java
language and we've added in public
void wash a procedure with no return
that's what the void means
and it's going to print out and so let's
go ahead and create another
class in here
new
class
and this one's going to be washing
machine
washing
machine
and
we'll go ahead and hit finish on here
and we come into our washing machine
this opened up a nice new tab for us
and we might have a private
string
model name
and we'll change this to model type
model type equals
so the type of machine is is a top load
washing machine
so we have a samsung is the main type of
machines we're looking at we have top
loader or top loading washing machine
and then we're going to add up here
extends
machine
and so this is the the key code we're
going to look for because we want this
to have the properties of the machine
so this comes in and says whatever is in
machine we now also have in our washing
machine
and then of course if we're going to do
all this we need to actually be able to
run it and if we're going to do that we
want to go ahead and add in the public
static
void main reserved
keywords there and this is just your
standard main
startup you have your string of
arguments
there we go
and of course our bracket
and then in here
we're going to take and create a washing
machine object
and so here's our wash machine
it's of course the type washing machine
and it's going to equal a new
washing machine so we're initiating a
new object in here there we go
and then we want to do something
and if we're going to have it do
something we wanted to go ahead
let's see what happens we have wash
remember our key word up there was
washing machine dot
wash
and where did that come from well if you
go back into machine
here it is public void wash there's the
procedure
and it's coming into the washing machine
and this is inherited
that way we don't have to retype that
every time we have a washing machine
this could be washing machine
maybe the next one is
i don't know different kind of washing
machines i'm not an expert on washing
machines
we have to do a wash
and then specific to the washing machine
in here
we also have
the type
and so we can come back up here or brand
so we can come up down here we can go
system
dot
print line
wash
machine dot
brand
plus
a little dash in there
plus
and then we're going to go ahead and we
have our wash
machine
dot
model type
that model type we put in there
so the brand where does the brand come
from the brands coming from our machine
we have our protected string which is
going to be samsung
and then we have our washing machine
which has the model type which is a top
load machine
and if we go ahead and run this
after of course we make sure we have
that semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle is printed out
from machine and then the samsung top
load washing machine is the second
printout line here
and so when we have our wash print out
here also the wash machine wash
this initiating cycle and then we have
that's where that printout comes from we
can go back up here to machine you can
see right here initiating cycle
and then we flip back over to the
washing machine we print out wash
machine dot brand
which is the machine class and then wash
machine dot model type which is
underneath the washing machine
so let's go over all that let's take a
look and see what we're talking about
here
so we saw in the code the extends
keyword
the term extends is a pretty defined
keyword in java that allows you to
create a new child class by deriving the
variables and methods from the parent
class to reduce code length and improve
the performance
and we see that right up here in our
public class washing machine extends
machine
so the next key thing to talk about is
access modifiers
and i kind of breezed over them when i
put together the code but we'll dig in
there a little deeper
we talk about axis modifiers
there's four different words you really
need to know and that's default
public protected and private
and i'm going to tell you right now
default equals public
so what is default default access
modifier is set implicitly
whenever you declare a class without a
specific access modifier by default the
access of a class or method when
declared without a specific access
modifier becomes available to any other
method or class within the same package
and in java the default is public
so public a certain class can be
declared as public by using the keyword
public any class or method when declared
as public becomes available to any class
or method declared in the same package
but if a different method or class needs
it it should be imported
and then we have protected a certain
class is declared protected by using the
keyword protected this provides access
to the methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and then private a certain class is
declared protected by using the keyword
private
this provides the ultimate protection to
the data members and the methods of the
private class this procedure is
implemented by class to encapsulate the
method and members
so uh we'll take a little we're actually
going to do a different example in here
but i do like this underneath the
washing machine
you can see right here we have put in
private a private string
what this means is that only washing
machine can access that private string
where if you have protected the children
can access it
so a protected screen if you're
underneath a machine up here we have
protected
so that when i create the washing
machine and extend machine
i can still access it but if i create a
sub
class of washing machine and i mark it
as private that subclass is not going to
be able to access it and so it has to do
with what layers of accessing
think of this as a big team project
you create something do you really want
that to cascade down to the next class
or who do you want to have access to
that
let's go a little deeper to really bring
this home because it's really important
to understand this terminology
let's go ahead and start a new class
here and we're just going to call this
particular class
summation
and go ahead and create that finish
and so our summation class it's going to
be uh pretty simple in here uh we'll go
ahead and do
uh
public
so anything but he can access it just
remember here's our public on there
and then we'll just do a
anti-jerks that's what it's going to
return as an integer
we're going to call it add
and we're going to put integer x comma
integer y
and
then we'll just return x plus y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs they both have to
be integers and we're going to return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so real simple class right there
and if we're going to have a summation
let's go ahead and create a new class
we'll call this one child
and in our new
child class
we're going to go ahead and keep this
simple and we're just going to have our
public static main
we're going to have our summation a
equals new summation
and then system out print line a dot add
100 plus 200.
pretty straightforward everything's
public in here
oops okay
there's our running and we see that
answer is 300.
so this is public if you remember
correctly we're talking about public
and so when we use the public keyword
any class or method when declared as
public becomes available to any class or
method declared in the same package
but if in a different method or class
needs it it should be imported
so here we go it's that's our public
setup it's just open to everybody
well everybody that's under the package
inheritance so whoever's using that
package can now use the this particular
child
and let's go ahead and add a new class
in and this time we're going to do a
parent class
i'll just put that right in there
and we come in with our parent class you
can see right here the parent class
itself is public but what we want to do
underneath the parent class is we want
to create a protected
void because we're not returning
anything and print so we're going to do
the print there
and this protected print let's go and
put our brackets in there and we'll do
just a simple uh print line hello world
and once we have the
print hello world we want to go ahead
and add a child class to this
and let's see we already well we had the
child class when it took it out a second
ago so we'll go ahead and put that back
in uh here's our child class
and for this child of class we wanted to
go ahead and extend the parent
so inheritance there's our extend on
there oops let me type that
all right extends parent so now the
child class is part of the parent class
and we'll go ahead and put our main in
there so that it will run it and execute
it and we'll create our child x
equals new
child class
go ahead and assign our variable x and
initiate it and then we'll do just the
print and see what happens here so
here's our print statement
and we'll go ahead and run this and
compile our child on there
and when it comes in there you see it
says print hello world and so the parent
has marked this as protected so it's
protected from
objects that are not inheriting it but
the child can still access that
information and print it on there
so here's protected this provides access
to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and a lot of programming that's usually
where you end up is doing a lot of stuff
that is um underneath your parent
that is protected you either make them
public or protected a lot of people are
sloppy and just make them public but
most of stuff you want to make sure it's
protected and then we finally have our
private and i'm going to go back here to
our child and we're going to
run this
and it's going to come up and say
proceed with launch errors in setup and
then it's going to give us an exception
thread main compilation error the method
print from the type parent is not
visible
and that's because unless you actually
initiate the parent
you're not going to see this code
because it's private it's only private
to the public to the parent class so
even if i extend it in child
it will not be available and that again
protects it that means it's something
that you don't want to inherit and
cascade down because maybe it is a piece
of code that is going to be changed and
so you don't want all the children to
crash every time you make a change to it
so with private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
in the methods of the private class
this procedure is implemented by class
to encapsulate the methods and members
so very important we have private and we
have protected
and we have public the more access you
want other pieces of the software code
to have and other programmers they have
the more public you want to make it and
of course the default is public
now one of the common workarounds for
this because you only have protected
data but you still want it to be used by
the subclasses
is to create what they call like a get
or a and we'll do it up here we'll go
ahead and do a
private
integer x equals five
and then instead of
on your inheritance instead of having it
uh
call it from
the child we might have a get thing or a
get get thing
we might have a public
return an integer
and we might have it say get x
and this simply just return
x
and what this means is that when we have
something simple like this where it just
doesn't return x i can go back into my
child here
and instead of print x we'll do
x dot
get x
and we'll go ahead and print this out
or you know something simple with that
we'll go ahead and do a
system print line on this
and when we run this
you'll see it come up it's going to
recompile and we get our five what's
happening here is now i've created
underneath the parent
private information you don't know
what's going on with it it's protected
uh you might have a procedure that's
protected in this case we had the print
procedure and then we access it from the
public and this could have easily have
been instead of
maybe we'll just call it
public
void
public print
kind of a goofy way of doing the code
there we go and then it could go in here
and access our
print
and so we can actually still access this
print variable up here by wrapping it in
kind of a get or a
public function this allows us to
protect whatever code is going on in the
parent class so it can't be messed up it
can't be accessed indirectly it has to
go through the right processes and so
when we get to the child on here
the child can then still has the public
processes but all the other information
isn't is protected and is private it's
really important to remember that
private right there
brings us to super keyword
and we talk about the super keyword uh
super keyword eliminates the confusion
between parent class method and sub
class method
super keyword is implemented to access a
method or constructor that is defined in
the parent class
so back in eclipse we'll go under parent
and we'll take this we're going to
take the private out of there so now we
have an integer five
and we'll go ahead and just remove the
print because we're not gonna do that in
the parent
oops and the public
there we go
and so let's create a parent that just
has one piece of information it has an
integer x equals 5.
and then we're going to go to the child
and let's go ahead and add in here
integer
x equals 10.
and these are by default they're public
we haven't set anything on here telling
it what it is
and so what i'd like to do is we'd like
to go ahead and create
a
one more thing there we go create a
procedure here
and we'll just call this void capital
print
this is going to be a system out print
line and this is what i want you to
notice is we're going to print out x
and super x
so we have the child class x and we have
the parent class super x
and if we come down here
and we do x
dot
print
don't forget my semicolon
add a couple spaces in here to make it
uh look nicer when we print it and we'll
go ahead and run this
and you can see that the child class
prints 10 and the parent class is 5.
and so this way you can actually store
different information depending on what
it is you're working on and what you're
doing and that's where this super comes
in you can see right here where the
super
underneath the class
and the print module
now you can't just put it in down here
under print
let me explore what that looks like if i
just take this and i go ahead and
highlight it
and let's say i wanted to just instead
of doing x print
it's going to come up right here right
off the bat you see the super dot x i
can do x dot super dot x and it's still
going to give me an error right here it
has to be underneath a procedure in the
actual class and not under the main
this brings us to types of inheritance
and there's four main types
we have single inheritance which we've
already pretty much looked at but we'll
go back over
we have multi-level inheritance we have
hierarchical inheritance and hybrid
inheritance
let's go ahead and just start with the
single inheritance single inheritance
consists of one parent class and one
child class here child class inherits
parent class methods and data members
and let's go ahead and create a new
class up here just to change it up and
keep it interesting new
class and we'll call this one student
and under the student
then we'll have a simple setup we'll
just do an enrolled and i'll say
enrolled in simply learn there we go so
there's our
class student
and then we'll create another class
we'll do it as a because we have our
student our base student
and then we'll call this one
new
class
and we'll call this one
computers there we go so here's a rolled
finish
and four computers let's go ahead and
put in a print line here
and we'll put down
studying computers
and we want to go ahead and do the
extends extends
student so it's a student studying
computer subclass computers
and this would all look familiar because
we've been doing this for
you know a lot of the other setups this
is your basic inheritance
and we'll change that from enrolled to
studies
and then let's go ahead and put a main
in here so we can actually run it
and we have our p enrolled which comes
from our
parent class and our p studies which
comes from the
child or the
one that inheritance hit the extends for
student and let's go ahead and run that
there we go run
and you can say enrolled in simply learn
studying computers
and then we can go on to the next setup
and this is where we look at multi-level
inheritance
there's also a parent child inheritance
relation but the difference is the child
class is inherited by another child
class
this is the basic structure of most
programming languages right here you
have an object you have all the
different things under the object and it
gets all the way down to whether it's an
array you're working with whether even a
class is a sub child that goes all the
way up to the object and we can simply
do that in our code in eclipse
and we'll just go ahead and add a new
class in there we'll call this one
java there we go
oops
java
and under java we want to go ahead and
oh create some of the similar stuff and
then i want to go back to my student i
took out the main and student just
because i don't want it to run the main
in there
and in here we're going to have system
out
we have instead of studying computers
focus
on java which is what we're doing right
now
and maybe we'll call this classroom and
then we can come down here and we have
our p equals new computers well instead
of new computers we want our java
and it's going to be a java object
and we need to put our extends in up
here
extends in this case we came from
computers
so there's our initial thing and then we
have our last print in here
and of course if we run this now we'll
see that it should if i did everything
correctly come up and say enrolled in
simply learn studying computers focus on
java and we have the enrolled which is
the parent to computers
and then we have under computers
we have
student then computers and then java and
so each one of these classes just
cascades all the way down and this is
your multi-level
from your class a to class b to class c
and if you can have multi-level
inheritance we can also have a higher
archaeal inheritance where your
parent-child relationship the only
difference is here multiple child
classes inhere from one parent class
and that is pretty uh we'll do another
class here
if you remember correctly we had
student computers
maybe from student we'll have instead of
computers we'll have
project management
project
management so you're studying your idol
and
all your other classes in there for
cascade and for
doing agile programming and in here we
can do that it's just the same as we did
before
we just have a second child coming in
from here and so this would go ahead and
extend extends
extends
student
and of course whatever subcategory you
have one in here for running this
and so for here we'd have like our void
studies in this case instead of studying
computers
uh we're studying project management
project
management one of the other wonderful
classes that is taught
from the simply learn team
and we're going to run that and you can
see right here we have computers oops of
course
instead of computers i meant to do
project
management there we go and we have to
also initiate it as a new
and then when we run here we can see
this uh we're enrolled in simply learn
and we're studying project management
and then finally there is the um
the hybrid the name itself explains it
to us
the hybrid inheritance can be a
combination of any of the three types of
inheritance supported in java
and so maybe we already saw that because
we have
our a and our b
if we flip back on over to our
eclipse
we have our student our student now has
a computer's
project management so there's our
hierarchy all and then they're mixed
because we also have the java which is
an extension of the computer and so we
have multiple layers there
so one of the issues that comes up with
inheritance in classes is what they call
the diamond problem
and in the diamond problem the java
programming language does not support
multiple inheritance as it ends up with
serious ambiguity
and that is where we have d which
inherits from both b and c
which might both inherit from a
this is the diamond factor because as
you start tracking your supers going up
which one are you actually looking at b
or c or a
and that's why they call this a diamond
problem it comes up more than you would
think you get very complicated
structures and you realize oh i need to
have
both sets of instructions come down to
whatever i'm working on and you can see
where that can become a problem
let us take a look at is a relation and
has a relation now these i mean their
vocabulary but they're more of a concept
understanding how things fit together
and so we talk about is a relation when
a class inherits methods and members
from a different class then the
relationship is said to be
is a relation examples orange is a fruit
and oh let's just jump back on over here
and we'll make a
new
class
and we'll call this class customer
so we're going to have our customers
oops
there we go if i can remember how to
type
so we have a class customer and i've
gone ahead and our team in the back went
ahead and prepped this for us
let's just take a quick look though we
got public string name so it's accessed
publicly if you leave this out it'll
automatically be public because that's
the default and then we have our
customer and the string which is a name
and a string as a city and then when you
do a customer and you send it the name
in the city it will do this name equals
name and this city equals city we could
have easily done this private we have a
call-in to it to create it so it
wouldn't really matter too much whether
we did it private or
public i would actually be more likely
to do it private
and for this
example we'll go ahead and create
another class and we'll call this thor
we'll have our store class we have
customers and we have a store
and then we'll go ahead and
set up in here and this time we did do a
private we're going to create a list of
customer customers
and then the store list coming down and
then this customer customers and public
list customers
a quick look at this is we did make this
one private
which is nice because now it can't be
accessed externally except from store
and then store has the public list
customers so we can send it a list of
customers and then it go ahead and
returns the customers from that list
and then we add it to the store
it sets the customers in the store this
dot customers equals customers
one of the reasons we have the error
lines in here is i haven't compiled it
so it doesn't see the customers are part
of our package
and we'll get to that in just a moment
here
and then let's go ahead and create
another class we'll call this is a
relation
since that's what we're working on
and here's our is a relation set up
and we're just going to put this as the
main so you have your main in there
and then we went ahead and prepared
a series of customers
and we'll just call that customer c1
equals a new customer customer c2 equals
a new customer and we're just creating a
list here that's all we're doing
and if we're going to have a list then
we need to go ahead and create a list of
customers
and
we'll just do that with a simple list
set up
and then we got to add those customers
into the list so let's go ahead and do
that
so breaking this down we have a customer
uh one which is raju
bangalore shiva hyper bad
sachin mumbai and so on and then we just
created a list of customers a new array
of lists and then we add in each of
those customers so now we have a nice
list of all our different customers in
here
and then we want to go ahead and
create our
store
and we'll put in store and it'll be a
fruit smoothies franchise i put down
fruit smoothies french
maybe that's not a good abbreviation you
might think it's a french instead of
franchise
there'll be a new store
and then we have our new store which is
um
in this case
we're going to put in that new store
customers and if you remember we went
back here into store let me just flip
back on over there
it's going to take that list of
customers
and put that into this customer so now
the private list is going to equal that
list of customers
and then of course we can come in here
and we do public list it's going to
return that list of customers so we have
public assets here and this store you
can add public at the beginning
we'll go ahead and do that just to make
it clear is it public
is what's going to run on there and
let's go back into our is a relation
and
back to store i'm going to go ahead and
just change this to customer list
so here's our list customer list and
it's going to return
the customers from this selection from
our private variable
as we come into here
we can come down here and we'll go ahead
and
put that in there
we'll do a loop on this we'll have a
list customer and we're going to create
a list of our customers from our fruit
smoothies franchise
and we'll get the customer list from
there
and then for a customer in the um in our
for a customer cst in customer
we're going to just print that name out
there
now at this point if you have
an error showing up here under list
and also underneath the array list
depending on how you did your install
you might have to go ahead and import
those your arraylist from your java
utility not a big deal
and then once we go ahead and we have
this all set up
you'll see here the compiler goes
through and then we have the name of the
customer
the city and then it just lists the
customers going down here
so when we talk about our relationship
of our fruit smoothies franchise and
customers the customers
they are
a relationship directly to the french
smoothies franchise
now the second idea is it has a relation
and let's go ahead and take a look at
that and see how that differs
and we'll go ahead and create a
oh let's see we had customers so let's
do um
and we'll call this one
we're doing with smoothies so we'll have
flavors
our favorite we'll do favorite flavors
favorite
flavors for class very strange class
and let's see in favorite flavors we'll
go ahead and give it a couple things to
look at we'll have a private
string and a name
and then we'll have a public
string
um
get flavor
there we go and that's just going to
return
uh return
we'll just have that return the name of
the flavor
there we go and then we want to go ahead
and create
one more class and this class would call
has a relation
and i'm hoping you're guessing where
we're going with this let's go and put
some code in here to make it work
and let's go back to our favorite
flavors and put in a constructor so that
we can load the flavors
and then return this name so we can
return the flavors we'll go back into
has a relation
and let's just create a customer we'll
call it cust
our new customer is toby marshall from
mumbai and our favorite flavors are
strawberry banana and peanut butter i
don't know it's a strange concoction
and then we run a print line we're going
to print the customer name from
customers and the flavors get flavor
and so when we're looking at this what i
want you to be aware of is that
neither the flavors
nor the customer are in the same class
they're not it's not an actual
relationship but they have a
relationship because we have toby who
happens to like strawberry and peanut
butter
and if you remember just a quick note we
were looking at the diamond problem
you can create a class that then has
these two subclasses in
and that's how you go around the diamond
problem is you don't inherit but you
create classes inside the class you're
working with
what is polymorphism
according to chemistry the term
polymorphism can be defined as the
ability of any element or compound to
exist in multiple crystalline forms this
is called polymorphism for example if
you have the carbon atom you can come
out in different forms in coal graphite
and diamond
what is polymorphism in java
similarly in the terms of java
programming language polymorphism is
defined as the ability of any object in
clat in a class
to perform a particular task in multiple
methods
this is known as polymorphism in java
we're going to open up our eclipse
editor and we're going to do some animal
sounds with cows cats and dogs just kind
of a fun almost kids-like
example of polymorphism and you can see
i already have my inheritance in here
let's go ahead and create a new
uh package
and we'll call this polymorphism
just to keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're going to go ahead and add a
class in
and if you were doing um
an abstract class we could label it as
abstract we're not going to directly
access it and we'll call it animal
sounds maybe we will we'll see how we
load the
program up but we'll call this animal
sounds
and let's create a public
it's not going to return anything but
we'll call it sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a
system out print
and with our system out print line we'll
just have it say animals
make different
sounds
there we go
so yeah it's really simple and
straightforward we're just gonna have it
print something out
and if we're gonna do that let's go
ahead and just um a good thing i didn't
make it abstract let's go ahead and just
test it out and see what it looks like
and we'll do
oh we'll call it animal main animal
maine
and in here let's go ahead and test out
what we just put together
uh we'll do our static void main so it's
going to run on here and we'll create
our animal
sounds
we'll call it animal so we don't know
what kind of animal this is we'll call
it new animal
sounds
and we'll just take that animal
um and i like to
put it in capitalize but usually we like
to do this lower case
there we go
and we'll just have our
animal
dot
sound
and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
comes out
we can see here animals make different
sounds okay that's not too exciting
uh so let's jump in there and let's say
we have um in this case we're going to
add in a couple of different animals
we'll add in a
oh let's start with a
cow yeah why not a cow
so we'll have our cow in here we'll go
ahead and click ok
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually
makes us you know a very clear noise so
we'll go ahead and give the cow a sound
and we'll have the cow um say moo moo
and the cow is going to
extend
there's our um
and we'll put in our extends animal
sounds and then i want to go back here
to our animal main
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal main we want to do
cow
cow
equals
new
cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds there we go
and we run this
you can see it comes out here and it
says the cow says moo moo
so if we go back to cal we're just going
to do this real quick
and let's say
we just take this out of here the public
void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal main and run that
recompiles animals make different sounds
because it doesn't know what sound a cow
makes
so this is really central to
polymorphism is we're taking something
going on in the um
in one setup that we've brought in and
extended from our animal sounds and
we've changed it to the cow says moo moo
and we can also add in multiple animals
in here we'll go ahead and just add in
one more animal we'll call this one
we'll do a dog why not
uh so here comes in our dog
and of course we want the dog
to actually say something
and we'll have the dog uh go bow wow and
then we'll go back to our animal main we
have to create a dog
and we'll say cow
simply dog dog uppercase for the class
lowercase for the actual object
and then of course we need the dog
to make a sound so we'll go down here
and go dog dot
sound
and when we run this as you expect the
it's going to compile it there we go
animals making different sounds the cow
says moo moo the dog says bow wow
characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member of method in a class with
different types
which we'll cover briefly in a minute
polymorphism supports implicit type
conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism runtime
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time thus
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time
in method overloading in java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared
we'll now execute a program based on the
functionality of additional operator in
a different situation and let's flip
back on over to our eclipse
so in here i'm going to go back under
the dog
and let me just highlight this
and we're going to do the same thing so
you see right here it says public void
sound so this is identical public void
sound
but instead of sending nothing we're
going to send it a string we're going to
call it angry
now at this point
you should note that what if it's a
happy dog
i would have to add an if then if the
string angry said happy then we'd print
happy or something else
but we're just keeping it simple so
we've entered another sound identical to
the first but we've added string angry
to it and this one's going to print out
the dog says growl growl now if we go
back to our animal mane and here's our
dog same dog
same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here
and we put that string in here we'll go
ahead and just call it angry it doesn't
really matter what string you put in
here because we haven't sorted out what
the string means
for now it just says growl growl it's
going to recompile it so remember this
is a polymorphism during compile time
and here we have it the dog says growl
growl the dog says bow wow and then the
angry dog says growl growl so there is
another
thing called operator overloading
operator overloading is not supported in
java the authors of java wanted to keep
the language less complicated
explaining operator overloading it
basically is a way of bundling
operations into the call statement and
user procedures it's so that it looks
like a math on a paper you have a plus
add b plus c kind of thing and it's all
wrapped up in your call to another
statement this just gets confusing it
really isn't necessary so the driver
developers decided not to put it in
there so runtime polymorphism in java
programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage
here the overriding method gets resolved
in execution
so far we've talked about compile time
polymorphism as you saw in the program
we just wrote when it's compiling it
does the extend and figures out which
overload method to use on there
in run time polymorphism method
overriding in java the method overriding
is a procedure where child class is
allowed to implement a specific class
that is already provided in the parent
class
for run time compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go ahead and
introduce the super key word now from
inheritance you should remember that we
can
look at super from before but we're
going to use it slightly different it's
kind of doing the same thing as when we
did the inheritance but we're doing like
what they call an override during run
time so the term super is predefined
keyword in java that is used to refer
the immediate parent class object or
method defined in the program in this
procedure whenever you create an
instance of subclass then automatically
an instance a parent class is also
created that will be implicitly referred
by the super reference variable
so going back into our animal sounds
let's go in here to dog
and if we add a super
dot
sound
in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is because we
extends the dog extends animal sounds
and so here's our super dot sound and if
we go ahead and we'll run and compile
this
and you can see here that it comes down
and says the dog says growl growl
because that's what we had it system out
print line to
and then the super animals make
different sounds and so if we go back to
our animal mane
this is what it's calling right here
it's going back into sound under the
animal mains and it's printing out or
doing whatever it does here at this
point we usually have it returned
something so you can look up whatever
the original class was using
so getting back to
these two setups whether you're using
the super to use a runtime polymorphism
because that's what's happening during
run time versus compile time
polymorphism during compile time
polymorphism method call is handled by
the compiler itself so the programs
maybe take a second more to compile but
it runs faster in the runtime the method
call cannot be handled by compiler in
the execution stage so if you have any
errors it's not going to show up either
during the compile time we have compile
time polymorphism is less flexible as it
needs handle all method calls in compile
time so you really in runtime
polymorphism your it exhibits higher
flexibility as a method call gets
handled at runtime coming in the
execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less
that's what i was just talking about it
compiles it so the compiling takes maybe
a little bit more but if you're
executing the same program over and over
and over again once it's distributed
it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script a
thousand times suddenly that 0.01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
thousand iterations uh then with the
compile-time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in runtime integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in runtime again that's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre-mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overriding
advantages of polymorphism programmers
code can be reused via polymorphism uh
number one goal of a programmer is to
reuse the code as much as possible so
you're not reinventing the will over and
over again
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities
and some of the disadvantages of
polymorphism that can come up is that
polymorphism ends up raising performance
issues in real time
you can see where as you're loading all
these different things you might end up
creating loops you didn't know you're
doing polymorphism reduces readability
of the code
uh sometimes your actual code everything
you look at in java is polymorphism all
based on a primary object so you could
have a very complicated setup and then
it actually is very easy to read when
you actually put your final variable in
there
but when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you loop
through all these different inherited
modules or classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is
what exactly is a java collection
a java collection can be generally
defined as a collective unit of objects
in the form of a group
for example a group of numbers of
integer data type etc moving forward we
enter into our next topic where we face
the java collections framework this will
help us understand java collections in a
little more detailed way
a java collection framework represents a
unified architecture for storing and
manipulating a group of objects its
architecture includes the following
an interface a class and the java
collections api
to understand these in a much better way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy the utility
package java.util contains all the
classes and interfaces that are required
by a collection framework the collection
framework contains an interface
named as an iterable interface which
provides the iterator to iterate through
all the collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface which acts as
a root for the collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator and the
methods of this interface
the following figure illustrates the
hierarchy of collection framework out of
the complexities we have the interface
and the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time as you can see on
the screen we have the iterable class
which is implemented by the collection
class and this particular collection
class is further implemented by list
queue and set and moving ahead we have
the following classes which have
implemented the list queue and set
classes in the list we have arraylist
linked list vector stack and on the
other hand on the queue we have priority
queue dq and array dq and finally on the
set we have the hash set
length hash set sorted set reset etc now
moving further we will enter our first
java collection which is none other than
the interface so the first one is an
interface an interface can have methods
and variables
but the methods declared in an interface
are by default abstract that is
only the method signature is available
not the body
interfaces specify what a class must do
and not how it must do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection is a foundation to the java
collections framework note that all the
collection interfaces are generic for
example public interface collection is
the syntax for the generics and when we
declare the collection we should use it
to specify the type of object which it
can contain
it helps in reducing runtime errors by
type checking the objects at compile
time to keep the number of core
collections interface manageable the
java platform doesn't provide separate
interfaces for each variant of each
collection type if an unsupported
operation is invoked a collection
implementation throws an unsupported
operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces that we should use
for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are set
interface list interface dq interface
queue interface map interface sorted set
interface
sorted map interface
no worry those are a lot of interfaces
but we will discuss each one of them in
a detailed way along with a practical
example
for a better understanding
so the first one in the docket is the
set interface
a set is a collection that cannot
contain any duplicate elements
this interface model is the mathematical
set abstraction and is used to represent
sets such as a deck of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose set implementations
the hash set tree set and
linked hash set the set interface does
not allow random access to an element in
the collection you can use an iterator
for each loop to traverse elements of a
set
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical example i have
prepared a code document for all the
programs that i am going to explain to
just save time
you can always have access to it all you
need to do is just ask for it in the
comment section below so you can see on
my screen we have an example for set
interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23 43
53 22 and 65
so let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53 22 and 23
43
so the sorted set is here which is a 21
22 23 43 53 and 65 and the first element
being 21 and the last element being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next type of interface which is
none other than the list interface
so what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain duplicate elements you
can access any element from its index
the list is more likely an
array with dynamic length the list is
one of the most used collection types
and array list and linked list are the
implementation classes of the list
interface
the list interface provides useful
methods to add an element at a specific
index to remove and replace elements
based on the index and to get a sub list
using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list interface
so we are going to add in three names
which are david john and stacy into our
list and also we have a fourth edition
which is stacy again
just to check if the statement is true
it says list interface also allows
duplicate elements unlike the set
interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david john and stacy are added into the
list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this comment and try to run again
and check if the fourth element which is
the duplicate of the third
will be added into the list or not so as
you can see the program got successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy the duplication of the first one
got successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into our next type
of interface which is the queue
interface so what exactly is a queue
interface q is a collection used to hold
multiple elements prior to processing
besides basic collection operations a
queue provides additional insertion
extraction and inspection operations
cues typically but did not necessarily
order elements in the fifo or first in
first out manner
among the exceptions are priority queues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is the element that would be
removed by a call to remove our poll in
a first and first out queue
all new elements are inserted at the
tail of the cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for queue interface
so in this particular queue we are going
to store the names of fruits apple mango
grapes and banana and apple being the
head of the cube and banana being the
tail of the cube
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first after that
we are going to remove the element
grapes from the queue
so the command is q dot remove the
element name so after that the grapes
element has been removed from our queue
we have the latest size of the queue as
three
now after that we are also going to
check if the element apple is included
in the queue or not
so for that statement yes the element
apple is included in the queue and the
result is true so this is how the queues
work and let's move further and in the
next phase we have the dq interface so
what exactly is a dq interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion and removal at both
the ends is called as a dq interface
the name dq is short for double ended
queue and is usually pronounced as dec
most dq implementations place no fixed
limits on the number of elements they
may contain but this interface supports
capacity restricted dqs as well as those
with no fixed size limit this interface
defines methods to access the elements
at both the ends of the dq
methods are provided to insert remove
and examine the element for a better
understanding let's check out an example
so you can see on my screen we have a
program for dq interface so here we are
going to add in some elements into our
dq and then also try to remove the first
element and print the updated dq now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so as you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the elements which we try to push
into the dq were 52 10 and 21 52 is
being the first element and the 21 is
being the last element so we try to
remove the first element which is the 52
so after that the updated dq is having
two elements which are 10 and 21
so this is how the queues work now let's
move ahead and learn our next type of
interface which is the map interface so
what exactly is a map interface a java
map is an object that maps keys along
with its values a map cannot contain
duplicate keys each key
can map to at most one value
the java platform contains three general
purpose map implementations
which are the hashmap tree map and
linked hashmap
the basic operations of a map are
contains key contains value size and is
empty for a better understanding let us
check out an example so this particular
example on my screen is an example
for map interface here we are going to
add three elements and map them as one
as cricket two as hockey and three as
archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are
mapped with their keys and the element
cricket is mapped with the key one and
similarly hockey with k2 and r3 with k3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move further into our next
type of interface which is the sorted
set interface
so what exactly is a sorted set
interface so a sorted set is a set that
maintains its elements in ascending
order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as word list
and membership roles
for a better understanding let's check
out an example based on sorted set
interface
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to print the same
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and we have our
elements printed in the sorted set and
you can see the
names have been arranged in the form of
ascending order according to the
alphabets which have started in the
first position so this is exactly how
the sort set interface works
so the last one in the interfaces is the
sorted map interface a map that
maintains its mapping in an ascendant
key order this is the map analog of
sorted set the certain maps are used for
naturally audited collections of key
value pairs such as dictionaries and
telephone directories
now for a better understanding let's
check out an example based on
map interface or sorted map interface so
you can see the program on my screen is
an example for sorted map interface so
here we're going to add in the elements
john molly aaron and daisy into the map
interface now along with the names we
also have their aggregates which is 76.5
for john 87.3 for molly and
for aaron and for daisy we have 73.4
now finally we're going to fetch the
data of molly which is the aggregate of
molly now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and knowledge
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our next topic
which is the java collection classes
so now that we have finished the java
collection interfaces let us have a
quick understanding of java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method the add method is used to add an
object to the collection and next is the
ease anti method this method returns to
true if the collection contains no
elements followed by that we have the
clear method and this method is used to
remove all the elements from the
collection
followed by that we have the remove
method this method is used to remove the
given object from the collection if
there are duplicate values then this
method removes the first occurrence of
the object next to the remove method we
have the size method so the size method
is used to return the number of elements
in the collection so after the size
method we have the stream method the
stream method is used to return a
sequential stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is the two array
method
so the two array method is used to
return an array containing all the
elements in this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method this method is used to return the
hashcode value for this collection
next
the equals method
the equals method is used to compare the
specified object with the remaining
elements in the collection followed by
that we have the iterator method so the
iterator method is used as an iterator
over the elements of the particular
collection and finally we have the
contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element is existing in the
collection and false if it is not
present so with this we finish the
collection interface and collection
interface methods now we will move ahead
into our next topic which is none other
than the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class a class is a user
defined blueprint or prototype from
which objects are created it represents
a set of properties or methods that are
common to all the objects of one type
now we'll start up with the first one
which is the hash set class so the java
hash set is the basic implementation of
the set interface that is backed up by
the hashmap it makes no guarantee for
the iteration order
of the set and permits null elements as
well
so this class offers constant time
performance for basic operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets we can set the initial
capacity and load factor for this
collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before its
capacity is automatically increased for
a better understanding let's go through
an example
so on my screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes along with null
values
so we have added in two null values to
just check if it allows two null values
at once so basically it only should
allow one null value so let's check out
how does it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the null value
is stored only once that too in the
first location
so this is how the hash set classes work
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class which is the tree set
class
so a tree set class is a navigable set
implementation based on a tree map the
elements are ordered using their natural
ordering or by a comparator provided at
set creation time depending on which
constructor is being used this
implementation provides guaranteed log
stein cost for the basic operations such
as add remove and contains
note that the ordering maintained by a
set whether or not an explicit
comparator is provided must be
consistent with equals if it is to
correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example now we are
going to add in some numbers into the
tree set using the add method now let's
execute this code and see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set and the numbers are
ordered in ascending order
which is 0 18 88 748
983 8476
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is
the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array that is an implementation of list
interface that allows null elements so
in this class we have three types of
arrays which are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays now let's check
out the one-dimensional array
so
a one-dimensional array looks similar to
this where we have the array index and
the element present in the array so here
our indexes are a 0 1 2 3 and 4 and the
elements which are shown here to
understand one-dimensional arrays in a
much better way let's go through a
sample program
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for one-dimensional
array and we are going to store the
elements 10 20 and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one-dimensional
array
moving further we will discuss the
two-dimensional arrays the
two-dimensional arrays are completely
similar to one-dimensional array but the
only difference is the index numbers
earlier we had index number but now we
have index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements in a matrix form
so to understand this in a much better
way let's go through a sample code
so you can see this particular program
in my screen is an example for
two-dimensional arrays so here we are
going to add in elements one two three
and four in the matrix form and we are
going to use two for loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output
so you can see we have the elements 1 2
3 and 4 and the elements are printed in
the matrix form
at the array index location 0 0 we have
1 0 1 we have 2 and 1 0 we have 3 and 1
1 we have 4 so this is how the two
dimensional arrays work and finally
let's deal with the third type of array
which is the multi-dimensional or
three-dimensional array
so you can see the three-dimensional
array is completely similar or a little
bit similar to the two-dimensional array
but the only difference is we have a
third vector here
so next up we have the linked list
linked lists also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list doubly
linked list and circular link list
now let's check out each one of those
so the first one is the single linked
list so you can see in a singly linked
list each memory segment is divided into
two parts so the first half of the
memory location is given for the element
and the second half of the memory
location is dedicated for the address so
this particular address is used to point
to the next element or the next memory
allocation which stores the second
element similarly the third so this is
how the singly linked list works so the
last memory or location is called as
tale and the last address will not store
nothing but null which indicates the end
of the singly linked list
now to understand single linked list in
a much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list now
we are going to add in the elements one
two three and four in the form of a
singly linked list now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are 1 2 3 and 4. now let's move further
and try to learn the next type of linked
list which is the doubly linked list
so the doubly linked list is completely
similar to that of the singly linked
list but the only difference is we have
two address locations so the first
address location of the head stores null
and the last address location of the
tail stores null which
indicate the start and end of the doubly
linked list respectively
so here in the second memory location
you have two addresses so the first
address points to the previous element
and the next address points to the next
element so to understand doubly linked
lists in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for doubly linked
list and we have the node which has the
data and previous address next address
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output and the elements that
we are going to store in this particular
doubly linked list are one two three
four and five
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the notes are
one two three and four and five
so this is how the doubly linked list
work and now let's check out the third
type of linked list which is the
circular linked list so there are
similarities between the previous linked
list and the circular linked list
so the circular linked list makes it
circular based on the last address
location
so this particular address location
points to the first element back again
so this is how it becomes a circular
linked list so to understand this in a
much better way let's check out an
example for it
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for circular linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output so you can see we have
successfully included one two three four
five six and seven and eight into our
circular linked list and they are
printed on the screen so this is how the
circular linked list work so moving
further we will try to understand the
next type of classes in java collections
which is the hashmap class so hash table
is based on the implementation of map
interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key hash map class is
roughly equivalent to hash table except
that it is unsynchronized and permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map now for a better
understanding let's go through a sample
program
so this particular
program on my screen is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer and their bike so let's
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
manufacturer and their mate bikes now
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class in java collection
which is the tree map class so the tree
map is based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at map
creation time depending on the
constructor used
now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the roll numbers and the
names of students here now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console
so we have the role numbers of the
students and their names amber
james wallet and reynolds along with
their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms so the first one is sorting
sorting does the job of ascending at
descending numbers based on the
algorithm written by the user for a
simple example we shall consider the
bubble sort algorithm for this one so
you can see on my screen we have an
example for bubble sort algorithm so we
have the elements 289 39 48 6 28 1 2 and
33 which are ordered in
an orderly manner let's try to execute
this program and order them
so you can see array before bubble sort
is 289 38 48 similarly 33 and after the
bubble sort we have the sorted array
which is 126 28 33 39 48 and 289 so this
is how the bubble sort works now let's
move further and understand the next
type of api which is the shuffling
algorithm so the shuffling algorithms
are designed to destroy the current
arrangements they are employed on
creating randomness in the list so for a
better understanding let's check out an
example so you can see the program
written on my screen is an example for
shuffle algorithm so we have an array
which has the elements completely sorted
in ascending order which is 10 to 100.
now when we run the shuffle algorithm
these elements will be completely
shuffled according to a random order now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
elements which were in an ascending
order are now completely in disorder so
this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further and
understand the next type of algorithm
which is the searching algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example let's use the
binary search
now you can see a program on my screen
which is an example for binary search so
we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array now what we are going to do is
search for the element or the key
element to in our array using the binary
search algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says the element which you're looking
for is found in the index location one
so this is how the binary search
algorithm works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the composition
algorithm so the definition says the
frequency and disjoint algorithms test
some aspect of composition of one or
more collections so the frequency counts
the number of times the specified
element occurs in the specified
collection
so the disjoint determines whether two
collections are disjoint that is whether
they contain no element in common or not
now to understand it in a much better
way let's go through an example so you
can see on my screen there is an example
for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and
the elements are completely disjoint now
moving further we will enter into our
next topic which is based on the
benefits of
java collections so there are various
benefits of java collections out of
those the major benefits are software or
code reusability so the java collections
enable code reusability to save time
followed by that the ease of designing
apis so the next two ease of designing
apis we have the simplicity in learning
and using apis and finally increased
speed in programming
so these were the major benefits of java
collections
what is an exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program
this may not be considered merely as an
error but it surely does impact the
normal functioning of the program
segment
now these types of exceptions are
resolved by the most efficient mechanism
called exception handling
exception handling is not any rocket
science but a simple mechanism that
drives the compiler to the next
statement by making the compiler
understand that the input obtained or
the malfunction that arise is just an
unexpected or an unnecessary event which
can be ignored by sending the user with
a relevant message about the exception
arrows
for a better understanding let us go
through a small example
so as you can see on our screen we have
typed in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data.txt from the c drive so this
particular data.txt is not really
existing in the c drive so when we run
this program we will face an exception
that says file is not found so let's try
to run this program and see
so as expected so when we run this
program we get that this particular file
what you're looking for which is
data.txt is not found
or in other words it is not present in
the specified location
so this is how the exceptions work in
java
now followed by this we will move ahead
into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error
so what exactly is an error
so here we are trying to learn about the
error just to eliminate the ambiguity
between an exception and an error also
further we will discuss the major
differences between them but now let us
go through the term error first
unlike an exception an error poses a
serious potential threat to the program
or sometimes it is even capable enough
to collapse an entire software
so basically an error is occurred due to
syntax error or some logical error while
coding so we have a sound understanding
of an exception and an error now let us
move further and learn the differences
between the both
error versus exception
so some of the major differences between
an error and an exception are
an error is classified under unchecked
type whereas on the other hand an
exception is classified under both
checked and unchecked
the next difference is if a program
encounters an error then it turns out to
be completely irrecoverable until the
error is resolved whereas in the case of
an exception
if the program encounters an exception
then the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
java.lang.error
on the other hand an exception belongs
to the class java.lang.exception
the fourth difference says that an error
can be encountered only during the
program's run time whereas on the other
hand an exception can be expected both
during the run time as well as the
compile time
finally we will mention an example for
both an error and an exception
we can consider the input and output
error as an example for error and on the
other hand
we can consider divide by zero exception
as an example for exception
so with the differences discussed we
will now move ahead and have a look at
the exception hierarchy in java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really simple
there is one root class called the
throwable
now the throwable class is basically
inherited from object which comes from
the superior route called java.lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception
further an error is inherited by
different types of errors for example
jvm or java virtual machine error memory
error
and also in some cases some of the
errors are caused by the incompatibility
of the ide or the framework which are
you are using
next up is the exception
now the exception is inherited by few
more exceptions which are mentioned as
below the exceptions can be input output
exception sql exception class not found
exception runtime exception and many
more
further the runtime exception is
inherited by some more
which are the automatic exception
number format exception etc
now that we have a good understanding of
the exception hierarchy let us move
ahead and check the differences between
checked and unchecked exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions
these are really simple exceptions and
can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the checked
exception
it is not serious and is completely
ignorable
followed by the checked exceptions we
have the unchecked exceptions on the
other hand the unchecked exceptions are
defined as an exception that pops up
during the run time is called as the
unchecked exception
it is considered as serious and is
caused by logical errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular example is based on
checked exceptions
so basically we have a text document
called data.txt
in the location documents username users
c drive
so this particular data file has five
lines so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input
output and again the same exception
and here
file not sound exception
so these exceptions are errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from c drive
which is data.pxt
so this particular data.txt has five
lines of text so what we are going to do
here is try to type in a for loop and
try to read the first three lines of
this particular document so basically
when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not found exception input
output exception and another input
output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if we run this program
then we can find our lines
so the lines in the data dot txt file
were hello welcome to simply learn we
are an e-learning company our
certification is recognized by major
mncs end role and upskill
so this particular example was for
checked exceptions
now
we will also go through an example for
unchecked exceptions to learn it in a
much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have 10 elements which are 1 2 3 4 5 six
seven eight nine and ten
so what we're going to do is we're going
to access the 11th element of the array
which is not really present so this
should throw an exception
so array index out of bond exception is
one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move ahead into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have five major
keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows
so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception block
in a program when you specifically type
the exception that you might expect to
face in your program then you describe
it using the keyword try
followed by that the solution for that
exception will be defined in the catch
block so the catch block is used to
specify the solution
finally
the finally is a keyword which has the
executable code which is completely
mandatory for a program to execute
followed by finally we have the throw
keyword the throw keyword basically
throws the exception when it is found
during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect in your program
sometimes you might
try to type in your user defined
exception or sometimes you might type in
the exception that is
default in its way
or in other words it might be system
defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in java
let us move further and solve some of
the most frequently faced exceptions in
java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in java
so the first one is the array index out
of bound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
address maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown
so to understand this particular
exception let us go through a practical
example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer data type so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is
0 1 2 3 and 4.
now we are going to provide the address
of the required element so during that
process we are going to specify
one location which is more than the
maximum location of the array so here
the maximum location of the array is 4
and if we try to provide the location 5
then this program should throw us an
exception so let's try to run this
program and see the output
so as you can see we have our array here
now
the program is requesting us to provide
the address of the element required so
what if we provide file
so now it should throw an exception
so this exception is the array index out
of bound exception now let us try to run
this program again and specify the
proper address
so for this time let's provide 4 and see
if we get the output
so as you can see at the address
location we have the element 50 as we
have defined here
now our program is running perfectly all
right
now let's move ahead into the next type
of exception
which is none other than our null
pointer exception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown
so might be a little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical example
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a string called sdr which stores
a text called simply
followed by that we have another string
type which stores a null value which is
abc as you can see abc is equals to null
now here we are going to access the
value of abc
so here the string abc has a null value
and we are trying to access it so this
particular code segment should throw an
exception called null pointer exception
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the null pointer
exception so whenever in java if you try
to access the null values then the null
pointer exception is strong
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception
which is the number format
if you try to store a value with wrong
formatting then this particular
exception is thrown
now to understand this in a much better
way let us try to execute a sample
program
so here on the screen we have a sample
program
where we are trying to cast a string
into integer so this kind of operation
should throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception
followed by this we have another most
commonly faced exception which is the
arithmetic expression
if you try to divide a number by zero
this particular exception is thrown now
let us go through a practical example
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers n one is equals to
zero and n two is equals to hundred
so here what we are trying to do is we
are going to divide the number 100 by 0
which is practically not possible so
when we try to execute this particular
program then we should be getting an
exception that says you cannot divide a
number by 0.
so there you have your personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
zero try a different number
so this is how the automatic exceptions
work
so with this we have come to our last
topic
which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in java
so the first one is use exceptions
conservatively
so exceptions have proven that they can
be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessarily
so it's better to use boolean values to
indicate successful implementation of
smaller operations for example if you
specify a particular operation and it
successfully gets executed then you can
just notify the user by specifying a
boolean value which can be one or in the
case of failure you can just specify the
number zero
next after that we have the customized
exceptions
it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design time rather than planning them on
the go
so in other words we can consider this
as if you're planning to design a
software then
in that particular stage itself you must
also evaluate the kind of exceptions you
might face on the process of designing
so tomorrow if you completely design a
software and suddenly an exception is
popped in your head then designing or
including that particular exception in
your finished software
might be difficult so it's better you
start planning your exceptions
followed by that we have exception
logging
keep track of the exceptions and this
process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has popped up
followed by that we have early through
and early jail an exception should be
thrown as early as possible and should
be resolved in the same pace
and then we have the closing resources
since exceptions halt the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are shut so as to save
the resources
what is jdbc
jdbc is a tool or an application
programming interface that establishes a
connection between standard database and
java application that intends to use
that database
need for jdbc
establishing database connectivity to
execute mysql or sql queries and ddl dml
commands
view and modify data records
and one of the most important things to
look at when we're talking about a jdbc
and probably uh the most confusing part
where the devil's in the details
is data types in a jdbc
so we start looking at the data types
and you're setting up your data you have
your sql which is your var character and
your java equivalent
java.language.string
and you have your bit in sql in java
it's boolean in sql it's numeric
java.math.big.
integer int
real float float float
so there's no real difference in job
between a real number and a float number
your double is double your binary is a
byte
data java sql date so your date and
java.sql date
and there's also your sql timestamp
java.sql timestamp
array java.sql array reference
javasql.referencestructure.java.sql
structure
character
java.language.string big integer long in
java
variable binary it's a byte
a clob
and that's character large object
and then equivalent is java.sql.clob
and then you have your blob in sql
which is a collection of binary data
stored as a single entity and the
equivalent in java is going to be your
javasql.blob
now if you're doing a lot of programming
i would suggest having a cheat sheet
there and then once you're up and
running you'll start to remember most of
these just because out of use
with the jdbc architecture
we're looking at the application then it
goes into the jdbc api so you have your
application your writing your java
database connector api
then that has a manager underneath of it
and then you have your java database
connection drivers and the drivers are
the ones that are transferring that
whether it's an sql server mysql server
the oracle database
or different sources that use a jdbc
connection
jdbc environment setup
so when we talk about the environment
setup we have java and your
environmental setup underneath of that
in setting up a java environment you
have to download the latest jdk set java
to home and set your java path so if
you're just using eclipse for the first
time or whatever ide you're using to
program you want to make sure you have
that all set up and you have the current
jdk in there the java development
package
and then with mysql
setting up mysql environment download
the latest mysql workbench extract the
file run the setup file and that will
get you set up with your own mysql on
your computer
and mysql registers with your operating
system so it's kind of like a global
variable when you start accessing it and
it's designed that way because normally
when you're using an sql or mysql
database it's installed on a server
so it makes sense that you want it
registered with the operating system so
it's accessed globally
steps to connect your jdbc
step one import your packages this
procedure is followed to make sure that
the relevant packages are readily
available for the api
step two load and register your driver
the imported driver is needed to be
loaded and registered for establishing a
connection between application and
database and if remember in this case
we're doing the mysql so we make sure
our mysql driver is installed
and step three connecting database after
the first two steps the next stage is to
connect the database this can be done by
a git connection
step four writing a query
so now we're actually starting it into
your scripting here we write in the sql
command or query that we need to execute
if you're not familiar with sql it's
good to have an sql cheat sheet set up
once you start understanding how it's
put together you'll find that it goes
really quick and it's pretty fast to
learn but it is its own query language
and you do need to learn
a number of the main settings in poll
language so you know what you're doing
step 5 executing query now the query
from the api is executed using execute
query
and we'll actually load that up just as
a string variable when we look at that
you'll see how that fits together
step six processing result after step
five the system basically does two
things it processes an output and
retrieves the values from your query
and then step 7 closing statement the
result set and statement needs to be
closed explicitly
and you'll find there's two closing
statements there is your result set
which is still pulling from the database
and then step eight
which is we need to actually close
closing connection so the last stage is
to disconnect ourselves or the api from
the database so we no longer have that
open connection using resources
so we're going to jump into our java
database connection example
and we're going to do that with what we
call the university database
let's start with a basic overview of
mysql
and you can go to dev.mysql.com
and you'll see here we can look up more
information they have the download of
the newest version
this is
a full sql database package
and some of these you can actually go in
there and if you're doing a database
management they can spread across up to
usually don't want to go more than five
servers but
it is designed to go up to five servers
kind of set up with terabytes of data in
there
for a developer on the programming side
we usually want to install
something like mysql
locally so on my setup it has no network
connections
it doesn't auto start on the boot up of
the computer
and i have it locked down that way if i
use some kind of simple password or
something like that for one of my demos
it doesn't go anywhere no one can access
it
now another option to mysql
is also the sqlite
and you can go to the sqlite.org read
more about it and download it
it has a couple limitations that you're
not going to see in your regular your
full scale mysql or oracle or sql
but most of it will transfer over and so
for a small project you can actually use
it as a back end for storing your data
you can also integrate it or upgrade it
into my sql because most of the sql
commands are the same
and when you go into
the mysql which is a significant
download versus sql lite
you can certainly go down to downloads
and then there's also
the connectors so
devmysql.com
download slash connector slash j
and i bring this up because it depends
on how you set up eclipse
for your interface and your ide and it
depends on what you need and how you
exactly on your setup as far as the
connectors we'll look at that a little
bit more closer
in the mysql it is an oracle based so
you'll have to set up an account if you
don't have one you have to log in it's
all free
as long as you're not doing like the
enterprise with all the support and help
on it you don't have to pay for it it's
an open source
now once you've installed uh mysql and
if you do sqlite you're not going to
have these interfaces it'll all be done
from java code
but once you've installed mysql it's
going to add in a terminal window and
then also
the workbench which is just a nice gui
uh interface for mysql server
and we're not going to do anything with
the workbench you can play with it
certainly
because a lot of times you don't have
the workbench installed on your computer
especially if the mysql
is set up on a different server and
you're remote accessing it especially
like if you're in the classroom or
something like that they probably have
sent you your login information so you
can get into the shell quick note though
is if you do your own mysql just note
that i kept this as a local host you can
actually see it down here root local
host
no outward connections and that's just
to protect my computer once you start
opening those you have to be aware of
your passwords and since i'm doing demos
i want to keep my passwords really
simple so that's not the focus of the
programming
i had to log out and relog back in
so once you've gone in there you should
have this a lot of times your interface
might be web based if it's a remote
mysql connection you're working with and
i'll prompt you for your username and
password
in this case mine is on my computer it
automatically has me login as admin so i
have full admin rights
and then we always like to start by at
least i do is show
databases
and these are the current databases on
here
they have some different information on
them that is part of the basic setup and
some examples like sakila and world are
both example databases that
automatically load with mysql
for this example we're going to create a
database
and it's going to be university we'll do
capital there university
don't forget our semicolon
and
time you can see how long it took 0.69
seconds and of course if we go show
databases
you'll see now that there is a
university in there
and we want to go ahead and use
university
that means that whatever we do any
commands that we have in here for tables
or whatever are now going to be going
into the university database
so now our database has changed
and let's go ahead and zoom in
let's see here we go set okay
a little bit more so we get a nice big
print so you can see what i'm doing a
little bit better
there we go all right so we're going to
go ahead and create our table
and this has all been prepared so i
don't have to go through and redo it all
the time
you'll see here we're going to do
a create a table engineering student
and then we have
student id is an integer not null
department variable character 25 long
first name
last name pass out year
university rank primary key
in creating this note a couple things
first we created a table engineering
students and we've gone ahead and
created the fields as part of the create
setup here
and the things i want you to note is
that we have our integer so our student
id is an integer our department is a
variable character and is 25 long and
the reason i say that that is really
important is when we flip back on over
here if you remember from our
there we go
if you remember from our data types
here's our variable character and in
java language that's a string
a string
doesn't say hey it's only 25 long and so
you've got to be a little careful when
you're pushing and pulling this data
especially when you're writing the data
from java into the sql that you check
for that length of that string
and then the integer is of course an
integer and of course your other data
types you can see how they follow suit
but with variable character be very
aware of that that that is a designated
25 characters long
and we're going to go ahead and insert
some data in here
here we go we'll go ahead and insert
into
engineering students values
and this is going to be the student id
and it's also the primary key so keep in
mind that that is a
unique value in there and then we have
cse computer science engineering karan
akaria 2018 1272. so there's our
pass out year 2018
and ranked um
i guess number 1272
i'm not sure where the um oh it's a
university ranking there we go
and then we have some prepared data
which i just went ahead and pasted in so
we have a whole bunch of individuals in
our database now
and we'll i mean it's the same line over
and over again insert into engineering
students values and then you have your
list of values
and we can see that by doing a simple uh
select
uh
we'll do what's the star so it's going
to select everything one of our hot
characters
if you're not familiar with um sql get a
setup on there and look it over
and you can also
download a cheat sheet from somewhere
with all the different commands in there
i myself do a lot of
consulting
and so i'm always jumping around from
one platform to another
if you're doing that kind of work it's
more important to understand the
limitations and the advantages of
different systems and then you have your
cheat sheets for putting together stuff
really quickly when you need it
and you can see here the data we just
put in there there's our student ids
department first name last name
pass out year
and university rank
and we'll go ahead and do one query in
here real quick we're gonna we already
did one query we're gonna do two queries
uh we did select star from engineering
and then we're gonna go ahead and select
student id department first name last
name so you can actually choose what you
select instead of doing the asterisks
where student id equals 10202
and when we go ahead and execute that in
here
oops
there we go you'll see that it returns
the one individual with that student id
here
so let's take this back into our eclipse
because we're still doing the setup so
you have your my sequel server set up or
you did sql lite with a little bit
different setup going on there
and let's flip on over and see what's
going on with eclipse
so in eclipse we're going to go in new
we'll start a new project
and we'll call this
jdbc it's our jdbc project whoops
select a wizard
i forgot where i was going on there it's
a java wizard we're looking for this
project java project
there we go and we're going to call this
there now we're in the right spot uh jd
bc package that way everything will be
bundled in there in the same package and
finish it
create all right so you can see right
here we have our new
jdbc package we're working with
now at this point there's a lot going on
as far as your options
if you set this up for doing database
management which i did not and i'm going
to show you the two different ways you
can go under
windows
and under preferences
and in this list you'll see database
management and then you can just go in
there and set it up this way and it'll
pull in that information for your sql
connections
now if you did not and you downloaded
the mysql
it does have an option to download the
java connex which would put it into
wherever you installed that at which is
default under your c drive program files
now on mine
i didn't i downloaded the connection
separately
and there's two different ways we can go
under project
and under the build project
give that a moment to come up
oops i mean properties there we go the
project properties and the java build
path
this same window can be accessed by
right-clicking on your
package we're working on and then we can
go down to properties and you'll see the
same window opens up
and we're going to go under java build
path
we're going under library so these are
libraries we want to include in our
setup
and then i click on our module path and
at this point you'll see add external
jars here
now again if you haven't already preset
up any clips you can just add jars and
it will be in the jar library so there's
different possibilities there but i did
a download so i'm going to go add
external jars
and i happen to keep mine on my d volume
under my sql
and you'll see my sql connector java and
this is
mysql 8.0
and i just go in here
oops there we go i just go ahead and
open this up and you'll see right here
it has my connector java
once i set that in it's now added those
packages and there's hundreds of actual
subfiles in there and it's all set to go
and i can apply and close this window
and now i'm ready to go ahead and start
writing my script and start building a
program in here
and let's go ahead and go under source
new i'm going to put in a new class in
here and we'll just go call it jdbc
same as the package i'm going to finish
that
and we're set up with a new class in
here
and once we've got this set the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and import
all of our java setup in here so we have
the java connection and now we want to
go ahead and import it
and when we look at this
we can see we have our
connection and remember two of these
have to be closed explicitly and that's
your connection
uh when you create the statement
you have your driver manager uh so when
it goes in there that's a piece that
connects to actually does the connection
to the um database the drivers that
convert everything in the code in there
so you have your connection to the
database you have the code that converts
it
you have your result so you're going to
get a result off of your query
then you have your exception so if you
have an error throws or something like
that that's where that's going and of
course the actual statement that you're
going to send to the sql server
and of course we want our java to be
able to actually run so we'll put our
main in there public static void main
and it's going to throw the sql
exception
so you'll see right here that's what
we're working with and there's our
javasql sql exception on there
so the first thing we're going to need
on our setup let's put that in here is
going to be our connection information
uh we need to know the username i'm just
going to call it string you name equals
in this case i created a user
richard underscore simplylearn
and then i created a password my
password remember this is a localhost so
you probably don't want to have a simple
password like that but mike this whole
database is locked down on just this
computer there's no outside network
access or anything like that to get in
here
and then of course this is a separate
user so it's not even my admin or root
user
and then we go ahead and put a query
right here in this case we'll start with
our most basic query if you remember we
already did that on our at the very
beginning select star from engineering
students
and we're going to use that query in our
code to start off with
and then another really common thing
when you're setting this up
is that we also want to test it and see
hey did we import our package correctly
is it set up correctly uh so remember we
came in and we
imported our my sql connector jar file
in the code we would just want to make
sure it's it's working correctly and
that's what this is it says try class
for name and then it has our
com.mysql.cj.jdbcdriver
saying hey do we have the driver for
this that's all that's doing
and if not then it's going to print an
error so we can find out why it doesn't
have that driver
and then next we want to actually start
getting into our actual code and in here
we're going to do a try because whenever
you do any kind of major connection you
want to make sure
that you're looking for your errors
you're not going to miss on anything and
we're going to do a catch
and so we're looking for any kind of sql
exception error
and for this demo we'll just do
you know print it out so um oops wrong
spot
goes into the catch section there we go
uh so we'll print it out over down here
as far as the error on there and it's an
xql exception so still looking for the
code which we haven't put in here yet
and this is really where the the magic
really starts to happen because we have
our
connection
and
there we go
and you'll see that the connection is
that's all this is right here here's our
connection up here
and
we pop it down here we have a connection
we'll just call it con
one end so keep it uniform
there we go
and this is going to go to the driver
so in other words right here we're going
to need a
the driver manager and that's what we
imported here and it says get connection
because that's part of the driver
manager
and we have um our url
let's see and we of course forgot to put
the url in up above so let's go ahead
and go back there and put that in
and the url comes out as a jdbc mysql
that is registered with my computer so
my computer has when it's running the
mysql
this is the local host
in this case we call it university
that's where this comes from
and that's all part of your mysql setup
if you're working with a remote database
you'd want to get this information from
the remote whoever set the database up
so that you have this particular line of
where to call
and so we go back down here we have our
connection it's all set up on here the
next thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead
and
create our statement
and this initializes it so we have a
statement called statement but this
statement is going to be based on our
driver manager which is then connected
to the connection so these are all
connected to each other and this
generates the format it needs
for when we actually send our inquiry
remember here's our query right here so
we're going to send select star from
engineering students for right now
we haven't put that part in we're just
creating the class or initiating the
instance so that we can do that
and then once we've initiated the
instance here let's go down here
we need to go ahead and generate a
result and so we have our results set
again that comes up here from what we
brought in
we're storing the data coming in or
storing the pipeline to bring it in
we're just going to call that result and
then we have this is generated from our
statement here's our statement so this
is all like linked together here's our
execute query which is part of the
statement and here's the actual query
which is coming that we put together the
select star from engineering students
and then finally we want to actually do
something with our information so we'll
do is we'll just loop through it while
and here's our result
set that we just generated so wall
result
dot
next
and this just generates a boolean so it
says hey there's still another result
coming in so we need to go ahead and get
that next result
then we'll go ahead and create a um
and we'll take that string university
data and then
we're going to loop through the
different results
there we go
integer and then there we go university
data
and we want to tag on the end of it
result.getstring i
so what's going on here we just did a
bunch of things we are going through
each row
result.next each row of data that comes
off of the database until this returns
null there's no next result coming in
there and then we come in there we look
at the result the one we're looking at
is the current one so it goes through i
forget how many we put in there about 20
goes you know row 20 0 row one row two
row three row four
and then on each of these rows
we have a string it's an array of
strings
and we're going to get that string and
it returns i so this is get string of
column i
so we have row and column
and really important it is programming
to really understand rows and columns
because that's so central to most of the
data processing going on
and then finally we want to go ahead and
see our results so let's print them out
we'll put in our nice print statement
system out print line university data so
this is going to print each row as it
goes through it and then i'll reset the
row again to an empty string and then
i'll add each of the columns to that row
for my result and then we'll print the
next row out
and now that we have a complete code
let's go ahead and go up here hit the
run button
it's going to compile it runs it out and
we can see down here
let me just get my double mouse we can
get a better view
uh here's our different uh your id comes
up
with their i forget what the actual
setup was but the cse the name the date
the ranking
all that prints out one row at a time
and that's what we're doing here of
course if you're processing the data
differently you might be loading this
into a
user interface this might be generating
other information you might be doing
statistics with it
but you can see
how it's set up in here as far as
pulling the data into the java format
and then running it from there
just so we can get a quick glimpse of
where this goes let's go back up here
and we're going to flip back and forth
between a couple different screens so
let me do that
and here if you remember we did select
star from engineering students
and there's the same thing up here that
we got down here this is our my sequel
server interface and this is the
interface we built in java
and from here we also did this
particular selection select student id
department first name last name
pass out year university rank from
engineering students where student id is
and we got the single row on here
and this is kind of interesting because
i switch something in the code here
where this could cause a problem it
won't on this one
uh let me go ahead and paste this in
here and we'll run and compile this one
and you see it comes out with the single
user
so the danger of this particular code
is that i went ahead and hard coded in a
loop for i equals one to six
and so this one we pulled it just
happened to be that we did selected six
different columns in here so you gotta
be a little careful when you're coding
in here what are you pulling and where
is it going
uh you can see if i take out oh let's do
um we'll just remove the student id
and we're going to run that without the
student id
we compile it there we go and it gives
us a bunch of errors because it doesn't
see the we're short a column down here
so when it gets down to this code down
here
under the while statement
and it goes hey where's number six well
there's no number six and so we get a
lot of errors on that
and you can see where queries let me
just go back up here and paste another
query in
there we go
and we'll run this one and what we're
looking at is uh we're going to go ahead
and do the same columns
and
we'll just leave this as a star to make
it easy so we're going to select all
columns
from engineering students where the
passout year is 2018.
just do a copy of that one
and we'll run that
recompiles
and you can see here's all the 2018
on here if you look at the dates so
they're all 2018
and that's the same as our
query directly into the sql server if i
do the same thing on here
you'll see they're exactly the same
and just because we're having fun let's
flip this back over here and we'll do
one more
sql
server and let's do in this one
let's just take this whole thing out
here
and in this one we're going to pull in
all the departments but i want the
minimal university ranking as the
highest from engineering students
that way we can get an order of the
rankings on here and we'll go ahead and
run this
and there we go there's our minimal one
so this one hit the lowest ranking on
there or closest to number one
and we can do that in here and get the
same result uh there's karen
karen is awesome
ranking number 96
and you saw these other people that are
ranked way below koran so that's this
guy must be super smart
so that concludes our jdbc example
university database where we took a
quick look at mysql server
or you can do sqlite and some basic
queries you can put in there and how
that works
so the first question
what exactly is a servlet
now imagine you are searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it
this question from you to the internet
is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud or in technical terms your browser
sends your request to the respective
server responsible for storing for that
particular information and helps you
with it when requested now the server
gets triggered with your request and in
written it helps you back with the
information you have requested for this
answer from the server is called the
response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server for this process to
happen so smoothly and effectively we
need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server we find the component
responsible for such an effective job it
is called the servlet container that
holds java based web application and a
set of individual components called as
servlets
now we are close to our answer so this
particular java based component takes
care of web request and response to sum
it up with the form of a definition
we can define it as follows
a servlet is a java program that runs on
the java enabled web server or
application server they are used to
handle the request obtained from the web
server process the request produce the
response and then send a response back
to the web server now hoping that it was
a clear explanation can we move ahead
with the next topic
so the next topic we have is
so how does the servlet work in reality
or more practically or in depth what's
the life cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life to
get our work done so the stages are in
it service
and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created and not for all the requests
afterwards so it is used for the
one-time initializations just as with
the init method of applets
the servlet is normally created when a
user first invokes a url corresponding
to the servlet but you can also specify
the servlet is loaded when the server
first started when a user invokes a
servlet a single instance of each
servlet gets created with each user
request resulting in a new thread that
is handed over to the do get or do post
as appropriate the init method simply
creates or loads some data that will be
used throughout the lifecycle of a
servlet followed by the init method we
have the service method
so what is service method surface method
is the main method to perform the actual
task the servlet container that is the
web server calls the service method to
handle request from the client or the
browser and to write the formatted
response back to the client each time
the server receives a request from the
servlet the server spawns a new thread
and calls service
the service method checks the http
service type and accordingly performs
the crud operations which are the get
post
put delete etc and calls do get do post
do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate the service method is called
by the container and service method
invokes do get do post do put and do
delete etc methods as appropriate so you
have nothing to do with service method
but you overwrite either with do get do
post and other types depending on what
type of request you receive from the
client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete and
do put methods
so first we will discuss about do get
method so what exactly does a doget
method do a get request results from a
normal request from a url or an html
form that has no method specified and it
should be hardly by do get method
followed by do get we have
do post
a do post request results from a html
form that specifies list post as the
method and it should be handled by do
post method similar to to get and do
post the do put and do delete options
are usually used to update and delete
the data
when asked by the client so to sum up
these do get do post do put do delete we
can consider them as crud operations so
do get basically gets the information
what you're looking for do post method
usually post the information or provides
you with the response from the server
and followed by that we have the do put
which is usually used to update the data
which is present on your server and
finally delete which is used to delete
an existing data on your server so these
can be considered as crud operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method
the destroy method is called only once
at the end of the life cycle of a
servlet this method gives your servlet a
chance to close database connections
halt background threads write cookie
list or hit accounts to the disk and
performs other such cleanup activities
so with this we finish up the lifecycle
of a servlet now we shall understand its
architecture
basically the architecture of a servlet
can be understood by reverse engineering
the life cycle of a servlet so this is
how the servlet execution takes place
when a client or a browser makes a
request to the web browser
so the servlet architecture includes the
following first one servlet interface
to write a servlet we need to implement
the servlet interface servlet interface
can be implemented directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or http servlet class
followed by that the next part is
request handling methods as we have
discussed before there are mainly three
methods defined in servlet interface
which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods the first time a servlet
is invoked the init method is called it
is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet so we can put all
your initialization code here the
service method is used for handling the
client request as the client request
reaches the container it creates a
thread of servlet object and request and
response object are also created
these request and response objects are
then passed as parameter to the service
method which then processes the client
request the service method in turn calls
the do get do post methods if the user
has extended the class from http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this we have finished the
architecture of servlet moving further
we shall quickly discuss the features of
servlets and then enter into the
practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets the first feature is java
servlets are portable in nature as i
have mentioned above the servlets use
java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language the same holds true
for servlets for example you can create
a servlet on windows operating system
that uses glassfish as a web server and
then later run it on any operating
system like unix linux and apache tomcat
web server this feature makes servlet
portable and this is the main advantage
of servlet over cgi we shall discuss all
the differences of cgi versus servlet in
the next section for now we will discuss
the features followed by the first
feature we will now enter into the
second feature which says java servlets
are efficient and scalable once a server
is deployed and loaded onto a web server
it can instantly start fulfilling the
request of the clients
the web server invokes servlet using
lightweight thread so multiple client
requests can be fulfilled by servlet at
the same time using the multi-threading
feature of java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request the servlet is truly efficient
and scalable the next and the final
feature of java servlets is they are
robust and highly secure by inheriting
the top features of java such as garbage
collector exception handling java
security manager etc the servlet is less
prone to memory management issues and
memory leaks
this makes the development of web
applications and servlets secure and
less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets now
let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode the first one was to set
up the environment for java servlets and
the second one was to execute a basic
program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program
so we have these prerequisites where we
have to set up java home
and java path followed by that we need
to set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path so
catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server home and path
now we will set up these things by using
the environment variables now i'm using
a windows operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
variables
and inside this you can see that i have
already set up the environment variables
for catalina home java home and jre home
so now let us just select java home and
edit it so that we can see how did i set
it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home and inside the
variable value i have a location so this
location is nothing but the java jdk
location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home and the variable value is the
location of jre folder in my local
system so i have my jre folder in my
local system at c drive program files
java jre
and similarly the catalina home
which is inside my program files apache
software foundation and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables so inside system
variables you can see
the path just edited so then you can see
the path variable set for java
jre and tomcat
now just select ok
ok and finally another okay
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them so in case
if you have doubts about the tomcat
version to download then i'll help you
with that just open google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site and since i'm using a
windows operating system i'll be
selecting the 32-bit or 64-bit windows
service installer version
and after this gets downloaded you need
to set up the home and path variables
for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to create
a servlet program which are creating a
dynamic web project create a servlet add
servlet api jar file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new and inside that you
have
the option of other just select other
and inside that you'll be finding
web so select web and inside that you
need to select the dynamic web project
and select next
so you just need to name to your dynamic
web project so i'll be
naming a server
then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you for opening this particular in java
ee perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see
server folder here which has already set
up everything you need
now what you need to do is set up a new
servlet
so right click this
and select new
and inside that you can see the option
of servlet just select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up the class name
for now let's just type in hello and go
to next
now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select do get
method
now let's just finish it
and there you go your servlet has been
ready so this is the basic template
created by eclipse for you now next we
need to add in the build path so for
that you need to right click the server
and then
select build path
and here configure build path
from here you can add the external
library select the external libraries
option and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all and open
and that's how you add all the required
libraries of tomcat server now apply and
close
now the last step is to execute the
project now just to save time i have
already typed in the program
which is over here
now let's try to execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world
now the server i have choose this tomcat
server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully hello welcome to
simply learn
now we'll move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
so let's include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application and
finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information so
these were the advantages of using
servlets in java moving ahead we will
discuss the disadvantages of using
servlets
so following are the disadvantages of
using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated so let's often slow
down the application
business logic of servlet is difficult
to understand we need a jre which is the
java runtime environment on the server
to run our servlets and finally the data
connectivity is a little complicated
so these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets and java moving ahead we
will understand cgi
why are we learning cgi because even cgi
is similar to servlets and it also does
the web interactive job similar to
servlets so thought you should know
about some basics of it so let's
understand its definition and
architecture real quick so the cgi or
common gateway interface is a standard
for writing programs that can interact
through a web server with a client
running on web browser
these programs allow a web developer to
deliver dynamic information usually in
the form of an html via the browser a
cgi program can be written in any
language including java that can be
executed by your web server cgi programs
are commonly used to add search engines
guest book applications database query
engines interactive user forums and
other interactive applications to
websites in very basic terms a cgi
program must interpret the information
sent to it process the information in
the same way and generate response that
will be sent back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through environment
variables so with this we will move
ahead into the architecture of common
gateway interface
so you can see the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to servlet normally the request
is sent in the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells and it
will be processed by the cgi shells
based on the program provided and the
response is sent to the user now moving
ahead we shall understand the
differences between the common gateway
interfaces and
the servlet so the first difference is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes written in native
operating system while on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low compared to
servlets on the other hand servlets are
having high performance compared to
cgi's
the third difference is
for a common gateway interface it is
hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely platform
independent
followed by that the common gateway
interface scripts are directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into bytecode because the
servlets are executed using the java
virtual machine and in java virtual
machine whatever the code you transfer
it will be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable and on the other hand we have
the java servlets to be completely
portable so these are the major
differences between the common gateway
interface and java servlets now let us
understand the java servlets requests
and responses so first we will deal with
the request phase in request we have
various types the first one is being the
http request the http object is used to
represent the http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible through the http
request followed by the http request we
have the request parameter the request
parameters are the parameters that are
sent from the web browser along with a
request
the request parameters are typically
sent as a part of the url or as a part
of the body of an http request
followed by the request parameter we
have the request header the request
headers are the name value pairs sent by
the browser along with the http request
the request headers contain the
information about the web browser
software being used what type of files
that the web browser can receive etc
followed by the request header we have
the input string if the browser sends an
http post request request parameters and
other potential data is sent to the
server in the http request body it
doesn't have the request parameters that
is sent in http request body it could be
pretty much as the data like file or
soap request
the next one is a request session the
session object can hold information
about a given user between the request
so if we have set an object into the
session object during one request it
will be available for you to read during
any subsequent request within the same
session time scope followed by the
request session we have the servlet
context the servlet context contains the
metadata related to the application
followed by subreddit context we will
enter the response phase in the response
phase we will deal with the first one
which is the http response the satp
response object is used to represent the
http response to your request a web
application sends back a response page
to the user as a response to the http
request from the browser sent to your
web application
followed by the http response we have
the right html
to initiate the process of sending the
html back to the browser you need to
retrieve the print writer from the http
response object
this can be done using the right html
followed by the right html we have the
response header similar to http request
the http response includes headers as
well these are responsible for all the
data written in the response followed by
response header we have content type the
content type header is responsible to
tell the browser about the type of
content you are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you about the
number of bytes your servlet is sending
you in return followed by content length
we have redirection
redirecting will help you to redirect
yourself to the different webpage from
the current one so these were the http
requests and responses in java servlets
now we will enter the next part where we
will deal with the session tracking and
cookies so first we will understand
session tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval session
tracking is a way to maintain state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as session management and servlets
http protocol is stateless so we need to
maintain state using session tracking
techniques each time the user requests
to the server the server reads the
request as a new request so we need to
maintain the state of a user to
recognize a particular user you can
understand this in a better way by
looking at the picture shown on the
presentation each time you send a
request you will be receiving a response
from the server as well as this
particular request will be recorded as a
state in order to recognize you as a
particular user now after session
tracking we will enter into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between multiple
client requests a cookie has a name a
single value and optional attributes
such as comment path and domain
qualifiers a maximum age and a version
number by default each request is
considered as a new request in cookie
technique we add a cookie with response
from the servlet so cookie is stored in
cache of a browser after that if the
request is sent by the user the cookie
is added with a request by default thus
we recognize the user as an old user
there are two types of cookies they are
non-persistent cookie and persistent
cooking let's understand non-persistent
cookie first a non-persistent cookie is
valid for a single session only it is
removed each time when the user closes
the browser now let us understand the
persistent cookie the persistent cookie
is valid for multiple sessions it is not
removed each time when the user closes
the browser it is only removed when the
user logs out or signs out from the
browser
so before we begin with what exactly is
a java api we will understand what java
is
so basically java consists of two major
components that are java runtime
environment and java development kit
so when we get into java's api we might
want to dig a little deep into java's
development kit
so jdk consists of three more major
components that are the java's compiler
java virtual machine and apis now we
will learn each one of them in a bit
more detailed way
so at first we have the java's compiler
so java compiler can be defined as a
software program that is designed to
convert the high level that is the user
return or user readable code into the
computer readable code that is the
machine level or byte code so this
particular byte code will be transferred
to the next state where we find the jvm
so what is jvm so jvm is an abbreviation
for java's virtual machine so java's
virtual machine is responsible for
processing all the byte codes and
providing an output to the user
next we find our topic for today's
discussion that is the java api
so just like java's virtual machine and
compiler java's apis are the integral
software packages that come with the jdk
the primary intention of api is to
establish communications between
different applications
so on my screen you can see a pictorial
representation of java api's
architecture so at first we have the
javas program on the topmost layer so
this particular segment will be having
the user return program and user
language
followed by that we have the interpreter
javas api and the java's virtual machine
which are responsible for reading and
compiling the java's program so at the
last final level we have the application
hardware which is responsible for
interacting to the javas program so this
is how the java aps architecture looks
like now followed by this let's dive
into the next topic
so in the next topic we find the types
of developers using various types of
apis for different jobs
so at first we have the open developers
next we have the internal developers and
at last we have the partner developers
don't worry we will understand each of
these developers in a bit more detail
and along with some examples for a
better understanding
so at first we have the open developers
so open developers are used by top-end
companies so leading companies provide
access to their apis as open source
through authentication via a unique
secret key to keep track and ensure the
legal usage so basically what happens
here is there might be some big
companies like social media companies or
some other companies which provide the
api they use for their applications as
open source to the developers so these
open developers get access to their apis
through getting authentication
so they'll be creating a profile they'll
be providing the
research details of their application
like what are they using that particular
api for and other reasons to use those
apis then they get the unique secret key
from the owner of that api
and that's done just to keep track that
the api provided is not misused
so the open developers majorly include
the b2c teams and some of the major
companies that provide the apis for open
developers are twitter and telnex so one
best example is the twitter where the
twitter provides twitter api for the
twitter developer accounts for using
that for any kind of developing things
or
some data science applications and much
more
so followed by the open developers next
we have
the internal developers
so you can consider internal developers
as an organization so the internal
developers belong to a specific
organization and work in a close
environment these apis run with a high
security that can establish
communication between the application
and the application hardware so only the
internal developers that is the
developers belonging to that particular
organization have the access to that
particular api
so this particular type of apis
run on a high security level
so internal developers majorly include
b2c teams b2b teams a to a teams and b2e
teams
so some of the major companies that
provide the internal apis are instagram
google mail and google cloud virtual
machines
next we have the partner apis
so the partner developers are similar or
like internal developers but the only
difference is there is a collaboration
between two or multiple companies for
example consider yourself to be linked
with a different company and you both
wanted to create an application so only
you both can have access to that
particular api that you're using to
create your application
so partner developers majorly use the
b2c teams and the major companies
providing the partner apis are microsoft
and fenextra
so with this we finish the first topic
that was what is api and who exactly
uses it and for what purposes now we
dive into the next segment where we
learn the need for java apis
so why exactly we need java apis
now java apis are used for multiple
reasons but the three most important
reasons for which we use java apis are
to streamline the operations improvise
the businesses and finally create some
powerful applications we will discuss
each one of them in a bit more detail
so the first one is to streamline
operating procedures we have multiple
social media applications like twitter
facebook whatsapp etc followed by that
we have multiple delivery applications
such as amazon flipkart then we have the
fnb such as zomatos swiggy etc so all
these applications are running smooth
and hassle free because of the
significant improvement in the
implementation of java apis by using
java's apis users are provided with
multiple options on the screen so this
kind of approach makes the functionality
very simple and easy to use
followed by this the next important
requirement is
to improvise the business
introducing apis to the public leads
many companies to release private data
to generate new ideas fixing existing
bugs and receive new ways to improvise
operations the twitter developer account
is an example for api that gives
programmers private api keys to access
twitter data and develop applications
followed by that we have the third one
which is to create the powerful
applications online banking has changed
the industry forever and apis offer the
customers ability to manage their
finances digitally with complete
simplicity so this is made possible only
by the use of apis
now followed by this we will dive into
the next topic where we understand the
types of java apis
so basically there are four different
types of apis in java
they are public private partner and
composite we will discuss each one of
these apis in a bit more detail
at first we will deal with the public
api
so what are public apis public means
open so public or open apis are java's
apis that come with the jdk
and they do not have any strict
restrictions about how developers use
them
so followed by the public apis we have
the private apis
so the private or internal apis are
developed for a specific organization
these particular apis will be accessible
through the authentication by only the
employees belonging to that particular
organization
so followed by private apis we have the
partner apis so similar to private apis
even partner apis are having some
authentication process to use so
the only difference is here instead of
one organization we might have two or
multiple organizations and the employees
belonging to that particular group of
organizations will be able to access the
apis and implement them or use them
followed by partner apis we have the
last one which is the composite api
composite apis are microservices and
developers build them by combining
several service apis
now that we have covered the different
types of apis let us now discuss the
categorization of java apis based on the
services that different varieties of
apis in java provide
so data and api services are another way
to categorize java apis other than the
previous type which is the public
private partner and composite apis are
also classified based on their data
manipulation capabilities and the
variety of services they offer so this
type of categorization has four
different types which are the internal
api services external api services crud
operations and user interface services
we will understand each one of them in a
bit more detail at first we will
understand internal api services
internal api services are developed to
offer organizations services specific to
that particular organizations
these services include only complex data
operations and internal processes
followed by internal api we have the
external api external api are open
source apis that developers integrate
into existing application or website so
internal apis are something similar to
private apis and externals apis are
something similar to
public apis next we have the crat
operations so cred apis provide data
manipulation operations over various
data storage units such as software and
service that is sas and relational
database management systems such as
rdbms using standard data storage unit
connecting tools like database
connectivity that is jdbc etc
next we have the user interface services
user interface service apis are open
source apis that allow developers to
build user interfaces for mobile devices
computers and electronics now let's
examine the rules and protocols that
java apis must follow
so that brings us to api service
protocols
the rules and protocols guide the
different functionalities of java apis
so different apis have different service
protocols let's consider an example for
restful api service protocol as an
example
so for a typical restful api developers
must follow the following rules
for a typical restful api developers
must follow these rules
stateless uniform interface client
server cache layer no worries we will
discuss each one of these protocols in
detail first we will discuss stateless
so what exactly is stateless
so since the restful api follows client
server architecture by default it is
recommended that restful api services to
be stateless all the time
next we have the uniform interface the
entities in a restful api are server and
clients
applications that run on global scale
need uniform client and server interface
through hypertext transfer protocol or
http and uniform resource identifiers
uri will allocate the required resources
next we have the client server
the client server model used in the
restful api should be fault tolerant
both the client and server are expected
to operate independently the changes
made at the client and should not affect
the server and vice versa
next we have the cache including a cache
memory allows the application to record
intermediate responses and run faster in
real time a restful api also includes
the cache memory and next we have the
layer
a restful api is built using layers
layers of api are loosely coupled or
independent from each other each layer
contributes a different level of
hierarchy and also supports
encapsulation
next we will go through some frequently
used apis
so this is the list of most frequently
used apis in real time so we have web
api facebook 4j twitter 4g android api
java advanced imaging java data objects
and you can also see the acronyms for
them in the right column so some of them
have no acronyms and some of them have
acronyms for example we have android api
as google java advanced imaging as jai
data objects as jdo etc so moving into
the next slide we have a few more apis
so we have restful apis java media
frameworks java persistent apis java
speech api java 3d java usb for windows
etc and similarly on the right column we
have their acronyms so for java media
frameworks we have jmf for restful apis
we have nothing and java 3d we have j3d
java speech api as js api and few others
so followed by this we will advance into
the next topic where we will discuss
about the advantages of using java's
apis
now using java's apis will help you with
multiple advantages now we will discuss
the most important advantages of using
java's apis
so the first one we have the extensive
sql support apis in java enable a wide
range of sql support services in users
applications through a component-based
interface
next we have applications apis in java
provide effortless access to all of an
application's major software components
and easily deliver services
next we have efficiency
java's apis are highly efficient because
they enable rapid application
development also the data that the
application generates is always
available online
next we have the automation api allows
computers to automatically upload a
download update and delete data
automatically without human interaction
followed by that we have integration
java apis can integrate to any
application and website and provide a
fluidic experience with dynamic data
delivery
followed by that we have scope
java's apis make websites application
and information available to a wide
range of users and audience
followed by that we have customization
java aps enabled developers and
businesses to build applications that
personalize user interface and data
and finally we have the adaptability
java apis are highly flexible and
adaptable because they can easily accept
feature updates and change to frameworks
and operating systems
what exactly is java enterprise edition
the java ee stands for java enterprise
edition which was earlier known as j2ee
and is currently known as jar kataka ee
the java enterprise edition provides a
platform for developers with enterprise
features such as distributed computing
and web services
now let's move further and understand
why exactly we needed java enterprise
edition we needed java enterprise
edition for four major reasons to have
powerful api support to reduce
development time to reduce application
complexity and finally to improve the
application performance so followed by
the need for java enterprise edition we
will move ahead and understand the java
enterprise specifications so in the java
enterprise specifications we are going
to discuss the four major specifications
used by enterprise developers so the
first one being the enterprise
specification followed by that we have a
web specification then we have web
server specification and finally some
other miscellaneous specifications we
shall discuss each one of them in detail
firstly we will move ahead with
enterprise specification so in
enterprise specification we have the
first one to discuss that is the context
dependency injection
the context dependency injection
provides a container to inject
dependencies as in swing
next we have java enterprise java bean
the enterprise java bean is a set of
lightweight apis that an object
container possesses in order to provide
transactions remote procedure calls and
concurrency control
followed by java bean we have java
persistent apis so the java persistent
api are the specifications of object
relational mapping between relational
database tables and java classes
next we have the java transaction api
it consists of java interfaces and
annotations to establish interaction
between java transaction support offered
by java enterprise edition the apis in
the abstract from low level detail to
the interfaces are also considered as
low level followed by java transaction
api we have the java servlet
the java servlet specifications define
how you can manage http request either
in a synchronous or asynchronous way
so followed by java transaction api
which is one of the enterprise
specifications we will move ahead into
the java web specifications
so the first one in the java web
specification is the java servlet
so this specification defines how you
can manage the http request either in a
synchronous or asynchronous way it is
low level and other specifications
completely depend on it
so followed by java servlet we have the
java web socket
so the java web socket is a computer
communication protocol and this api
provides a set of apis to facilitate web
socket connections
followed by websocket we have the java
server faces
so the java server faces is a service
which helps in building graphical user
interface out of the components so
followed by java server faces we have
the unified expression language the
unified expression language is a simple
language which was designed to
facilitate web application developers so
followed by the web specification now we
will enter the web server specification
out of which we have the first one which
is the restful web service so the java
restful api web service provides
services having representational state
transfer schema
next we have the json processing
java api for json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided in a json format followed by
json processing we have json binding so
the java api for json binding is a set
of specifications that provide for
binding or passing a json file into java
classes
next we have the xml binding so xml
binding simply allows for binding of xml
into java objects for example soap is an
xml based protocol to access web
services over http this api allows you
to create soap web services so followed
by the web service specifications of
java enterprise edition we finally enter
into the other miscellaneous
specifications of java enterprise
edition sort of that the first one is
the validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by bean validation api
in java followed by validation we have
the patch applications so the batch
applications provide the means to run
long-running background tasks which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically
executed followed by batch applications
we have java enterprise connector
architecture
so the java enterprise edition connector
is a java based technological solution
for connecting java service to
enterprise information system so with
this we will enter into our next step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install java enterprise
edition
so the basic requirements to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system are you should be having the java
virtual machine from the standard six
edition or more followed by that your
local system should be having at least 1
gb of ram capacity
next your system should be having at
least 250 gb rom space available and
finally you should be having the java
development kit installed into your
local system
now next we will understand how to
install java enterprise edition into
your local system so in short these are
the steps you need to follow to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system first you need to browse into the
oracle official java site then go to
java standard edition development kit
followed by that except the license
terms download the jdk file run the jdk
file as an administrator in your local
system then set up the java environment
i know this looks a little bit complex
but don't worry i will drop a link in
the description box below which will
explain you in a much detailed way how
to install java into your local system
please check that to have a better
understanding of how to install and set
up java in your local system
so followed by this we will learn the
differences between the java standard
edition and java enterprise edition
so the first difference between the
standard edition and the enterprise
edition is the standard edition provides
basic functionalities like defining
classes and objects whereas java
enterprise edition mainly focuses on
high end and corporate type of java
applications
the second difference between the both
is java standard edition comes with only
the standard specifications which will
be used by a beginner and similarly on
the other hand java enterprise edition
comes with some advanced specifications
which support web applications and
servlets
the third difference between the both is
the java standard edition comes with
features like class libraries and
deployment environments whereas the java
enterprise edition has structured
application with the clients business
and enterprise layers
the fourth difference between the both
is
the java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments whereas on the other hand
the java enterprise edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications the fifth difference
between the both is the java standard
edition is preferred and used by
beginners and on the other hand the java
enterprise edition is preferred and used
by experts in java field
the sixth difference between the both is
the java standard edition does not have
authentication whereas on the other hand
there are strict rules and regulations
to be followed when using java
enterprise edition related to
authentication
what is junit
junit is an open source unit testing
framework for java
here the term unit testing framework
comes into consideration
so before moving forth let's check what
is meant by the term unit testing
unit testing as the name suggests is a
way of testing a unit
here a unit refers to the smallest piece
of code that can be fetched out of the
system
it can be a line of code a method or a
class
keep in mind smaller the chunk of code
the better it is
if the tested units are small the tests
tend to run faster providing a better
insight into the code and its
performance
unit testing helps in the early
identification of defects
it enables the developers to spend more
time on reading the code rather than
writing it
and a successful code helps in boosting
the confidence of the developer
then coming back to junit the framework
is used by java developers to create and
test their codes
it is used for unit testing of the
source code and junit works on the
approach of testing a small part then
coding that and continuing the same till
the end
junit testing helps developers to
develop more reliable readable and a bug
free code
every time a new code is added
all the test cases have to be
re-executed to make sure that nothing is
broken
there are graphs in junit that show the
progress of the test
the graphs show green when the test runs
smoothly and it turns red when the test
fails
now when we know about junit let's see
the way to download and install that
into our system
before you go on to install junit make
sure you have jdk and eclipse installed
in your computer system
so
let's go on
first open your browser in the browser
type
download junit
in download ju unit we'll get about
junit
in about junit when we scroll we find
download and install
in download and install
when we go inside that link we will find
two jar files
here let's download these two jar files
when we click on this download button we
will download jar
after the first jar is downloaded let's
go back to that page and download the
second jar file
after both the jar files are downloaded
let's go to the location
here we can see two of our jar files are
downloaded
let's copy these jar files
go to our documents and here in the java
libraries where all the java libraries
are stored let's paste them
after we have pasted these files
we shall open our eclipse
as soon as our eclipse opens we will
first create a project here new then we
shall create a java project
in java project let's name it
junit
installation
click on next
and finish
here
then in this java project
right click on it
and go to the build path option in the
build path option
go to configure build path
here go to the tab libraries
and this side go to add external jars
in add external jars you will get the
location of our two jar files and if you
don't get them you can browse to the
location where you have stored them or
to the location of java libraries
then select these two files and open
them
you will see the two jar files appear
here
then click on apply and close
now come back to junit installation that
is a project right click on it
and click on refresh
then right click on the src folder
go to new and create a package
let's name the package to be
junit install
and click on finish
in this package
create a new class
and we shall name the class
junit
install
and click on finish
now let's create a method over here
in the method we shall type
public void my
j unit
install
and system dot
out
dot print ln
welcome
to my
j unit
welcome to my j unit
testing
now i will add a library over here
library
test
i can see a error now when i hover over
this library
i can see it says import test
so now when i click on it the error is
gone
now we shall run our test and since we
are testing with junit we shall click
here
go on run as junit test
here we shall click on ok
and then we can see
in the console it shows welcome to my
junit testing as we had placed it over
here
here on the left side you can see the
junit report
you can see runs one out of one and
there is no or zero errors and same
there are zero failures
so here in the space provided you can
have as many number of tests as many
bunch of code you want and with the help
of junit you can test any particular
part of the code
the top 10 java project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executor we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
any one which has a good support for
java the most preferable one would be
the eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
motto etc are basically planned and have
reached greater heights today this kind
of project on your resume could make a
huge difference and who knows tomorrow
you might even get into one of those
companies and start working on their
projects or
build a company of your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate as their own choice
with an unmatchable
ease this can be done just by click on
their fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show
online voting functionality followed by
the abstract we will get into the
technicality of this particular project
so the first phase of this particular
project has the admin phase where the
admin has the right to manage the
candidates manage the voters and their
profiles and passwords and finally
election results followed by the admin
we have the voter or the user of this
particular application
the voter or the user gets to register
himself or herself into the application
followed by that he can use the login
and logout options and next we have the
profile and password managements so
followed by that we have the option to
choose the positions to vote and finally
to cast the vote now this particular
project is an advanced level java
project developed to show online voting
functionality it showcases the use of
java servlets html and css again coming
into the ide the ide for this can be
anyone who has good support for java the
most preferable one would be eclipse and
intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online health
care management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-health care management
system is a web-based project developed
in java the main aim of this particular
project is to provide effective
management of data related to staff and
patients in hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows we
need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka
and oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-healthcare management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects so new
features and modules can be easily
integrated into the system in the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a roller
coaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop
the customers can access bank's website
for viewing their account details and
perform the transactions on account as
per the requirement bank employees can
login and add customer and account
information to perform transactions with
internet banking with internet banking
the brick and mortar structure of the
traditional bank gets converted into a
click and portal mode thereby giving the
concept of virtual banking a real shape
thus today's banking is no longer
confined to branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by
customers around the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular project are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account read
raman from the selected account transfer
the amount from one account to another
close the account so the software
requirements for this particular project
are java programming language and and
javascript for scripting language and
oracle for database and tomcat for
server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios many schools and
colleges have now turned towards the
online education system and are looking
forward to hosting online exams for
student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students so the students
can login update their profile and
password select answers for the mcqs
write answers to questions and finally
closing the session and log out this
particular project can be made a grand
success by making use of simple java
servlets and java programming languages
and server like apache tomcat followed
by the online examinations we have the
smart city smart city java project can
be a web-based software developed to
store the details of a particular city
the main purpose of the project is to
help tourists and other visitors to a
city by providing information about
hotels transportation facilities air
ticket booking shopping details city
news etc the smart city java project
serves the visitors as a guide of the
city and hence the project is called as
city guide project in java using this
project the details of the city can be
accessed from anywhere at any time the
implementation of the city project
promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option
booking that option and payment window
finally the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
design drones that can act like a cop
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or comps or
travel agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have the
bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted
to manage security it stores the old bug
reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the
client-side scripting as the javascript
and the id for this particular project
would be eclipse with all the my eclipse
plugins and finally the user interface
can be designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java and pr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing algorithms so
followed by vehicle recognition project
we have a last project which is the
speech recognition system
so speech recognizer converts audio to
text java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus asana
commit changes and finally provide the
process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse
python is a very popular programming
language for application development
data analytics machine learning as well
as ai hello everyone and welcome to our
course on python programming my name is
anish karan and i will help you learn
the fundamentals of python programming
and what programming in python really
means and what it is all about
i am sure there are plenty of you over
here that are watching this video that
have their own reasons and multiple
reasons to start learning programming
and programming in python in particular
our goal over the duration of this
course is to ensure that you are able to
learn python and learn python
programming to a level in which you can
tackle whatever problems you have and
whatever projects you set out to do in
the future now i'm sure you must have
heard that the some of the most upcoming
fields and some of the high prospect
domains in the market right now such as
data science ai machine learning require
python programming and our goal in this
course is to get it to a level where you
can start tackling and creating
solutions to whatever problems you may
occur whether it be in your job or in
your studies or anywhere else or any
personal projects that you may
take up in the future now before we
actually get started on the actual
concepts and the fundamentals of python
i want to show you over the next two or
three videos exactly what how python
came to be what was the philosophy
behind creating this language and
basically a brief introduction behind
python and python programming so python
programming was developed first by a
person a dutch programmer by the name of
guido van rossum and python was first
released by him in the year 1991. now
the design philosophy behind
python was to create a language which
was much easier to read and much easier
to actually code in compared to the
or in contrast to the languages that
were prevalent back in those days such
as the language c
now formally python is an interpreted
high-level general purpose programming
and what this means is that
python is a it's a language that can be
used for a wide variety of applications
as we will see later uh the high level
uh part of this definition basically
tells us that python is written in a
language that is very abstract at a much
higher abstract level compared to the
instructions that a computer can
actually read so in layman's term you
can say that python is a very close to
the actual
language that we humans use and that's
the way python has been designed and the
difference between a high level
programming language and the lower level
programming language is that low level
languages are essentially machine
language instructions that are the
actual instructions that a computer can
actually understand a high level
language like python is something that
we humans understand better and we can
write in it better now the term
interpreted over here essentially means
that we don't need to compile our
instructions that we give in python now
as i mentioned earlier that the
computers or any system that involves
computing needs low level language to be
fed to it so that the computer can
actually understand because computers
cannot understand the way we write our
code and this process of converting from
high level to low level called
compilation and in most languages such
as c there's a special process involved
called compilation which we do after we
create our blocks of code or scripts or
whatever now when we say python is an
interpreted language what this means is
that we can actually work on python and
see the results right at the get go we
can skip this step of compilation
because our system that runs python
actually does all of that uh conversion
from high level to a low level uh
language as we type our code and uh this
actually speeds up the process very well
for us and makes programming in python
and other interpreted languages as well
much much easier for us python is of
course an open source language it's uh
the most bare implementation of python
known as c python is actually
even currently being maintained by a
foundation known as the software python
software foundation so essentially
python is being maintained developed by
a group of very talented developers and
it's open to pretty much anyone to work
with and to create libraries for this
allows python to be an amazing language
in the in the modern world because in
the modern world we have uh different
issues and different problems in
different spheres and domains that we we
would need to update our libraries or
update our packages that we use in our
programming language on a very regular
basis and so python being an open source
language allows us to keep updating and
keep up with the times essentially when
it comes to solving problems now let's
go over some of the features of python
and these features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as i mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
python we since python is open source as
as i already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in python and
we create in a particular system say on
windows
we don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or that
same piece of code on some other system
say on a linux system or
a mac system python itself comes with a
very large standard library this this
facilitates us
a lot because we don't need to
create our own libraries or modules or
have to download very specific libraries
most of the problems that we do
encounter
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python write right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and
as as you will see later
python has one of the most user-friendly
data structures
that can be found in any language
especially compared to some of its
contemporaries now python is a
dynamically programmed language and this
is very important and what this means is
that in most compiler based languages we
there are certain processes that can
only happen during the compilation stage
so
what a dynamic programming language does
is it takes all those
compilation specific
tasks and processes and
it does it for us as we actually type
the code so we don't need to waste time
or spend extra time to do something that
would otherwise be needed to be only
done in compilation we would have to set
out specific uh runtimes just for that
so this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and uh yeah so it's
a it's it's a very important feature
about python now quickly i will just go
over some of the
areas of python where
like
areas of um or
different domains where python is very
heavily implemented and the first one
the first few ones that come to mind are
like web development and
ai and machine learning so you have
technologies like django and flash that
are
built on top of python that
are used extensively for web development
when it comes to something like
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you have uh distribution such
as anaconda you have pandas and many
other libraries like scipy and numpy
that are used extensively to so tackle
problems in this domain and similarly
python finds use in most of the
scientific work that goes on nowadays
because of
again some of the libraries that i have
already mentioned such as scipy
interestingly if you are into game
development or gaming in general you
would see that python actually has
certain libraries and certain
technologies that facilitate game
development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop uh be
creating desktop gui's image processing
graphic design applications and uh
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses
there are many technologies in the
environment of python that
were almost designed for the specific
purpose of
being able to present certain concepts
or to be able to teach certain classes
and
i can't think of too many programs or
too many environments outside of python
that are better to solve these education
and training course related
problems and situations uh so i will
show you how to install python on
windows since i have a windows system uh
however i will also point out uh the way
you you would have to install python on
aim on mac os or linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the downloads
section when you do click on downloads
you get redirected to this website that
uh this webpage that i'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version
but of course if you for whatever reason
if you needed a particular version of
python you can download that as well
by just scrolling down and choosing the
option that you want now it's important
to note that whatever option you choose
of course i would recommend the latest
one but no matter what option you choose
i would recommend you choose a version
of python three point something because
uh previous versions of python uh namely
python 2.7 and uh and basically every
version of python two point something
has it will not receive any more
maintenance and updates
because
the developers have decided that python
will they are trying to shift towards uh
maintaining and updating python
three-point whatever completely right
now so yeah
let's not delay this
any further and just download python 3.9
so once you select the option out here
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now i would of
course recommend this to install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into
the drive where your windows is actually
installed your your main drive so as you
can see now that once my setup is done
it should give me a pop-up soon so my
setup is done for python and this is
essentially how you would um download
python on your windows system but what
if you had mac os or if you were using
linux well for mac it's a it's actually
almost as simple you just go
if you see out here below this download
button python option you get the website
asking you are you looking for python on
a different os and it gives you the
options of linux mac and even other oss
but for mac
if you wanted you would just open this
tab and
just like the windows option you would
so choose a version and you would choose
an installer for that version so if i
wanted to say python the latest one i
would just download this installer and i
would install my mac system now when it
comes to linux i cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the linux option out
here it would take you to a page with
different installers and
essentially packages for linux systems
in specific what i would recommend to
you if you are a linux user and you need
python is to go over to the real
python.com website and
they have a very good uh essentially
instructions on how to install python
and since i don't have a linux system i
cannot directly show you how to install
python on linux so yeah if you do have
linux please head over to this website
and this should be of a lot of help to
you now
as i had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an ios user you
would go to the ios app store and
download an app called the pythonista
app for ios it essentially is like a
full-fledged
python environment where you can develop
in python on your iphone or even ipad
and if you were an android user you
could you would go and download an app
called the pi droid 3.
there's a free version and a paid
version for this app and of course the
difference between the free and paid is
that the paid supports uh code analysis
and code prediction these are certain
details you don't have to worry about
right now and uh honestly if i wouldn't
worry too much about installing python
on your mobile devices currently since
i am assuming most people would be
learning programming and programming in
python on their pcs or laptops now that
we've mentioned how to install python
what i had actually shown you was
installing
what is called an implementation of
python on your system an implementation
is essentially a program or a software
or an environment that allows you to
actually work in python so what i showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
c python uh even though you would not
you would not have seen the word the
letter c or the prefix c
but yeah that implementation that i had
i had downloaded myself and i had shown
you to download
is actually the c python implementation
which is python built
on top of c the the c language
essentially
there are other implementations such as
ironpython which uses the.net framework
and jpython that uses java virtual
machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that i would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python i want to introduce
what is called a distribution view
this distribution is called anaconda
anaconda is a very important
distribution especially if you are
looking to
use python in data science and machine
learning and ai which i am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards the
moving towards data science and if that
is your goal or in any case whatever
your goal may be i would recommend that
you install anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their anaconda is python with
i
in the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that i had shown you
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
would you need to download both of
course not if you download a python you
do not need anaconda to work on python
and
if you have already downloaded anaconda
which i will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so i'll just speak
about anaconda little briefly so as i
said it's a distribution it it it
contains a bundle which includes the
basic python implementation and a lot of
technologies and softwares and
applications
that have essentially helped us to use
python in
in in specifically managing the big data
applications and data science related
projects so so now i will show you
actually how to install python i mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if i did
a quick quick google of anaconda
so the website that i'm looking for is
anaconda.com and i'm looking at products
and i'm looking at individual edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial team edition these are for
companies usually or for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to
this particular webpage where it will
ask you if you want to download and
again there are options depending on
which machine you're using after you're
using a linux you would choose one of
these two if you are using mac os you
would use one of these two and since i
am a windows user and i have a 64-bit
system this is the option i would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been uh downloaded so
upon opening it it will open up this
installation thing
you can just click next on most of these
again if you want to specify your
destination folder you can change it
here mine will be with a default folder
in the c drive and you can leave this
unticked you can you can change these
options much later so
this is how you install an account on
windows and it's pretty much the same on
other systems as well now once it's done
i will show you what exactly what are
some of the things that anaconda
contains that are not there if you uh
installed python like the way i had
shown you earlier just the bare bones
python implementation so as you can see
here my installation is actually
complete
and
now i will open anaconda and i'll show
you what how you can actually use this
anaconda
so if i search for anaconda in my system
i would look for something called
anaconda navigator to actually get
started with this and when i open that
it should open something like this so
this is what opens when you click on the
anaconda navigator and as you can see
there are a bunch of applications you
don't need to worry about what these
mean
right now
uh just understand that this this is
essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install anaconda navigator now now
that we have actually tackled
where we've seen how to install and i'm
hoping and i would recommend definitely
that everyone is watching this video
installs anaconda not just the
normal python uh installation or
implementation uh now that we have
gotten all the introductions and the
basics and the installations uh
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is uh
how do we actually start doing this task
of creating our first python script how
do we how do we realize uh now that
we've installed a python like uh now
let's how do we start doing something so
the answer to that constructions that
you give
for python to run and execute to give
you a certain result so i will show you
how you can create a python script now
there are multiple ways of creating a
python script you can create it directly
from command line which is obviously
something i would not recommend because
it is not convenient and easy and it's
not very useful for the beginner another
way is using a text editor such as the
one i have opened right now which is the
notepad plus plus the text editor now
it's very important to not get confused
uh between notepad plus plus and the
standard notepad that comes with your
windows
or wordpad for that matter in fact text
editors such as
notepad and wordpad
that you are more familiar with create
text and files in a form that is called
rich text now rich text is something
is text that
contains formatting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text
plain text is obviously text which does
not contain these fonts and the
formattings
and it only respects white spaces and
indentations those two being actually
useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents
that is very that was actually created
with programming in mind
obviously you can use a bunch of other
text editors such as whim and atom and
you can google for these there are
plenty of them so
without any further ado let's create our
first python script so one of the most
common one of the most famous examples
of
a first program in any program for that
matter not just python is creating a
print statement that gives us a
statement saying hello world so
in python this is how you would go about
or this is the syntax you would use to
create the statement
all right
now
it is very important when you are saving
your python program that you use the dot
py prefix so if i were to save this i
can choose whatever folder i am going to
choose
any sort of interpreter or anytime we
need to read the script to know that
it's a python script we need to add a
dot py otherwise it will not be treated
as a python script it will be treated as
some normal document sort of a thing so
now that i've stored it as dot p y uh i
have created my first python script now
obviously the next question is i need to
see
what happens when i execute this line
when i run this script essentially so
to see that
there are multiple ways the first way
that i will show you is a command line
method which is obviously again before
we get into it it's not something that i
will be using to teach you it's not
something i would recommend you just
immediately start using um but for the
sake of showing i will show you how to
execute a script in command line well to
do this you go since i have installed
anaconda in my system and i will be
using anaconda to
work in python what i will look for is
something called the anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that i
get anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this
now i am already in the folder i believe
that had my script so
how do i call this script or how do i
run the script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so i enter test dot py if you
if this was in a different folder you
would have to change your folders and
command line which is again something
that i might show you later but since my
file is already in the folder that i am
in in my command line i would just have
to enter this command right now so if i
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what i wanted i wanted it to
print this
these two words
and of course the command line is now
waiting for the next command for me so
this is uh one of the most simple ways
of for the most rudimentary ways of
executing a python script now another
question would be well this isn't the
most visually appealing or
not the easy to read or easy to use way
of
executing scripts and i would agree and
that's why i'm going to introduce a
another technology or a software called
the ide so the ide in python or in any
programming language stands for
integrated development environment it's
essentially a software that not only
allows us to run scripts but it allows
us to create the scripts it allows us to
debug it allows us to see outputs it
allows us to see intermediary outputs uh
it allows us to do a wide variety of
tools and tasks and uh it comes with a
bunch of robust features to enhance our
python programming experience so let's
let's see so i will show you a an ide
called spider which comes bundled along
with the anaconda distribution that i
had mentioned earlier so if i open the
anaconda navigator
as you can see the anaconda navigator
shows me a bunch of technologies and
options and i'm looking for something
called the spider ide which is over here
as you can see here it's a scientific
python development environment uh this
is exactly what i'm looking for so
i am looking to launch this so now that
i've launched it you can see out here
this is what an ide looks like now this
looks very sophisticated and it's it's a
one and any almost any ide is a
wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider id in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have already created our
script in notepad plus plus and i want
to open that script and i want to see uh
how and i how it would the result of
that script would look in an ide so
let's just open it so we can browse for
our file and as i had
named it test this is the file over here
i open this and as you can see out here
in the left hand pane
my script has opened and the commander
had given or had written is out over
here now if i want to run this
application i press this green button
and as you can see the result of my my
execution essentially is over here and
it's in slightly small font but as you
can see over here uh it says hello world
and it's way and the next line is
essentially it's it's waiting for me to
do another execution of the script and
then it will give me new results so
let's actually give the system new
results so now that i have printed
something called hello world let's let's
change what's written over here
let's say i will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what i'm exactly doing these are things
that we will actually cover in the
in upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a
let's store a a number three let's
create a variable b story number five
all right let's get another variable c
uh which will store the result of what's
in a and b in the addition of a and b
all right and let's print the result
or print what's in uh this variable c or
what's the result of a plus b i will
print a statement saying the result of
the addition
of 3 and 5 is all right and i will put
my result over here
as you can see
i should get the result in this pane so
let's execute this and you can see
my first line is executed saying i will
perform basic maths and the next line
says the result of the addition of three
and five is eight so
this in this script what i've done is i
have performed uh two print statements
and i've performed a basic expression
some variable assignments all of these
things we will be doing later this is
what i what i'm essentially trying to
show you is that ides are a very
convenient way of not only creating the
scripts but actually seeing the results
and then making adjustments as well we
can com we can create a completely new
script we don't need to create a script
from some special file or text editor uh
i can just create a new file here and
this is my new script essentially so i
can start working on this new script
right over here from the get go so ides
are very powerful spider ide comes
bundled with anaconda there are other
ideas such as the i idle ide it stands
for
indicated development and learning
environment so the ideal
ide comes
as part of the
basic python implementation that i had
shown you in the previous video where if
you just installed a basic
python
implementation it would come along with
a basic ide known as idle or integrated
development and learning environment but
of course since we are using python and
that is what i would recommend uh it
comes with a more robust ide called
spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific
and numeric applications
and was designed specifically with that
in mind
now
this is not the only way we can actually
work with python there's another very
interesting and
a very educative
method of creating python let's say
python programs and it's something that
i will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called uh notebooks
now
before i get into the details i will
state i will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the jupiter
notebook and when i open or when i
launch the jupiter notebook this is what
i get now
a very important
feature or a
a feature of notebooks is that notebooks
a web browser or a web-based application
so you it's not something that you can
use if you are offline or disconnected
basically if you're disconnected from
the internet it is something which for
which you would need an active internet
connection however it is way more robust
and it has very very good uh
properties that allow it to be used in
education or for presentations and such
so as you can see this is my jupiter
notebook these are a bunch of folders
don't need to worry about what these are
right now
i will show you how to create a fresh
notebook so if you go here now you go to
new and you select under notebook the
python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see
this line is essentially waiting for me
to enter some sort of a command or a
statement that i would give in a normal
python thing now if you would have
noticed the diff in uh until now
everything that we were doing involved
uh creating a script which was the whole
series of commands and functions so if i
go back to my spider ide as you can see
like this is a whole script and this
script contains multiple different
tasks and functions that are
individually uh being performed so this
is a separate print function this is a
separate edition another separated print
function and for longer
programs or larger programs you like you
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like what is
the result of just this print statement
or just this
it's not typically what an ide is used
for and this is where notebooks come in
super handy uh if i had to break down my
previous script essentially where i
first did a print statement where i said
some random thing say hello
yeah so if i execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now i want to do what is 5 plus 3
it should give me the result over here
8. now in the next
another part of your program might be
storing 5 and 3 into variables so i can
do this and i can do this so now this
line will store the variables now i want
to do the addition of what is 5 plus 3
but i want to use the variables and i
want to see what's the result as you can
see a plus b means five plus three which
is eight and i've essentially broken
down various different parts of my
previous script into
into its individual tasks and i'm able
to see what each part of that script
does and this is very good when it comes
to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so i will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
different concepts when it comes to
python and i would recommend that you
get used to
notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to learn python
programming or programming in general in
fact
and again as i had mentioned earlier
notebooks are something that it's an
online application it's a web-based
application so i will have to need a
active internet connection to be able to
work on a notebook which could be a
disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with expressions well an expression in
python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in python is that a
statement in python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as i said
earlier calculation
resulting in between two different say
numbers or other objects that results in
a value and this happens in the case of
an expression so for example if i were
to add two numbers say five plus ten
this is an expression which should where
two objects five and ten are being added
and a result is being given to me which
is 15. now let's see an example of a
statement well a statement could be
something like a print statement so when
i ask python to print something for me
it's not calculating anything it's not
evaluating anything it's simply
performing an action that i have or a
command that i have given the system
which is to print whatever i have
entered over here as you can see so this
is a statement similarly there are
another type of statement known as
assignment statements which we will
learn actually right in the next section
well let's move on to variables right
now now earlier you might have learned
about objects in python so
objects are essentially data
that we can work with or manipulate in
python now variables are a place to
store these different objects
usually
it's much easier to
store objects in python instead of using
the objects explicitly themselves
because objects may be very completely
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply
very unnamed in a very simple manner so
that we can use them quite often in our
programs now it's important to note that
in python we do not have to explicitly
declare or define a variable to create
them in fact variables are created in
the same statement where we assign some
object to that variable in python the
assignment of variables happens using
the assignment operator which is the
equals to sign so if i were to if i
wanted to assign a number say 100 to a
variable say b
well it would be as simple as doing this
now anytime i want to know what is
stored in b i just have to enter b and i
will get the value that is stored in it
and we can store different types of
objects inside a any variable let's say
i store i want to store this particular
word in the form of a string now this is
stored in x and if i want to know what
is an x i can just see what is here and
it's a string hello which i had stored
earlier now it's very important that we
follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program so the
first rule is that you cannot start your
variable name with a number so if i were
to give a variable name like four num
is equal to something say
the same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and i will get an
error when i try this so if i were to
choose a num for
is equal to hello this would be
perfectly fine i won't get an error the
second rule is we are not allowed to use
any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if i were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and i
say i said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if i
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error
as you can see over here next the third
rule is that variable names are case
sensitive so if i have a variable called
num
or say num if this was one of my
variables and i stored say the value of
50. this is not the same as me writing
num all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in python is
that you are not allowed to use what we
call reserve words in python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the python programming
language and we cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them either
you can see over here some of them are
like false def if
uh del reyes and there are like there
are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh
where we try to really understand
what do we mean by storing data inside a
variable now when i say that we are
storing something inside a variable you
get an image or you get an idea in your
head that this variable is like a
container where we store or we put a
particular object inside it so does this
mean that variables have a place in the
memory are they also an object that is
placed in the memory where we can put
other objects inside of well i'll show
you an example where this idea is kind
of disproven or where i'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say i'm storing the same object
i will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and i'm going to
store it into two different variables so
i take x is equal to 100 over here
and in the next line i will store 100 in
y as well now if objects were i mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then x and y should have two
different ids but let's see what happens
when i check the id of x and the id of y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the id of x and the id of
y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
python cannot have the same id so
does this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
i said x is equal to 100 and y is equal
to 100 what i'm actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called x that i want to refer or
point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and i do the
same thing with another variable y so i
am not exactly creating it a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when i do id of x and id of 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called x or the id of something called y
it's giving me the id of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in x and y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what i'm trying
to say and similarly if if i were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see i've used the
value of 50 to explain my point so as
you can see initially x and y are
pointing towards this value 50 because i
have stored 50 and 50 in both x and y
now what if i changed the object that is
stored in x well that means x is now
pointing towards this new object and i
have stored this new object called hello
the string called hello as you can see
here so now x is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello
and
i haven't changed anything with respect
to y so y will point towards the same
thing and i can also make the pointer of
y different or what i'm trying to say is
i can store something else in y see i
stored this list in y 50 60 100 when i
do that now y is pointing towards a
different object in python and x is also
pointing towards something else so what
happens to this object 50 well now that
there's no variable referring to this
object 50 it becomes what we call an
orphaned object and we can actually see
that when we do the id of x now let's go
back to my example on the right where i
stored x is equal to 100 so as you can
see it gives me some id represented by
this number now let's say i stored x i
stored something different index say 200
now if i do the id of x it should give
me a different id because as you can see
the values are different and this is
because this object 200 is what is
stored in x and when i do the id of x
i'm actually getting the id of this new
object now 200. so as you can see point
as you can see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers
instead of containers for a particular
object in this video you will be
introduced to the concept of objects in
python now what are objects in python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
they're usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in python has three
important properties that kind of define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change once once it has been
created so for example if i took an
example of
say a string called hello i can use the
id function which is this is how you use
the id function to find out the id of
this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer as you can see
the id of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in python have an identity we
have another operation with uh regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially
what defines what kind of values and
operations
that that object can have so for example
a numeric dr type in python such as an
integer would allow us to do arithmetic
operations and similarly string object
type in python will allow us to do
concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that i had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string str stands for string similarly
if i did a type for a number say 50
it should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if i were to talk about this
string the string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this
particular object is a numeric object
with the value of 50. let's see in this
in this pictorial representation i have
shown you that you can assume this dash
blue area as the memory of the system
within this memory we have objects
created called 50 and hello and this
list containing smaller objects called
cat pen and 40. now what i'm trying to
show you here is each of these objects
have a type an id and a value and let's
see what they are if i wanted to see as
we had already seen the type of 50 now
let's find the id of 50. as you can see
we get this unique id for the object 50
which is obviously not the same as the
id of the object hello above and the
value of this object is the value of 50
itself so that was a brief introduction
into objects in python in this video we
will cover the topics of numeric object
types and type conversions in python now
let's get started numeric object types
in python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real-life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent numerals that contain decimal
points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8
and so on then there is the complex
object type which is used to represent
complex numbers in python and this is an
example of a complex number 3 plus 7j
this is a complex number 3 plus 7j where
the real component is 3 and the
imaginary component is 7. all complex
numbers have a real and imaginary
component and this is how we denote them
now it's important to note that this j
is a very common symbol in maths and
engineering used to denote the
imaginary portion of a complex number
and it's the same in python as well so
moving on let's talk about type
conversion in python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider
my example string to be
some something called 145 and i'm
showing this within a string for a
reason because i want to convert a
string to an integer so as you can see i
have stored this one four five within my
within a variable x and if i were to
confirm that it is actually an integer i
can use the type function and see that
it is actually an integer str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the end
sim by passing the variable that we want
to convert into the in function and as
you can see this is what i've done over
here but before this i will also store
it into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us
145 but are we sure that it's an int we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us
the answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and
also specify what base we have to treat
the number as
by default when we pass something in the
in function the program or python will
treat whatever we have passed uh within
the string as something in base of
decimal but what if we were to pass
something that is well not in a decimal
well we could do it like this now let's
store y
and in y let's store let's do this and i
will show you what this means x
and i will give a comma and 8. what this
does python is well i want to convert
the string in x
into an integer but i want to treat
whatever is an x as a number of base 8
so 145 is actually 145 in the base 8.
now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if i give
120 and i passed this integer through
the float function i should get 120.0
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the str function we can also use the hex
and the oc function if we want to
convert a particular number to a
hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say i have a number 688 and i
want to convert this into a string i
just use the str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is
this should be an end as we can see but
when we pass when we let's say
we convert it into a string 6 8 8 and
let's store it into some variable let's
call it a all right now let's see what's
in a it gives us 688 in the form of a
string but we can confirm
by checking the type of a it is an str
so it is a string similarly we can use
hex
if we wanted to convert an integer into
its hexadecimal equivalent in the in in
as an output of a string as you can see
this comp this sort of this sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this 0
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that
the letter after this first 0 is the
base of this whole number so it's saying
that x x stands for hexadecimal so it's
saying that 2 b 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths
you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2 b 0 is 688. similarly if
i did oct if i use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this zero is the base of
the number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an oct
represented by this letter o
and the number itself that we are
dealing with is 1 2 6 0 and 1 2 6 0 in
octal system is the equivalent of 688 in
the decimal system so this is how we've
converted a an integer in
an integer into a hexadecimal or a an
octal string now what if we wanted to
convert two
numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if i passed complex 5 and say
say something like 3.1
let's see what this gives us as you can
see it gives us an
a complex object where
our real part is 5 and our imaginary
part is 3.1 so what this does is
essentially
you pass two numbers the first one is
the real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if i
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
i will use the tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say i have a
string called
random let's call it random all right
now if i want to convert this to a tuple
i will use the tuple function as you can
see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component of this tuple
are the individual components or the
individual characters of my string
random similarly if i wanted to convert
the string to a list i would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters
of the word or the
string random and i could do the same
thing with the set function to create
a set of
individual characters of
the string random as you can see here
so yeah these were some of the basic
python
type conversions that i have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence
now strings in python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
python which contain components placed
one after the other where each component
is given what we call an index a numeric
index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and
disposition within the sequence now
since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index zero the second
is index one the third is index two and
so on now let's move on to defining
strings how do we define them well
strings are defined using what we call
delimiters and delimiters occur in pairs
an opening and a closing delimiter in
python these denominators are pairs of
single or double quotes so for example
if i were to use single quotes to define
a string i could i would do it like this
this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if i were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this
this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if i wanted to include a
single quote within my string well
if i try to let's see what happens if i
try to print a statement with a single
quote naturally inside it so say i'm
saying it's
my
birthday
all right let's see what happens if i
try to print this statement it says
invalid syntax and this is because as i
had mentioned in python single quotes in
double quotes are delimiters so they
have a special function in python and we
cannot simply just use them within a
string because python will treat them
specially for a special purpose so what
python will do is it will pair this and
this delimiter so single quotes and say
okay this looks like a string to me and
it's not going to understand the rest of
this and then it will find a random
single quote and it won't find its pair
and it will basically throw us an error
because of this so
one way or one workaround to introduce
single quotes into a string is simply to
delimit our
string itself using the other type of
delimiter or double quotes so if i want
to include a single quote i will close
my string using double quotes so if i
did this instead of what i had done
earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and i could i
would do the opposite if i had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string i would use single quotes to
close it so if i were to write a speech
statement she said
i am
hungry all right i have i want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and i'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has these two double quotes now i
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how are they
sequences so first of all all sequences
in python are a um it's a essentially a
sequence of smaller objects that form
the sequence right so let's try to
understand like how do how are strings
to be treated as sequences some
sequences that we will learn later are
like lists or tuples and in all
sequences
we can retrieve any particular object or
component in that sequence using its
index and how do we use indexes in
python well we enclose a numeric index
within square brackets now let's see
what i'm trying to talk about by this
example now say i'm storing a particular
string called say random within now my
variable name here is test and i'm
storing the string random within it all
right and this is a way of retrieving a
particular uh index from test i write
the variable name and then next to it i
put the square brackets now i'm supposed
to put um a numeral within the square
brackets to tell python like what a
particular index i'm looking for so
let's try zero now as i said python is
zero index based language so
the zero index essentially means the
first part of for the first component of
the sequence so let's see what happens
when i ask python to retrieve the first
part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string r in fact it's just one character
r and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is r so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so
this is so random is essentially a
collection of the string r the string a
the string n and so on together combined
to form the whole string that we call
random similarly if i wanted the
character at the third position of this
thing i would use well since the third
position and since we're working in
python i would use the index 2 and it
should give me the letter n as you can
see it's given me the letter n so this
is how we can show that
strings are also sequences in python
well now let's move on to um certain
string operations and functions that we
can perform well as you have seen
already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we want to know what index
is a particular character at and we can
do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and i want
to know where or what position the
character d is in my string random so
this is how i would use the index
function index and within the index say
i'm looking for the character d and now
i it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer 3. so if i
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is
the index function that we can use for
our strings now what if we want to
say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part we want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say i'm gonna i'm gonna use the same
string called random and store in test
right so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if i went to my
string random a and d is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what i
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice
from the first position
the first index which is the character a
up until the fourth position which is
the character o but it has not included
o so it's very important when i index
like this every every time i put
something to the right of this colon i
am not including this itself all right
so it's essentially one when i say uh
one colon four what i'm telling python
is give me the first the second and the
third character but not the fourth one
so it's given me a n and d and it's
that's this is how we do a slicing
operation in python similarly if i were
to say slice
from the first if i wanted only the
first and the second character i would
do this is what i would do
if i wanted the first
and the second character i would do one
two three so this way it says python
that i want the first i want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
i get a and n now so this is a basic
slicing what if i wanted the portion of
a string from a particular point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where i want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way i would do
this is
test now since i want it all the way to
the left i don't enter any index to the
left of my colon sign and since i want
everything to the left of the fourth
character i enter four here so as you
can see it gives me a r a and d which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if i wanted something to the right of it
i would just do it like this i would
enter some index here and i would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the
indexing in python everything including
the third character all the way to the
right so this is dom as you can see now
another perfectly valid um
slicing is say i want to slice
or take out
different characters from the string but
i want to skip certain characters like i
want this one then i want to skip one
and i want to take the next one and then
i want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step
so one way of doing this is now how do
we read this so as you can see i have
written 0 colon 6 colon 2. so what this
is telling python is i want every
character from my string test
starting from the 0th character up until
the sixth but not including the sixth
after skipping or taking two at a time
taken toward a time can also be assumed
as
skipping one at each step or skipping
one character at each step so what this
will do is it will go to random it will
take 0th one it will take r and then it
will skip the next one so it will not
consider a and then it will pick n and
then it will not consider d and then it
will consider o up until the sixth
character whichever that may whichever
that may be and if you see the output it
gives us r and o which is exactly what
we wanted we wanted r we wanted n we
wanted o where we skipped uh a and d or
we skipped the every second character
essentially so this is a way of um
slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of
a sequence or a string we can use
negative indexes so if i were to for
example show you let's see what this
what this gives me test what what is a
minus one index it gives me the
character m now remember a string is
random so minus one gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if i used test
minus 2 it would give me the second last
character which should be the character
o as you can see here now there are some
other important functions that you may
use in python for that let's create
another let's get another string let's
call it upper
lower all right i'm sorrying it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when i use the upper function
and what happens when i use the lower
function
now i'm going to use the lower function
for this
so these two functions will respectively
give out or give us the result or give
us our string in uppercase and lowercase
respectively so as you can see the upper
function created the first string in
full upper case and the second one
created this this string in full
lowercase now another important and
probably one of the most important
methods that we use for strings
especially when it comes to data science
is the split function so let's see what
i mean by split function let me create
another string let's call it hello world
all right i'm going to use a split
function and i'm going to see what
happens when i
use this function essentially so what
i'm doing in these in this these three
lines is i'm creating the string hello
world i am storing it in test and then i
am using the split function on the test
and whatever result i get i'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
i'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that i have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and i've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or add every comma so for example
if i wrote hello world using comma and
if i put a comma inside over here and
now if i try to execute this
like for example i am going to find i'm
going to look for commas in the string
and i'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening i
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if i introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and it's caused a split
between hello and world similarly if i
in my string if i put this comma again
and i put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
define our split using some whatever we
put in between these uh circle brackets
after the split function it's just
important to note that by default if in
case we do not enter anything over here
it will use blank spaces to do the
splitting
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if i have two
strings first and say another string
second
and i want to join these together well
the operator i would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing let's see what is
the result
as you can see what this has done is it
has combined the first string first and
the string second into one string called
first second so this is the concatenated
concatenation operator now finally uh
the last topic in this lesson is the
topic of escape sequences now escape
sequences are special commands that tell
python to either suppress special
meaning of some character or symbol in a
string or give or give the special or
give some special meaning to an
otherwise ordinary character
um in a string so let's look at the
first example now remember my in my for
earlier in this video where i was i was
telling you like uh what what is the way
of writing or how do we introduce single
quotes or double quotes into a string
and i told you the trick if i want to
use a single quote in my string
i just close it using double quotes or
if i want to use a double quote i close
it using single
well another way of doing this is using
what we call an escape sequence and an
escape sequence in python is the
backslash character all right so let's
see what happens when i use the
backslash character where i want to
introduce my single quote so if i use my
previous example where i wanted to
introduce a single quote and say
i am going to close it using single
quotes as
well so i'm going to go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if i
used the escape sequence that i
mentioned the escape sequence is just
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where i want my my
single quote so i introduce the
backslash now i have my single quote and
i continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python
to not read this
special character or the single quote do
not treat it specially and let it be as
a part of the string so as you can see
that's what's happened here now the next
case or the other
use case of escape sequences is when we
want to
give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so um let's take the example of
the character t and the character n we
use the character t to introduce tab
space um and we use the character n to
introduce what we call line brick well
let's see by an example so normally the
character t has no special function
so the character t within a string will
just
be outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here i'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is the larger than normal space
similarly if i were to use the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call
a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where i have this combination of
backslash n a line break has occurred so
uh there are plenty of other escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and
these are just two of the probably the
most common ones that are used so yeah
this was an introduction into strings in
python in this video i will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what a sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to uh
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way
or a simple list that i have just
created and assigned to a variable a
which contains three objects one two and
three let's talk about some of the
features of python lists python lists
are ordered and what this means is that
even if two lists contain the exact same
elements if they if the elements are
placed in a different order the two
lists are actually unique and different
and i can check that over here i have
created a list one two and three and see
if i create another list 2
and 1 and 3 the same elements were in
different order i will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when i use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see i
get the value false because even though
i have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where i
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making or as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if i created a
list right now where
say if i want to store some numbers
say some floating point numbers now
and i can put strings
as well into my list all of these are
valid
when it comes to objects that can be put
inside a list we have no such
restrictions so we can put any arbitrary
objects inside our list the final
property that i want to talk about is
that lists are
they can be nested to any arbitrary
depth what this means is that i can put
a list within a list and i can keep
nesting it essentially by putting
as many lists i want within my list and
i'm only essentially restricted by my
system's memory so if i created a list
like this
within this say i put another list and
within this list i put another list i
can keep going on
by keep going on doing this and i'm only
restricted by the memory of my system
that i'm using so moving on let's move
on and talk about some important list
operations that we will be doing when it
comes to lists so let's create a basic
list called a where i'm storing six
numbers so now say if i wanted to
retrieve a particular element say if i
want to find out what's on the index
three this is how i would do it if i
wanted a slice of my original list and
much like strings i do it the same way
so what this does is it tells python
that i want all the elements of list a
from index 1 to index 4 but not
including index 4. so it will give me
one two and three index
objects so it should give me two three
and four in this case as you can see
here two three and four i can do the
same thing by considering elements
say two at a time if i wanted to
consider elements or consider every
second element what i would do is this
syntax i would use this syntax and when
i give this command to python what it
tells what it understands is i want
every element from a
from index 1 to index 4 but not
including index 4 but i am going to
consider two
every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then skip one
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so i'm taking
strides i'm not considering elements
consecutively but i'm skipping certain
elements in between
if i wanted to consider every third
element i would change this to three and
fourth element i would change this to
four all right so let's see what happens
when i take every second element it
should give it should give me uh it will
consider say from one to
index three right so it should consider
essentially
this section but since it's going to
skip one it's going to consider this
skip this and then consider this it
should give me two and four as you can
see it has given me two and four and
like in other
sequences we can use negative indexes as
well negative indexing essentially
starts looking from the right hand side
of the list so when i say a minus one
it's essentially looking at the last
element of the list so it gives me the
sixth or the last element which is the
which is object six if i did a minus two
it gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the
what this tells the system is i want the
list a but with all the elements
reversed so as you can see i get my
element uh my list a but the elements
have been reversed right now let's move
on to uh concatenation and replication
well concatenation much like in strings
is done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if i'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this
now let's see what's in a
as you can see my original list has a 7
8 9 added to it and i can also add
things to the beginning of a list
similarly so if i wanted to add say
zero
you know at the beginning of a list i
just do it like this
and i get the element zero added to it
it's very important to note that i
i actually added 0 within a list because
if i did 0 like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an int object and it's
not a list but when i put the square
brackets i make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if i did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where i'm repeating
the values in a twice if i did a star 3
it's the same function
but now i'll have the elements repeated
thrice as you can see here let's move on
to modifying list values
this also shows the mutable property of
lists that i had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so i created
a list with elements where there's three
strings eggs apples and carrots and i
have
five int objects one two three four and
five
now if i wanted to change say the first
element
all i have to do is take the zero width
index
and say if i want to replace eggs with
say mango this is how i would do it
now i will replace eggs with mango if i
check what's in b
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly i can
use the slice syntax to replace a
particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so let's look at this
um i'm replacing i want to replace the
first three elements i want to replace
mango i want to replace apple and carrot
so what i will do is i will consider
this since this carrot is the second
index so i will consider 0 to 3 because
the third is not counted now i'm going
to replace this with three different um
let's see tv
and say sponge now let's check what's in
b you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact i don't have to
replace like for like if i want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if i want to replace the first three
elements kv orange and sponge
with
just one element this is how i'll do it
let's say
wine
now let's check what's here as you can
see three elements have been replaced
with one mine i can do it vice versa as
well i can replace smaller number of
elements with a larger number of
elements but here there is a slight
caveat that i want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if i wanted to replace the first element
wind with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index
and then put whatever objects you want
say i want to add instead of wine i want
to add beer i want to add
ball
and
say
club yeah well let's see what happens
now if i say b check what's inside my
now you can see my elements have been
added but they seem to have been added
as is you know
i had entered a list over here and that
whole list has been replaced
or this vine has been replaced by this
whole list in the first position but
that's not exactly what i wanted i
wanted the elements within this list to
be individually placed into my list and
the way to do that is not this syntax
but actually what i'm going to show you
now if i want to replace one if i want
to replace the index of the object at
index 0 i would give this statement a
slice statement where i will give 0
colon one so when i do this and if i
so let's create my old scenario again
where i had one
and i had one two three four and five
now if i do this b
zero but i give a slice then this slice
is essentially a single object slice
it's essentially the zeroth index again
but because of this
formatting or this this type of syntax
that i'm using
what python will do is now when i say
beer
and
ball
and club now what python will do is it
will not consider this whole list and
add it to in place of
wine or whatever i want to replace it
will actually consider the elements
inside of this individually and then
replace so if you see here
now if you see my list i actually have
the
i've removed wine and in place of it
i've put beer ball in club but these
three are actually individual objects
within my list and not objects within a
list that is then placed within my
original list so this is an important
caveat that you should take note of so
moving on let's talk about certain
methods associated to lists let's take a
simple list now one two and three the
first operation that i want to show you
or the first method is the append method
so when i do a append and say if i want
to append the list by one object called
4
i just do it like this now let's see
what's in a i put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if i wanted to
append
three different objects i want to append
5 six and seven now let's see what
append function does
oh no as you can see it's done a similar
operation to what we have seen earlier
when we gave a single index or the
single element replacement uh that we
saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what i
wanted i wanted 5 6 and 7 to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what i'll
show you next now if i want to extend
say the original list by three different
elements 8 9 10 when i use the extend
function it will not put this whole
thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what i wanted now the next
method that i want to discuss is the
remove method
so the remove method is what you how you
use it is within the parenthesis you put
the
object that is present in the list that
you want to removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if i want the object
8 all right this number if i want 8
itself removed what i will do is put the
value 8 here and it will remove it from
my list so if i check my list a as you
can see the value 8 has it's gone a next
another similar function to remove is
the pop function now the pop function by
default will remove the right most value
from the list but unlike remove the pop
function actually outputs a value and
that value is what we have popped out of
the list so by default it will pop out
the right route right most value of a
list or rightmost element of a list and
in this case that element is 10 so it
should give me 10. but of course if we
want to pop out any particular object in
this case we do not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if i
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list um as i can see it's
in index 0 1 2 3 4 it's the fourth index
so if i want to remove the list which is
at the fourth index i give the index
value inside the parenthesis and it pops
that out for me as you can see over here
so this was it for lists let's move on
to tuples next so tuples are another
ordered collection of objects much like
lists but they differ from lists in two
key properties first of all the tuples
are defined using parent thesis instead
of square brackets so this is how i
would define a tuple with elements one
two and three and the next very
important property that is different or
that differentiates tuples from lists is
that tuples are immutable and what this
means is that once we create an object
of type tuple we cannot make any
modifications to it we would have to
only create a new object if we wanted
something different and this is
obviously a key difference between a
tuple and a list but apart from this uh
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so
any operation that we did to lists that
did not modify the list or that does not
do any modification we can actually
apply to tuples as well so if i wanted
the first element of this dupl all i
have to do is call it by the index 0 it
should give me the value 1 as you can
see if i wanted a slice i can do that as
well it should give me two and three and
if i wanted to reverse my tuple well i
can use my same neat
technique that i've used for lists and
that i can use for the sequence i mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use tuples over list well one important
difference is that when we con when we
make a program execution where or where
we are manipulating a tuple if we did
the same thing for the exact same
objects in uh that if it were present in
a list it would be much faster than a
tuple essentially program execution is
just faster on tuples when compared to
an identical list so use tuples over
list when we want to be efficient while
we are creating an ordered list of
objects so whenever we create an ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is
when we are using dictionaries
dictionaries as we will see later is a
data type in python that needs an
immutable component
while we are creating the dictionary so
if we
want to use
uh something that is like a list but
since lists are mutable we can use a
tuple instead and use that when we are
creating our dictionary and we will see
like what uh what i mean by uh the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuple
over a list a brief section on tuple
unpacking and packing is what i would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when i create when i give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be
me packing this tuple into a object or a
variable t now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that i can unpack a tuple
onto another tuple so let me show you
what i mean by that so now that i have
packed one two three and four tuple into
t let's unpack it into another tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this tuple and i put this
into t all right now let's see what i
mean by unpacking something onto
something let's see what's uh what what
what happens when i put a if i just want
to see what's in a it actually gives me
the value 1 if i see what's in b it
gives me the value 2. if i see what's in
3 giving value 3 and d gives me value 4.
so essentially if you think of it what i
have done is i have matched this tuple
then put it into t and then put that
tuple t into this tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been
or a better way to say this would be the
element 1 has been packed on to or
unpacked onto a 2 has been unpacked onto
b 3 has been unpacked onto c 4 has been
unpacked onto d to show you what i've
done in a single line is essentially
this
this is essentially what i've done
i have assigned 1 to a 2 to b 3 to c 4
to d i have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only uh
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this tuple and
the elements on this tuple
should be equal so if there are four
elements here there should be four
elements here all right i in fact
another very important thing about or a
neat feature is that we don't really
need to mention the parenthesis when
we're doing this uh unpacking or packing
so if i did x
comma y comma z if i did it like this if
i put say five and six and seven this is
also a valid way of packing and
unpacking so now if i see what's the
value in x it is actually five if i see
what's the value in y it is six if i see
what is the value of x and z it should
give me a tuple containing five and
seven as you can see over here so this
is a neat feature of tuples called
packing and unpacking so yeah in this
video we will cover concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in python
there are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items in dictionaries
are paired using keys unlike in lists
and tuples where the objects are
assigned numerical indexes to define a
dictionary we use curly braces each key
value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
i have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each of the pair themselves are
separated by commas and these are
enclosed in curly braces to define the
whole dictionary in this
example
these are the keys banana apple and
grape and their respective values are
yellow red and green so this is very
important that in this particular
data type we have what we call a key and
that key is assigned a value and we can
have multiple such pairings and we have
three such pairs in this particular
example another example or the or
another type of way to define a
dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see i
have
inputted two value or two object tuples
this is a tuple this is a tuple and this
is a tuple and when i use it in a dig
function
when i place it within a list what
python will do is it will consider the
first element of each tuple as a key
and
the second element of each tuple as its
respective value
now if i check what's in d as you can
see the key banana has a value yellow
the key apple has a value red the key
grape has a value green this is another
way of defining dictionaries
an important
note over here is that the
the objects that we use for keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists
as an example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
keys also keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with
or should i say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have a mutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if i
created a dictionary with a key say
banana
and if i gave if i associated with it
a value green i cannot create
another key banana and associate
a value yellow let's see what happens
when i actually do this if you actually
see
what has happened here is python has
considered the second case so it's it
first looks at the first pair it goes
okay so my dictionary has a key banana
with a value green but right after it
sees another key banana with the value
yellow so it overwrites my first key
banana with the second key and it
overwrites the first value green with
the second value and we essentially get
one key banana with the second value
yellow so obviously this is uh python
does this to avoid duplicates however if
i
created a dictionary with a key banana
again
if i created i gave it a value yellow or
say green if i created another
key and if i gave this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not
nothing special will happen in this case
because values do not have to follow
such rules let's speak or let's see
certain dictionary operation operations
and functions now so let's bring back
our
original
dictionary which we had created earlier
with the three pairs all right so what
if i wanted to
we can use keys to
essentially do these operations and
functions let's see what happens when we
so much like how we use sequence how we
use indexes in example of sequences we
use keys when it comes to dictionary so
let's see what happens when we use a key
over here
so we actually know banana is a key in
this dictionary let's see what happens
when we do where we give this command it
actually gives the value associated with
that key which is yellow what if we
wanted to change a particular value
associated to a particular key i would
give i would do this i would give the
key and assign it
the value that i want to change it with
all right now if i check my dictionary
you can see the key banana no more has
yellow value but the value gold what if
i wanted to add a new pair you know a
new key with a new value completely i
would do it pretty much the same same
way as i did in the previous step i
would
essentially write my new key whatever i
wanted say if i wanted a new key called
watermelon i would assign it a value
red
and now if i check my dictionary
at the end of the dictionary you will
see that my
new key pair key value pair has been
added watermelon red as you can see over
here now what if i wanted to remove if i
wanted to remove a key value pair from
my dictionary i can use the delete
function which is
called by using this the del function
now how do i do it say if i want to
remove the key value apple in red so all
i have to do is do d e l
d and within square brackets i have to
only mention the key i don't even need
to mention the value just the key so
you can probably draw parallels in how
we use indexes when it comes to lists
and tuples and even strings and how we
use keys when it comes to dictionaries
they are quite similar so if i did this
and if i um oops i think red is actually
not a key as you can see red is a value
my
key is apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if i see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operations that we can do
for dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is
enter a key inside the parent thesis and
it will get the value associated with
that key so
if i gave the key great let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green
there is also x
that returns the key and value pairs in
our dictionary as a list of two object
tuples where the first object is
the
key and the second object is a tuple so
let's see what it does as you can see it
gave me a
list and in this list the
objects inside the list are two object
tuples where the first object is always
the key and the second is the value and
it's the same for each of the tuples so
this is what items function does let's
see what uh the next so the next
function is keys let's see what the keys
function does as you can see it returns
a list of all the unique keys within our
list i mean within our dictionary
similarly we can there is a function for
values as well and as you can see it
returns all of the different values that
are present in our dictionary in the
form of a list also it's important to
note that if we have a particular value
that has occurred multiple times in a
dictionary it will appear as many times
it has occurred in the dictionary or
appeared in the dictionary in our list
over here when we use the value function
so if say a particular value say i had
another key where its value was green
again so i would have the value green
appear in this list once more
essentially our next function is pop
item what this does is
much like the
pop function in list
it gives us the last entered
key value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon
key watermelon with the value red and
that's what has popped out when we give
this function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so
say if i had a dictionary let's say i'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where
i have say
some key called key v so as i had
mentioned i will use two object tuples
in this case
and
let's say i give this also a value green
all right and another
pair would be
say mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called key v with value green
and another key mango with the value
yellow and i already have a dictionary d
with
these values all right
now if i want to merge these two
dictionaries i can use the update
function what i do is say if i want to
merge d with x or x with d only the
ordering will change and that doesn't
really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if i want to merge d
with x i use d update and then inside it
i put my target dictionary now when i
check what's in d i have the
the the dictionary x and its key value
pairs
merged inside my original dictionary d
as you can see i have my original ones
here and i have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video i will explain what we
call the
type hierarchy or the standard type
hierarchy and python it's also known as
the data model in python and it probably
has other names so essentially in the
what we do or what we speak about in
this is uh how the different types that
we use in python are categorized and
classified and what are their subtypes
so it's important to note before we
continue further that there in future
versions of python there might be new
types that are introduced or the
existing ones may be modified but it's
safe to say that
what i will speak about in this video
will still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the nun type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
functions or it's you it's returned as
the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it
then there is the ellipses ellipsis is
something that you might encounter later
it is accessed through the built-in name
ellipses
it is used to indicate the presence of
this particular um syntax this
particular symbol or expression uh or
syntax in a slice its truth value is
true again don't worry too much about
ellipses right now next is numbers and
numbers is something that we are very
familiar with we have seen we work with
numbers a lot they are an immutable type
they are created through numeric
literals and they are the outputs of
arithmetic expressions and built-in
arithmetic functions its subtypes are
integers floating point numbers and
complex numbers
within integers you have plane integers
that represent numbers in the range uh
this number and this number so these
this numbers basically the largest
positive value that you can represent
using 32 bit notation in two's
complement and this is the equivalent
for the the negative the negative side
long integers on the other hand are used
to represent numbers in an unlimited
range that is only subject to the
available memory of your system so these
are two types of integers and as we know
floating point numbers represent machine
level double precision floating point
numbers or numbers with a decimal point
and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating point number that represents a
real part and a floating point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed
by natural numbers so each element in a
sequence has an index and that index is
a natural number the different types of
sequences are based on the mutability
whether the objects can be changed or
not is essentially what we mean by
mutability right once we create an
object whether we can modify it or not
that is how we differentiate different
types of sequences so there are
mutable and there are immutable types
now the different types of immutable
ones are strings we know what strings
are they are sequences that contain
characters unicode is the other
immutable sequence and then there are
tuples tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are
sequences that contain unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and
there is only one currently there is
only one built in
mutable sequence in python and that is
lists
lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects
finally we have well not finally but
next we have mappings and mappings are
again
sets of
objects but these objects are now
indexed using arbitrary
index sets you know the difference
between a mapping and a sequence you
could consider
sequences are ordered but mappings are
not ordered and
the indexes given to the objects and
sequences are always numbers they are
natural numbers whereas in mappings they
are not natural numbers but they are
certain arbitrary objects that we can
set for ourselves again in python there
is only one built in standard
mapping type that is the dictionary
dictionaries are there they represent
finite sets of objects indexed by nearly
arbitrary values the only condition is
that these indexes must be of an
immutable data type so these uh so what
i have mentioned until now are probably
the most common data types that we
encounter uh or that we have encountered
now the next types are like callable
types such as user defined functions
user defined methods built-in functions
built-in methods classes and class
instances so again callable types as a
whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming
and methods and functions and such the
other type are modules so modules are
module objects or modules essentially
are referenced or called using the
import function again modules can be
considered as these large libraries or
larger pieces of code or applications
that we
that contain various different methods
and functions and objects and classes
within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will during the course of this uh
tutorial we
or during the course of this uh
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions
where we create file objects out of
these files these are what we call file
data types
finally there are internal types that
are used by python interpreter again
this is something that does not concern
us right now but just know that
the interpreter for python uses these
data types for its functioning so this
was again this was a very brief um
introduction or explanation into python
type hierarchy in this video i will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so a simple
addition operation would be like 5 plus
6 giving me the value 11 i can do 5
minus 3 that's subtraction similarly i
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where i
use the backslash so say i did division
of eight divided by two now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the floor division where we
use a double backslash and what this
does is it returns us the largest whole
number that is lesser than the result of
our division so the division difference
between the float division and the
normal floored and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say i did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when i do 9 double
backslash 2. it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call flow division
essentially finally we also have
if you want to raise something to the
power of something so if i want to do 5
i'll say 6 raised to the power 3 because
i would use double asterisks and this is
how i would do it it give me 216 as you
can see
if i wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers i
will use the percentage sign so if i
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how i
would do it i get the answer one as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end alright so let's see
what we mean by this i am creating so as
we know the and operation returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so
that's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value of
false actually should be done like this
false so now
uh think of it like one and zero so one
and zero is obviously zero right so if i
did a
and
b i should get the answer false or zero
because i'm doing true and false so it's
like doing 1 and 0. so if you see this i
should get the answer false if i change
this to true as well now if i do this i
will get the answer true as you can see
the next logical operation is the or
operation where
well logical or is if either of the
operands are true then we should get the
answer to our order operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if i did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if i change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us false if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is the logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the
value that we get
is true if the operand is false so let's
take a as we know a is false over here
so if i did not a i should get the
answer true but if i change this to true
now if i do not a i should get false as
you can see so this was the
logical operations let's move on to the
next set of operations that is
comparison operations so there are a
bunch of them let's go over them one by
one if i want to check if two operands
are equal so if i did x is say equal to
two and now y is equal to three if i
want to check if they are equal i will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal i will get the value true
if they aren't it will get value false
as you can see since x is two and y is
three as you can see x and y are not the
same so there's false they are not equal
if i change this also to two now i will
get the answer to another the next
comparison is the x uh not equal to or
where we use the exclamation sign so
over here this is this um the result of
this is true if x and y are not actually
it's the same so i should get false over
here as you can see but if i change this
to say 5 now i will get true because x
is not equal to y in this case the next
one is greater than so if i did x
greater than y as we can see 2 is not
greater than 5 i will get false over
here similarly there is a lesser than if
i did x lesser than y i should get true
over here as you can see well there's
also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if i say x is
less than or equal to 3 i should get
true because x is 2.
and if i put 2 here i should also get 2
but what if i put 1 here since x is
equal to 2 and 2 is not less than equal
to 1 this is a false statement and i can
do the same thing with like this using
the greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1. and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if i did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if i
did
say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called b and call this
five all right so now if i did a plus
equal to b what this will do is it will
add b to a and then store it in a so
let's see what this does once i do this
now let's check what's in a it should be
5 11 as you can see 16. so this a plus
so this plus equal to sign is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same
there's a similar thing for this the
negative sim or subtraction as well
minus equal to so now that a is 16 and b
is still 5 of course if i did minus
equal to b now i'm subtracting the value
5 from 16 so i should get a is equal to
11 again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus b a is
equal to a minus b i mean as you can see
so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say b is equal to
i will say 2 all right now if i do a
star
star equal to b what this does is it
multiplies b to a and then assigns it
back to a so if i see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if i did a is
equal to 6 and b is equal to 2 and if i
did a sorry for division so if i did a
division symbol and
equal to sign and then if i give b what
it will do is it will divide a by b or 6
by 2 and it will assign that back to a
so my value on a should be 3 as you can
see here 3.0 obviously this is a single
single backslash so this is a float
division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float i can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if i did a is equal to 7 now
and then b is equal to 3. now if i did a
double backslash equal to b now it will
do the same division but
uh it will do a floor function so it
should give me 2 in this case if i did
the same thing
with a single backslash just to show you
the difference between single back slash
and double backslash division in this
case it will give me
the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment um say a is equal to say 5
now b is equal to 2. now if i do a
percentage symbol equal to two i mean
the it should give me it will assign the
uh it'll take the modulus on both sides
and then assign it to the left and the
operand now let's see what's in a as you
can see it it did a divided by two the
modulus symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by b and then give me the remainder and
then put that remainder back in a and as
you can see that the remainder of five
divided by two is 1 and we get that over
here similarly we can also do
exponential so if i have a is equal to
say
5 b is equal to 2 and i want to raise a
by if i wanted to raise the value of a
by the value of b and then store that
back in a this is how i would do it so
it should be 5 to the power 2 which is
25 as you can see here so this is
assignment operations so finally we move
on to
uh two special sets of operators one is
the identity set identity operators and
the other is the membership operators
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to one thousand and one
and b is equal to one thousand plus one
all right if i did a is equal to two
this is an equality check are they the
same values true now if i say a is b
let's see what happens as you can see
it's false this is because this object
and this object are not the same and
this is what the is operation does we
can confirm this by checking the id of a
the id of a gives us some value like
this and the id of b gives us as you can
see a different value so the two objects
are not located in the same place in the
memory as we have seen using the id
function and that is what we check
through the is operator and the is not
is essentially just the opposite of that
so so that is the identity operator now
the membership operator is used for
checking whether something is present in
a sequence or not so let's create a
sequence i will create a list to
show in this example my list is one two
and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
i will check whether now say two in a so
is two in a if it is it will give me
true as you can see is 5 in a it should
give me false because 5 is not in a and
the a not in operator is just the
opposite of that it checks the other
condition essentially so this is the
membership operators in python in this
video i will be speaking about what
precedence or what importance each
operator has when you use multiple of
them in a particular statement or a
command this is what we call operator
precedence so of course there's
confusion when we don't know which
operator has precedence over the other
and in python there is a strict
precedence that is followed in such
scenarios so this table gives us the
precedence so as we can see the
the operators at the top are at the
lowest precedence and as we go down we
get operators with higher precedence
over the ones above them so the low of
the operators that we have seen the or
operator the and and the not have the
lowest precedence so or and not and then
we have comparisons and identity
operators such as the equal to equal to
sign the exclamation equal to sign so
these operators come at the next level
then you have addition and subtraction
followed by multiplication division
modulus and flow division and finally
the highest precedence of all the
operators that we have seen till now is
the exponentiation or the double
asterisks so let's see a couple of
examples that explain this point a
little more so as we can see in this
line we have 20 plus then there's a 5 an
asterisk 3 minus 25 and we want to know
like okay what is the precedence in this
case so as we know we have the plus sign
we have a minus sign and we have the
asterisk sign so we have addition
subtraction and multiplication so which
one will take precedence over the other
well let's refer to this table as you
can see the addition and subtraction
have lesser precedence over
multiplication so this multiplication
will happen first so we actually do 5
into 3 first we get 15 after that we do
plus and minus so we get 5 into 3 15
then we add it or we can subtract it
over 25 that does not matter so we do 5
into 3 15 and then we do 20 plus 15
which is 35 minus 25 so
we should get an answer 10 as you can
see we do get the uncertain another
example would be
where we have this plus symbol we have a
double asterisk talking which shows
exponentiation and a subtraction and a
division so again as we know
exponentiation has the highest
precedence so in this whole operation or
this whole expression we first do uh the
operation associated with the
exponential so we do 5 to the power 2 or
5 exponent did exponentiated by the
power 2
so we have 5 to the power 2 which is 25
now we look at okay once we have that we
still have a addition and we still have
a subtraction and we still have a
division symbol and as we know division
takes precedence over addition and
subtraction over here so once we do this
we finally move on to this step where we
do the division of 6 divided by 2 where
we get 3 so we have 25 from this 5 to
the power 2 which is 25 and we have 3
over here so now we do 20 plus 25 which
is 45 minus 3 which is 42 and as you can
see that is the answer over here let's
look at
the precedences when it comes to certain
of the certain um comparisons or uh the
logical operations or the comparison
operations so as to speak so i've
created a variable called season with
the string summer i have created the
variable age with the value
with the string 10. so you don't need to
put it in the string so i have the into
object 10 and i have the color uh a
variable called color with the string
pink now i'm going to see in this line
i'm going to do an if and else statement
so if you don't know what an ifn
statement is just follow along with me
so what this does is if this condition
is met i will print this statement
otherwise else i will print this
statement now what is this first
condition it is saying
season equal to equal to summer whether
this variable is equal to the string
value or
as we know about the or operation age is
equal to this and color is equal to
equal to pink so as we can see in our
comparisons
and our logical operations the
precedence for or and not is or is the
lowest precedence uh and is above that
and the not is above that in this we
have the or and we have the and so of
course the first check is the and
function so it's going to check whether
this whole condition and this condition
are
it's gonna come it's gonna do that
operation so it's gonna do this and this
so is color pink color is indeed pink
okay so this this part is true now let's
see if this part is true as well now
once we're going to check whether this
is true or not what we need to see is
this condition itself has an or
statement so the first part of it is
saying is season summer season is indeed
somewhere as you can see here next part
is saying is age greater than 0 but this
does not matter since the or function
just needs one of the operands to be
true and in this case this is true in
this case it is also true so this is
this whole statement is true as well so
once we have this statement as true and
then this statement is true we can we
finally move on to we come back to this
and statement and we say since both the
operations all both the operands i mean
are true the resultant of this and
should also be true and since this is
true this whole condition we actually
move into this section of our ins if
else condition where we say okay we can
do this statement this print statement
and we do not have to print this
particular thing so
our answer should be our result should
be the
printing of the string this string okay
and as you can see the ok string is
actually what is printed over here so
this is
an example on operator precedence of
course it's it always helps to you know
try to
fiddle around on your own uh
create random expressions out of like
out of the top of your head and see how
exactly python is evaluating that and
try to understand break it break it down
on your own and this is probably the
best practice you can do to understand
operator precedence in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in python so starting off
what is this math module well
the python map module is an important
library or a feature that is designed to
deal with mathematical operations this
math module is part of the
basic python installation so you don't
have to install this separately
to use this math module all you have to
do is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import
math and this will import your math
module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video i will be showing you certain
um concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the math module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmic
functions
power functions and even trigonometric
functions that we can do using this math
module and the functions inside the math
module so starting off let's look at
some of the constants that are part of
this so as you can see
the standard constants are available uh
in this module are pi there is tau there
is euler's number nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity uh so let's look at
this one by one so starting off
our first constant is pi
um
pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circle's circumference
to its diameter and pi is an irrational
number uh you know the value of pi is
3.14 something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this
pi constant is as simple as this once
you have imported maths uh the maths
module all you have to do is do math dot
pi and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and
the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default uh thing for python that if
you call the pi constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle three it can be in n
units three meters or whatever you want
and you want to find out its
say circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if i had to find the
circumference of a circle in my scene my
code for some application with the
radius three or all i would have to do
is use the formula two pi r and uh to
call the value two pi r instead of
specifically writing three point one
four something i can just use this
function math
dot pi over here
and then i can enter
the r
as you can see it will return me the
radius as you can see so moving on uh
the next constant that we will talk
about is tau tau is uh similar to pi
in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius pi is the
ratio of a circle's circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio of a
circle's circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and
much like pi if you call the tau
constant in
you from the math module it will also
return you a float number and
to find that this is the function that
we use or this is the syntax so as you
can see this is this is actually 2 times
the value of pi 6.283 and even this is
returned correct up to 15
places to the right of the decimal point
and this is by default
uh next constant is the user's number uh
the euler's number is a it's one of the
most widespread constants used in the
world of sci uh in the scientific
community in mathematical community um
you will be using the
euler's number probably a lot as a if if
you move into data science or ai or
something like that so what is the
euler's number it is uh it is the
base of the natural logarithm if you
know what the natural algorithm is it is
used to calculate rates of growth or
rates of decay and as with numbers or
constants like pi and tau even the
euler's number is an irrational number
with infinite decimal places
the value of
the euler's number uh in short it's
denoted by the small letter e so this
value of e is are
usually approximated to around 2.718 so
how do we call this
constant is simply as math dot e this is
how we do it so you get this value again
this is also a float and it's correct up
to 15 decimal places so the next concept
that we will be talking about is
infinity now infinity is a it's more of
a mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive infinity something that
is higher than any known number to us
and negative infinity is lower than any
known number to us
so this is the concept of infinity and
how do we call this
function well so let's see what happens
when we call the math function math
constant infinity so this is how we do
it and as you can see it will return us
this
it might look like a string to you but
this is actually a special type in
python um which is not a string this is
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this uh infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of math.if will give us
inf and this is this inf is actually not
a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when i do a
typed when i check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in python 3.5 um a
special type known as math.inf um it
returns this inf data type
which is the equivalent wavefloat
so this is this is how we use infinity
if you wanted to get the uh value of say
minus infinity all you would have to do
is math dot inf with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus inf now let's check if
the concepts or the properties of
infinity are
maintained you know like every a
positive infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this um so
i'll take my throat in and i will do a
check uh is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then uh this is conceptually correct and
as you can see it is true in fact i can
change this number to anything as large
as i want this will be true because
infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know uh and similarly if
i did minus math dot in
inf uh and i checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus uh 10 to the power something right
this should also be true uh sorry it
should be a smaller sign symbol this
should also be true because i'm checking
minus infinity it's smaller than any
node number to us and it is true as you
can see so uh it's very uh also if you
did uh if you did something like so
let's say if we do
let's add something to this you know
it's a number so we should be able to do
arithmetic on this let's actually see
what happens when i add say 10 to
positive infinity it actually gives us
the same value back infinity because uh
intuitively we know that infinity plus
anything is still going to be infinity
right and this is exactly what python
does for us even if we add a number to
this the math dot inf or the infinity
constant in python it will still give us
uh the same value the same data type of
inf or infinity similarly if we
subtracted something from the negative
of max dot inf you know um say minus say
again let's say minus 100 so if we
subtract something from minus infinity
we're technically still minus infinity
itself so this will again give us minus
and
minus inf as you can see and this is
absolutely what we need and this is a
very very interesting feature in python
uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the nan
or the not a number constant so this is
not really a mathematical constant uh
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that
it's it's used to
is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate
a certain places where say a variable
that should have a
number um it's been corrupted for
whatever reason and it it now has a text
or a symbol and our code throws an error
then in these in these cases where
python expects a number from us or from
your code and it does not get it it will
throw you a n-a-n
value and this is usually used in cases
where you have errors in your code so
again just to check like what this this
constant i like how to call it this is
how you actually do it math.nan and it
will give you a data type called nan
also much like the infinity constant
let's see what's the type of this um
this constant again might look like a
string to you but of course this is not
a string this is a
numerical concept and as you can see
it's still a float so this is like um
it's another special
data type that was created for
specifically this case where
it's some it's the equivalent of a float
but um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the
using the math modules so some of the
common arithmetic functions that are
available to us are factorials the
ceiling operation floor operation
there's permutations there's
combinations you can find the greatest
common divisor or the gcd and the lcm or
the least common multiple and you can
truncate numbers so let's look at them
one by one so starting off with the
factorial operation the factorial
operation is done using the factorial
function as you can see here actually
defined like this math dot factorial all
right so now what we pass in between the
parenthesis will be uh what we calculate
the factorial for
as you know factorial is so factorial is
always for a positive integer and the
factorial for say a number 10 would mean
10 times 9 times 8 times 7 so on until
the number 1. obviously factors are only
defined for positive integers it is not
defined for uh negative values or it's
uh and it's also not defined for decimal
values so uh let's see let's look at an
example so as we know um so let's say we
pass
math dot factorial for 6 and let's see
what's the value so
this is exactly what we expect so we
expect the value of 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 2
that is actually 7 20. let's see what
happens when we pass 0
this should give us 1 since we know 0
factorial is 1. now let's see an error
case where we pass say minus 5.
as you can see this will throw us an
error because factors are not defined
for negative numbers now moving on let's
uh so the next function that we'll talk
about is the ceiling function so the
ceiling function is defined using math
dot seal seal as you see here so again
we pass the number that we want the
ceiling for in between the parenthesis
so what is the sealing function it gives
you the largest uh sorry excuse me it
gives you the smallest number that is uh
greater than or equal to what we pass
over here so
for an example if i gave you 6.6 and i
asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example seven point eight so
this should give me the value eight as
you can see here let's look at another
negative number so minus twelve point
three uh an integer that is greater than
minus twelve point three uh is minus
twelve the smallest integer that is
greater than minus 4.3 and this should
give you 12 as you can minus 12 as you
can see here
a similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if i gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2.
again if we pass integers
it will uh just give us the integer
itself again it is to reiterate this
ceiling and floor functions uh they give
you int in integer values so the floor
function will give you the largest
integer that is smaller than what we
pass over here so let's look at 6.7 so
the largest integer that is smaller than
6.7 is 6 and as you can see this is our
answer over here
the next function that we will look at
is the truncate function
the truncate function is defined using
this truncate is very similar to what we
have seen this is how we define the
truncate function uh it is very similar
to the ceiling and floor
in the truncate function what we do is
we pass a decimal value a float number
to the between between the parenthesis
and what we get back is the number
without the decimal component so only
the integral component so if i gave it
7.8 for example it will give me only the
seventh part it will return me only the
seventh part and it will chop away the
point eight part
if i give it minus 12.3 uh it will chop
away the 0.3 part and give me only -12
back so let's look at an example 8.9 it
should give me only eight as you can see
here see i did minus eight
or minus six point
nine this will give me minus six so you
can think of truncate function as
it does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions um let's move on to
permutations permutations are defined
using this as you know so in between the
parentheses i have to pass two values n
and k so i have to pass n n and a k the
k has to be less than or equal to n
because the permutation as you know is
uh the number of ways in which we can
permute
from n objects k tire k different
objects uh so what this mathematically
what this is is um permutation of n and
k is n factorial divided by n minus k
factorial so if i pass say 10 and 6 it
will give me the permutation of 10 and
6. so let's look at what's the value as
you can see it's a very large value
15 151 200. similarly there is a
combination function and this is a
combination the permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in
machine learning ai you will be using
these functions quite a bit um so the
combination function again you pass an n
and a k again the n should be greater
than or equal to this k what this
evaluates is n factorial divided by n
minus k factorial times k factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and six so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section um our gcd
and lcm as we know gcd is the greatest
common divisor lcm is least common
multiple so as of the newest version of
python in 3pm python 3.9 the math module
gets these two new functions that were
very lately added actually um since i i
cannot show you that because i don't
have the absolute latest version of
python on my system but using the math
dot gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
would do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if i gave these say for
example if i gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the lcm
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if i
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the lcm of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or
if you have python 3.9 or after that
you will have access to these functions
as well if you when you import the math
module so that was for the arithmetic uh
functions let's move on to the next
section which are power and logarithmic
logarithmic functions so let's start off
with the power function um there are two
there are uh multiple ways you know you
can actually do a power function in math
in python so you can do something like
this which is the equivalent of 2 to the
power 3 or you can use the inbuilt uh
module math and you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and if i had to do same
2 to the power 3 i would just pass 2 and
3 as arguments like this and it should
give me the value as you can see 8 over
here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is
not part of the math module it's a
function not part of the math model but
it's still part of the
base python you use this as well and you
can do the same thing vow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
now you might ask what's the difference
between these two functions well it's
not much for at least in a beginner's
standpoint it's not that much just note
that the math dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on the
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if i did
exponential of 3
this would give me e to the power 3 as
you can see oh of course i did not
define the module beforehand so math.exp
now when i do this it should it will
give me some value which is basically
euler's number or e to the power 3. so
this was the exponential function and
let's look at an example so we will look
at the example of rate of dk and we will
use the uh this function in that example
so the exponential rate of decay um
uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive uh elements that
is present in a substance after a
certain amount of time so the the the
the the expression is uh something like
the initial amount of uh radioactive
elements that were present uh right at
the beginning times the exponent of
minus 693 times t
t for time divided by the time period
the half lifetime uh so let's just write
it down to make it simple so again as
you can see
the uh so this will give me the
remaining amount of radioactive elements
right so let's uh let's write down the
remaining let's assign this to a
variable remaining so the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100 um
the time let's assume it's 10 years
uh and let's say the half-life um
half-life
is
around i don't know let's give some
value say three or something again this
is uh the details are not important so
this will i'm using the math dot
exponential function over here as you
can see and for these values uh now when
i check what's the value of remaining
after i calculated it it's something uh
so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that i started off with 100
units of some radioactive element um
and in 10 years this is what is left so
yeah so this is how we would use say the
exponential functions in a particular
example of ours so next the next
type of again
functions are logarithmic functions so
let's look at some of the logarithmic
functions that are part of the math
module so basic log function would be
written like this math.log in between
this i would pass the number that i want
the log for by default if i just pass
one number it will it will calculate the
log of 8 to the base of e as we know e
is the euler's number so let's see what
it does in this case it gives me some
value what if i wanted to specify a
particular base well i would pass a
secure argument in this case i want to
find the log of 8 to the base 2 this
should be the value 3 as you can see
over here
there are two specific functions that
are also provided in this math module
that is log 2
what this will do is again it will again
have to just pass one argument and this
will automatically find the value of the
log of 8 to the base 2 as you can see
here
similarly there is a math dot log 10
function if i give if i did this i will
find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math uh the square root function is
math dot sqrt
again we pass the what we want over here
if we want the square root of say
49 this should give me the value seven
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so
uh let's start off with some of the
trigonometric functions as we know
we can do sine we can do cosine and tan
uh some of the basic functions
the way we would do it is math dot sign
in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians and this is very important to
note we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if i say past
sine of
3.14 as we know 3.14 is an approximation
of the value pi uh my sine pi is uh
supposed to be uh in fact it's supposed
to be zero so let's see uh we get
something close to zero again since this
is an approximation it won't give us the
exact value uh similarly we can use math
dot cos to find the value of a
particular angle um if you want to find
uh if you want to find the value of the
sorry the cost of a particular angle we
can use the tan function in case
we wanted to find the tan similarly uh
we have the next set for arc sine and
the arc cosines of
the certain of angles so to use to find
the arc sine for example we would use a
dot sine i mean sorry a sine uh for our
cosine we would use this and for r10 we
would use this the next set would be
hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas
again the details don't have to be you
don't have to know the details you just
should
you should know that if you wanted to
say for example find out the uh
hyperbolic sign of an a of an angle we
would use math dot
sign h
and we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos h uh tan it would
be tan h and if we wanted to find the
inverse
of uh the hyperbolic inverse what we
would do is what we would do is use a so
we would use a tan h if we wanted to
find the hyperbolic inverse
of sine we would use a sine h and
similarly for cos it would be cos
a cos h so this concludes our video on
the math module in python and some of
the math functions surrounding this in
this video we will learn about
conditional statements
and we will learn about how do we create
these control structures
where we have these conditional
statements we will learn about the
keywords that we use in python to create
a conditional statement block the if
keyword the lf keyword and the else
keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in python
so let's get started so the basic
syntax if you will for a if statement in
python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this
pictorial if if there's an if statement
there is a expression
there is this block of code which if you
can actually see is slightly indented to
the rest of the code
and then we have the rest of the rest of
our code after that so what we're
looking at is this so this is our if
statement block um now let's let's break
this down so what is this expression
that we're speaking of uh an expression
in this context is a boolean expression
which evaluates to a true or false
statement so when we are speaking about
the if statement we have an expression
and if this expression evaluates to true
then we execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks
otherwise if it's false we move on to
the next the next statement block or the
beginning of a new statement so let's
look at an example to further understand
this let's take this if statement over
here as you can see in this if statement
i have this expression 50 greater than
30 so what python is going to do now is
it's going to check whether 50 is
greater than 30 and it's going to check
in a boolean context if this is true
then we can move on to the next portion
which is this but if it is false then we
will skip this so let's see what this
what happens over here so since we know
that 50 is indeed greater than 30 this
is a true expression we move on to this
block of code which is saying that print
50 is indeed a larger number than 30. so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at
what happens if i give a false
expression now i'm checking if 50 is
lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if i have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed in fact my print statement is
just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in python and this is how the uh
how we move on to
how we check for the true the truth
truthfulness or the falseness of a
particular expression in the if
statement so moving on um let's move on
to the topic of indentation in um in
python so as you can see
this uh this if statement is an example
of a control structure so without moving
without defining what a control control
structure is
in detail control structures consists of
these conditionals or loops or
iterations if you will
so all of these control structures
involve heavy indentation so what does
an indentation mean well what if i gave
you an example say i gave you some
variable called h and i wrote 20 over
here now if i gave you an if statement
saying if age is greater than 10 now uh
it's very important to note that when
i'm defining an if statement i need this
colon otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this colon is important uh
anyways so now i'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10 now
what is this what happens if age is
greater than 10 now what if i want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do i tell
python that there is a piece of code
or a section of code that i want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if i want say if i want
this line
this person is an adult again this is
some random line where i'm assuming age
is pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so
if i have uh this variable age where i
write this number 20 which denotes the
age of some person and i'm doing a check
if age is greater than 10. actually
let's be specific here well the adult
age for most people is 18 in most
countries so let's see if age is greater
than 18. now if i'm doing this check
i want to print this statement only if
this person is a person's age is above
20 above 18. so
how do i tell python that i only want
this statement to be
executed only during this if this
condition is met well this is the
indentation comes into play and as you
can see exactly as you can see uh this
part this portion of the code is
slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever
code that we have after this if
statement so let's see so this since
this condition is actually met as you
can see this print statement is actually
executed so this is the importance of
indentation now we will see uh in as we
move as we learn more about if
statements and else statements and lf
statements how indentation plays a key
role in defining what we want as an
output when a certain condition is met
all right so for now it's very important
to understand that this is how
indentation is used in python in other
languages we might use uh we probably
don't use indentation in fact popular
language the c language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for uh indentation
and programming so you might say that
so different people have different
opinions on indentation the general
consensus is that indentation helps make
the code look very presentable and very
readable and this actually is one of the
facets of python programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this
list or let's actually just copy this
example that i have written over here as
you can see what i am doing in this
piece of code is i have a list x where i
have this integer 50 i have two strings
cat and apple now i want to check a
bunch of things so i want to check if 60
is an x and i also want to check if the
string cat is in x and i want a final
sort of like if none of these conditions
are met i want something to happen so
how do we do that well we start off our
state our if statement block with the
standard if keyword all right now if we
have uh one more condition that we want
met then we can use the l if which
is kind of a short form for else if
so we use the l if keyword so it so what
this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is the keyword
used in our block to tell python that if
none of our earlier expressions have
been true then do uh what is in the uh
that is within the else
keyword that is indented within the else
keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is
only we only reach this l as statement
in case all of the other earlier
conditions have not been met or have uh
come to be false and not true so let's
look at uh this particular example so we
have a list of 50 cat and apple and my
first expression that i'm checking is uh
is 60 in x so this is how we check
actually so if 60 and x should be read
as is 60 in the list x so is this 16
elix list x well actually no we don't
have the object 60. so this part is not
executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in x well
actually it is
the string cat is indeed in x so we move
on to this statement block which is
within the condition that is met which
is print cat is in list x and you will
see that none of the other statement
blocks will be executed because we have
met our condition over here so if i
execute this as you can see that the
print statement cat is in list x is what
is actually executed and we do not uh
execute this obviously because it is
false and we do not even check or we did
not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition met
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many elif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for
but it's very important that we only use
and if we are using that we only use one
else statement and only at the end of
our block okay so moving on now i'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these these condition checkings so it's
very important to note that once a
condition is met none of the other
conditions are even checked for so
we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this
if statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that i have over here is where i've
stored the string cat in x now i have
three um i have three conditions that
i'm checking i'm checking is 50 greater
than 60 i am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and i'm checking i'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0 this is
not even a check this is literally just
checking if 1 divided by 0 is true or
false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by 0. so
let's see what happens when i execute
this statement now typically if i wrote
1 divided by 0 python will throw me an
error because 1 cannot be divided by 0.
that is an error error in a statement so
let's see what happens when i do this
actually as you can see i have a
statement being printed but i have no
error even though i gave it wrong i gave
an error statement in 1 divided by 0.
well now you might ask why is that so
well it's simply because i have actually
never reached this condition i have not
even
python is not bothered looking at this
because if you actually see there is a
condition previous to this
over here which is met and which is true
so we move on to this block we execute
this block and we forget about the rest
of the code so we don't actually get to
this erroneous statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that i have shown uh
to show you that once a condition is met
in an if statement block we do not look
at any of the further conditions that
are being checked okay so finally um i
have one
one small topic that i would like to
share with you is the conditional
expressions or the pythons ternary
operator now this is slightly different
to the if statement that we have talked
about up until now
in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what i am trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the
syntax for what i'm trying to talk about
this ternary operator so let's look at
this example and let's see what i'm
trying to do over here so i have this
variable age all right and this age is
26. now x now just just read this
statement x is equal to adult if a is is
greater than 18 else child now i could
have done an elaborate control structure
with an if statement then an indentation
within that if statement and then
i could have written else and then
another indentation and i would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that i have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable x and this
what value i'm assigning to x depends on
if this condition is true or false so
as you can see the condition says is age
18
greater than 18. so if this is true then
i assign this particular string if it is
false then i go to the else statement
and i assign this so since age is 26 is
greater than 18 i should assign the
string adult to x and as you can see if
i execute this and check what is in x
you can see adult is indeed an x so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's it's a
better looking way uh to perform simple
else uh some simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if
if else statement control structure
block so yeah this was the ternary
operator finally we let's uh we we make
a short note on the path statement uh in
python so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a
a place where it is a placeholder of
sorts so what if i had an if statement
and i'm writing a piece of code but i
don't know what to do with this if
statement so if if a statement is
correct if a statement is true
but i don't know what to do if this
statement was true
how do i tell python well let's just
keep it a hold for now and i might
put something into this block later in
the future well i would use the pass
statement so if i had this say the sum
condition again so i'm checking age is
greater than 18 but i don't know what to
do with this i would just simply use
this pass statement and uh this
basically does nothing uh it it's a way
to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future i
might have i might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently i don't have
anything to place over here so i just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is
a way where you can use a pass statement
in
if an else statement or infinite control
structures so yeah this was a uh basic
or the an introduction into conditional
statements and uh the control structure
uh of fnl statements in python in this
video we will be doing a small exercise
on if statements just to drive home the
point or the purpose of an if statement
we will be doing a small exercise so
let's first revise some of the concepts
of an if statement so basic if statement
can be something like this we have a
small condition where we're checking if
a variable x is greater than 5 or not
and if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement else we
move to the statement block now our
variable x has the value 5. now since x
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something
where we are checking multiple
statements we use the l if statement in
such a case so
now in this block we are checking in one
of the one of the conditions we're
checking is if x is equal to 5 or if x
is greater than 5 and then finally if
both of these conditions are not met we
say else and we print whatever or we do
whatever is in this particular statement
block which is a simple print statement
so as you can see x is indeed good is
equal to 5 so this is the block that
will get executed as you can see here
now another example are nested if
statements so nested if else statements
are if statements within fl statements
so let's look at an example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh
now we have an integer or a float in
this case 4.0 stored in orange price now
our first statement is checking whether
orange quality the variable orange
quality is it equal to the string fresh
and within that if the statement or if
this condition is met we do another
check where we're checking what is the
price is it lesser than five if it is we
do this block else we execute this block
finally if our initial
statement our initial condition is not
met we move on to this else block now
when i execute this what should happen
is i will enter this block because this
is true and finally i will enter this
block because this condition is also
true so i should have this printed i
will buy five dozens as you can see here
now let's move on to our main exercise
for this video so this was all just a
revision now we're going to use some or
all of these concepts in a sample
project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice
so in this exercise what we're going to
do is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter
now we use this in keyword to make sure
that whatever we have entered into the
input box is stored as a int data type
in the enter num variable
once we do that our first if statement
is going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
less than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered an invalid number now
once we have
say entered a valid number we move on to
this block this is in uh if else uh if
elif statement block now what this block
is checking is whether the entered
number is an even number or not now as
we know an even number is divisible by 2
and leaves the remainder 0 when divided
by 2. so this is what this check is
doing if this check is true that means
our number is even and we get printed
that our number is even the other other
check or the other
if statement is checking whether it's an
odd number and that means when we divide
by 2 we should get the remainder 1 as
you can see here and we get printed your
number is odd so let's execute this and
see what happens when we enter a number
now it's asking me to enter a number
let's say i enter 17.
now that i have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that i've
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if i entered something
else here let's say if i enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if i what happens when i enter an
invalid number let's say 25 now i enter
25 as you can see it says i have entered
an invalid number and in this case what
has happened is this condition itself is
not met and i have moved on to the
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when i enter 9 the
first check that happens of course is
this check whether it's a valid number
or not and since it is between 1 and 20
we move on to this block and in this
block is checking whether our number is
divisible by 2 or not and since it is
not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is odd as you
can see here
so this was a brief recap into the if
statement and afl statements necessary
file statements we also saw an exercise
where we used nested if else statements
in this video we will be i will
introduce you to the concept of
iterations in python and we will be
speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
indefinite iterations in python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the wire keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like in fl statements uh a set of
statements where
what happens here is following the while
keyword we have this expression where
this expression is evaluated in a
boolean context again we check if this
expression evaluates true or false and
if it is true we
execute all the statements or the
statement block that is indented below
this file statement now this is another
example of control structure much like
if any statement blocks where we use a
lot of indentation so let's look at a
basic example now of while loop so let's
copy this example and let's see what
this does so i have a variable n where i
am assigning it a value 0. this is
called an initializing process and it's
very important to note that most while
loops consist of an expression which
contains a variable a control variable
uh which
is usually initialized prior to starting
the loop and then this control variable
is uh typically very modified somewhere
within the
main loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and i am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's uh move into the loop
now so the loop has this wire keyword as
you can see followed by a
an expression n less than or equal to 5.
now what this is is an expression which
is going to check if it's true or false
is n lesser than or equal to 5 and as
long as this expression is true we will
continue doing whatever is indented
below this while statement and what is
below this while statement is a print
statement first of all which says value
of n is and it basically prints the
value of n in that particular iteration
and as you can see at this uh compound
assignment where we add the value of n
uh by 1 and we assign it back to n so
what this is let's see what this does
actually let's execute this and see what
this does
important to note the value of n again
is initialized at zero so this while
loop will keep going on until the value
of n remains lesser than or equal to
five so as you can see i have the
execution of this
particular block of code or this while
loop where i get the
multiple different iterations of this
print statement that you can see here
the first iteration it says value of n
is 0 then it's the value of n is one
what i'm doing is i am writing i am
assign i'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is
that initially the value of n is 0 and i
print the statement value of n is 0. now
i add uh the value of what is in n by 1.
so now what is the value of n so again
we do this check so after this first
iteration we come back like once this
whole
block of code is executed we again come
back to this expression and we again
check if this statement is true so now
that the value of n is actually 1
this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is one now again we add
the value of n by one and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if the statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's 2 is still
making sure that this expression is true
and this keeps happening until the value
of n is greater than 5 so once the value
of n becomes 6 this condition is no
longer met and finally we do not execute
the statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
uh we can use iterables and an example
of an iterable is uh the list so let's
look at this list and let's look at this
whole block all right so i created this
list a which contains five objects one
two three four and five all integer
objects and i have another variable x
where i store the integer one now i'm
this while statement now it might look
confusing now it says it says while a
now what is a well a is not uh your
typical expression where you're making
sure if some condition is being met or
not but this the way you read this is
while a exists so in the context of a
list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value x where we um we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and uh we pass x so the
first iteration obviously pass x is
equal to one and then we add x by one
and then the second iteration should
pass this iteration number two and then
so on and finally we have another
statement within this block called the a
called the pop statement where we're
popping the elements of a now as if you
would have seen the list the video and
list the pop statement removes the right
most value
from a list so if i do a dot pop
initially it will remove five from this
list and i will have the rest of them
again if i do pop it will remove four
from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that i'll also print the list
a each uh during each iteration and
let's see what happens over here as you
can see what is happening out here is
while a or while a has elements we are
going to continue doing this while
statement whatever is within it so in
the first iteration obviously we have
all of it uh and it is iteration number
one and as you can see the list contains
everything then i pop it then iteration
number two it again has elements but it
has lost its most rightmost element and
this keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
element or events the list has no
elements left be this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while loop
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when i check what's
in a it's an empty list and that is why
while a returned me a false and we did
not print any further so this is an
example of using a while statement using
lists
and of course
the next topic would be discussing
nested while loops and
this is a broad topic what i mean by
this is that when when i'm saying nested
while loops i'm actually talking about
nested control structures so we can have
while loops within while loops not only
that we can have if and if statements
within while loops we can have while
loops within if and else statements and
we can have if and l statements within f
and l statements so if you think of all
of these loops
and we will even speak about for loops
in the in the in in another video for
loops again are type of control
structures so all of these are control
structures while loops are control
structures for loops are control
structures if and as statements or
control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter
which is the like the parent of the nest
and then the child or the nest if you
can have a while loop within an if and l
statement you can have for loops within
a while loop all of this is valid in
python and uh it's one of the one of the
great features of python that is very
flexible in this way so let's look at an
example where i have a while loop within
another while loop so i'm copying this
piece of code where i have this list one
two three four five and another list
first and second now my first while loop
i print i print what is popped from a so
i take a then i pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and i
print what is that all right and then i
have another while loop where i have
this list b and i'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first uh
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then i do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do i go back to
this first one and then i come back and
do all of this again then i go back to
this one and then i come back and do all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so i have this first
iteration and then i do uh the second
while loop then i have the second
iteration and then i do the second while
loop and i keep doing this and this is
an example of a nested while loop okay
so our next topic in this section this
video would be break and continue
statements now break in continue
statements are
ways to abruptly end iterations uh in in
a particular loop and you can use break
and continue statements not only in
while loop but you can use it in also in
for loops so let's look at how we use it
in while loops and let's look at what we
mean by breaking continuous statements
first of all well the break statement
terminates the loop entirely so once the
break statement is found the the
complete while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continuous
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the the controlling
expression is again re-evaluated and it
is checked whether
the loop will execute again or terminate
this pictorial that you can see here
actually emphasizes or it shows the
difference between break and continue so
i have this while loop and i have an
expression all right i have a bunch of
statements and i have a break command
over here and i have a continue command
over here so if i encounter the break
command it will not execute any of this
in fact it will not execute this while
statement at all and it will move on to
the next piece of code that we have but
a continuous statement if a continuous
statement is encountered in a while loop
will not completely break away but it
will not uh it will not execute the the
rest of the statements in that iteration
only these two but it will go back here
it will check this expression again and
again we will do this all over again so
this is this small uh difference between
the break and continue statements but
both are used to abruptly end an
iteration in a loop so let's look at an
example of how we use the break
statement so i will use this example
where i have again i have initialized
some controlling variable n to 0
my first loop will check whether n is
less than equal to 5. if this is true
then i will print this statement then i
will what i i'm doing over here is i am
incrementing it by one now in my
previous my earlier example using a
similar uh using the similar example uh
i had no like this this part was not
there so what you got was i was printing
the value of n so it was printing as
like value of n is one i mean zero and
then one and then two and then three
four and five but over here i've
included a small i've nested an if
statement and within that i put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 i move on to this and i
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once
so when i have executed this i don't get
the whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then 2 3 4
i i stop at one and that is because once
n is equal to two i actually do not
execute this while loop again i do not
go back and execute print value of n is
two now in fact i break from this whole
while loop and my while loop terminates
right then and there and that's why you
only get these two iterations value of n
is zero and then value of n is one okay
so now i'm going to show you a neat
example of what happens or what is the
difference between a break and a
continuous statement okay so let's go
back to our initial example where we're
printing this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4
and so on but i've added one more
statement where i print hello at each
iteration so let's see what happens when
i do this as you can see it will print
hello after each of whatever i was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when i do
break well let's
go back to this if statement if
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now i have this continue
statement instead of a break let's see
what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we did not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that i want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello and value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because and this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again where we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to two and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continuous statement
with the break statement so this
concludes it for our video on indefinite
iterations this video we will be looking
at three examples where we are using
while loops along with other stuff like
say if and if statements so our first
example will be where we calculate the
factorial of a number in this example as
you can see here we are first going to
ask the user to enter a particular
number for us now this number is
supposed to be an integer once we have
this integer we store it to a variable
called number now we have this you can
say this
variable called fac which does 1 and you
we will see how we are using it later
now we know that the factorial of 0 is 1
that's how it's just defined so we have
an if statement checking whether our
entered number is zero and if it is zero
we say that the result is one or the
factorial is one however
if we enter a number that is greater
than zero we must calculate the
factorial for this number and that is
what we are going to do in this else
statement block over here now in this
else statement block we have a while
loop in this while loop the condition is
checking while number is greater than or
equal to 1 so as long as this condition
is true everything within that while
loop will be executed so as long as
number is greater than equal to 1 we are
going to execute these two lines now
what do these two lines do let us see so
the first line takes the variable fac
where we had the number one stored and
we're going to store fac times number
into it number being the number that we
have inputted so in case for example we
we entered eight then what this will do
this line will do is one into eight and
it will store that back into fac now
once that is done we move on to the next
line where we are decrementing the
number variable by one so if we have
stored eight or we have entered eight
into our input it will become seven now
as we know 7 is still greater than equal
to 1 so this condition is still being
met and then we do this process again
where we are going to multiply fac this
time fac stores the value 8 and we
multiply it times the new number which
is seven now so we do eight into seven
and then again we decrement this uh also
once we do eight into seven we store it
back into fac and we keep doing this
where we keep multiplying eight times
seven and then we decrement the number
variable by one and then we check this
condition again so what ends up
happening is we are going to keep doing
eight into seven into six into five into
four into three into two into one and
once we are at one again when we do this
document operation
the number variable will store the value
0 and then this condition will no longer
be met so number will be 0 and this
condition will be false and we can move
out of this while loop then finally we
store the result into a variable called
result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1.
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this um in real time once we execute
this so i'm executing this the first
thing it asks me is to enter a number so
let's say i enter my number eight as i
was speaking about eight all right now
that i've entered eight as you can see
the result that it gives me is factorial
of eight is four zero three two zero
which is correct and you can check this
for yourself where it will show you um
eight times seven or eight factorial is
basically this this number okay so now
in our next example we will be looking
at how we can generate fibonacci numbers
for this example we will be using bunch
of if and else if statements along with
a while loop so let's look at this piece
of code where we are actually doing this
so as you can see the first part of the
code is basically an input statement
asking us how many fibonacci numbers we
would like to generate and then the user
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an int into a variable count
now in this uh if statement the first
if statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
fib next if our
entered integer is 1 we just store the
value 1 in this array called fib if our
enter number is 2 we store 1 and 1 in
the array fib all of these are different
sets of fibonacci sequences this
obviously an empty and an empty array
shows that well there is no numbers to
be generated in this sequence if we have
one we just print the first number of
the fibonacci sequence which is one
itself if it is two we print the first
two numbers which is 1 and 1. now
the actual calculations happen when we
say we want a fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the fib
variable with the first two fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we are going to keep
executing the statement block as long as
this condition is met or this condition
is true and what this condition is is
it's checking this variable i which we
have initialized as 1 over here and
we're going to check whether that is
lesser than count minus 1 count being
the number that we have been asked to
input if the statement is true and as
long as the statement is true we will be
executing the statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array fib now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding uh each subsequent numbers
and we're going to store each subsequent
numbers back into the
array fib so in this case if you see the
what the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first position of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the zeroth position of the
arrayfib and both of these values since
they are one and one when we add them we
get two and we append that to fib so now
our fib will look like one comma one
comma two then we increment this by one
and what we do is we
do the same process again so in the next
step what would be what we would do is
we would do two plus one so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many fibonacci numbers i
would like to generate and i will say i
want the first let's say six fibonacci
numbers so i execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then two which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is 3 plus 5. so if we wanted more
numbers we would just enter over here
let's say if we wanted the first 10
numbers it would give us
the first 10 numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we are going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array for example if we want a three
by three array we will enter three comma
three and we are going to generate a two
dimensional array in which each of the
elements of the array are basically the
row times the column position of that
particular element and what i mean by
this is say we have a position i comma j
on the array the value of the
element at that position would be i
times j so for example if i'm looking at
something at the third row and the fifth
column or say the third row and the
third column for example the value of
the element would be three times three
and if i'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column i am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using code
so if you look to the right over here i
have a piece of code where i'm going to
in where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store
these uh these
dimensions in the
inputs in in a variable called input
string so obviously when we enter say 5
comma 5 that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want uh five say we
entered five comma five we want five as
a separate integer and the other five as
another separate integer and that is
what we do in this particular statement
where we're going to split up our input
string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the zeroth position of
dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position
in this particular array now
we are going to store the number of rows
as row number and that is the zeroth
position of this array and we are going
to store the number of columns as the
first position of dimensions or whatever
we've mentioned in the input so now we
uh we have this um our results array
called multi-list which is basically
what what our final array is going to
look like and we're going to store into
multi-list and
in this example we will be using for
loops to
do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi-list
saying that
we're going to have only zeros in our
sample array so initially once we have
initialized this array all multi-list
will contain is a say for example we
have inputted a 5x5 array it will have
basically a 5x5 array with all elements
as zero and that's what this line does
once we have uh done this we are going
to move on to the for loop portion where
we are actually going to create our
array that we want so as you can see we
are our first for loop is going to say
for row in range row number so obviously
uh range will generate a
an iterator which can be iterated over
um and since it says range row number
and say our the number of rows that we
entered were five what it's going to do
is it's going to create an iterator
containing the value 0 1 2 3 and 4. so
for row and range it will basically
basically row will take the value 0 1 2
3 and 4. and a similar thing is going to
happen in this nested for loop which is
within this where we're going to again
create a an iterator using this range
function and for the column number once
we have this we're going to do the
simple process of
multiplying the
the value of the element based on its
position so if it's at the position 3
comma 4 we're going to store the value 3
times 4 into that particular position of
the array and we're going to do this for
every position which is what happens in
these two for loops we're going to first
go by each row and then within that
we're going to check each column and
we're going to perform these
calculations and finally we print our
result so let's look at an example now
i'm going to say i want a 3 by let's say
a two by four matrix so let's see what
the results will be when i give this as
uh so what i'm saying is i want two rows
and four columns now as you can see here
it might not be very clear to you right
now but what you can see here is this is
the first row and this is the second row
and each row contains four columns so
these are the this is the my final array
that i get so what you can see here is
this is the zeroth position and the uh
or you can say this is the first row
first column first row second column and
uh since python is zero based so this is
actually the zeroth row and this is the
first row so as you can see uh this this
value basically is zero times one this
value is zero times two zero times three
zero times four and over here it is one
times zero one times one one times two
one times three so similarly if i did
for example a five by five matrix what
you will get is five rows now five rows
and five columns and for example like
this particular value is uh one two
three or zero one two three so zero one
two three and the first column so this
is three times one um if i took this
value this is like the fourth row for
example fourth row times the um zero one
two three third column so this would be
four times three which is twelve so and
uh each value of this has been generated
in the similar process so this is an
example of how we can use for loops
for a particular exercise that i have
shown you right now so this was it for
these particular examples into violent
for loops uh i hope you found the two
examples on while loop and this one
example on for loops helpful to you and
i hope it gave you further insight into
how we can use these types of loops in
different projects in this video we will
be covering the topic of definite
iterations uh using for loops in python
so starting off we know that there are
two types of iterations in programming
uh definitely an indefinite we have
already covered indefinite iterations in
the form of while loops
definite iterations on the other hand
are done using the keyword for
and the basic syntax or the standard
syntax for a basic for loop in python is
as you can see over here we have this
four keyword we have some variable we
have the in keyword and we have this
iterable and
we of course defined this control
structure with the colon and then
indented we have this statement block so
once this for loop has started we
execute all of these statements within
the statement block as part of the
follow-up iteration so yeah let's uh now
let's to understand like how for loops
work
exactly let's
look at the concept or meaning behind
what we call iterables and iterators so
so think of it in a stepwise manner all
right so we in python we have different
objects that can be used as iterables
and an iterable is basically some object
that uh it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects
so once we have these collection of
objects
we can create an iterator out of it
how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if i passed this
list a if i pass this list a through the
iter function and i store it in some
variable either underscore a
and i see what is iter underscore a it
is actually a list iterator at some
random memory location which we don't
really care about similarly if i gave a
tuple and i did the same thing i will
create a tuple iterator and in the left
if you can see over here i've done the
exact same
functions with sets and dictionaries as
well so i'm creating iterators out of
these
iterables so as to speak
now what is an iterator well an iterator
is
an object that yields
values successively so
if my list contained five values or five
objects an iterator of this list will
yield these values uh one after the
other and that is kind of how or that is
the basis for which we do
we create loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh
using another function that we call the
next function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since i've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see i've created this listed
iterator iter underscore a now with this
item underscore a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
i will keep yielding or i keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when i do next either when i do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when i do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if i did it again it gives me third now
if i kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now i get fourth now i get
fifth now a natural question is now that
i've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if i perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens i get a
an error or and this error is the stop
iteration function error which basically
is telling me look you have uh exhausted
all of the objects that were initially
present in this list a and you cannot
you cannot keep doing the next in the
next function anymore you cannot go you
keep going further so yeah so this is uh
what the next function does when it
comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
move or let's come back to our for loop
that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with
objects again 1 2 3 4 and 5. all right
this is a list now i'm going to do for x
in a print x and let's try to see what
happens when we do this okay
as you can see when i have executed this
it gives me one two three four and five
so i have first of all let's look at
this for loop i in this for loop i
define a new variable x and then i say
for x in a print x and what's happening
well in each iteration i am printing
whatever the value of x is
at present so in the first iteration it
is the first object one in the second
iteration it is the second object two
then three four five and then finally uh
on its own like uh this for loop knows
that okay now once i have exhausted all
of the objects within my iterator i can
stop doing this for loop and i can move
on with the rest of the code all right
so think of it like a three-step process
uh a for loop in python the first step
is it calls an iter function to obtain
an iterator for whatever we pass over
here this iterable second step it calls
the next function repeatedly in each
iteration all right to keep getting the
next item from the iterator so it gets
one and then it calls next then it gets
two then it calls next and it gets three
and then four and then five and so on
and then finally the third step is the
termination step is when after we do the
final next where we get this error as
you can see the stock iteration error or
exception finally this tells the for
loop function or the for loop that um
okay we have reached the end of our
definite iteration or the end of our
definite for loop and this is where we
must terminate our loop and then
continue with the rest of the code all
right so this is how a for loop works in
python now it's very important to note
that whatever we have discussed when it
came to while loops such as nesting of
while loops and nesting of other control
structures is also applicable in the
case of for loops so if i had a for loop
within another for loop that is
perfectly fine if i had a vial within a
for loop that is perfectly fine so all
of these are valid statement blocks that
we can do
and again for loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of
indentation when it comes to writing our
statement blocks within a for loop okay
so now i'm going to speak about in
specific i'm going to speak about the
this uh something called the range
function that is uh quite
you could say it's used definitely it's
used in other areas of programming but
it's widely used in python
i mean
i mean the for loop in python
what i mean by this is that um
range this range function is very
important for the for loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at um one of
the examples of using the range function
so what does a range function do is if i
give range five let's see what it does
it gives me range zero to five what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from zero to five so it will
contain the object zero one two three
four and five and we can use this as an
iterator so let's let's look at this uh
i have range five uh let's store this in
x okay now let's do a type just to see
what happens when we do type x it should
give me the type of range as you can see
and this is the type of an iterator in
python now let's see what happens when i
do 4 i in x
print i okay let's see what happens as
you can see it prints the number 0 1 2 3
4. an important caveat when it comes to
the range function is when we say range
5 it creates an iterator from 0 to 5 but
it contains the objects 0 1 2 3 and 4
only it does not contain the object five
itself okay this is something that is
very important too so uh once again i
created uh i use this range function to
create an iterator from
iterator of five objects from zero to
four zero one two three and four uh i
use that in my for loop and uh that's
what that is what you are seeing here
now let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so i had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay
let's use the range function on top of
the length of this list a and this is
like i can't show you an example right
now without any context but this uh this
form of using a for loop is used is
widely used in
python programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and ai i cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for loop
expression so you have four let's say i
in
range
len
a let's see what's going on here first i
create uh first i do length of a that
gives me five then i do range of five
that creates an iterator between zero
and four right when you do range five it
gives you an iterator of 0 1 2 3 and 4
as we saw earlier and this is what we're
doing over here we have created an
iterator out of the length of a list
now when i do print i it should give me
again 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 4 of course so as
you can see here it will give me 0 1 2 3
4 and this is a very neat way of using
the range function on top of the length
of a particular collection of objects in
this case we're using the list a this is
something that you will use a lot so i i
would recommend that you get used to
this form of creating a for loop as well
using the range function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will
resume with the next iteration so yeah
that was break and continue statements
and for loops uh finally i would like to
show you something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or as an
iterable when it comes to for loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again restore it
in a okay so i created this dictionary a
all right so i have dictionary a uh what
i'm going to do is i'm going to pass it
through the iterator function as you can
see and now i'm going to just for the
sake of showing you it will show i'll
show you that it is actually an iterator
of type of a specific dict key iterator
type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary i
have the key first that has the value
one i have the key second that has the
value two i have the key third that has
a value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now
a good question would be when i do
iteration or when i do a for loop on top
of this a well what is it going to pick
up is it going to pick up first uh is it
going to pick up the keys like these or
is it going to pick up the values or is
it going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value uh let's see what actually happens
let's do for i in
uh iter underscore a print hi let's see
what what is the iterations happening
upon using this so as you can see we're
using the keys so by default when we do
this when we perform when we create an
iterator out of a dictionary we use only
the keys as our
iterator elements or at iterator values
but of course like if you wanted to use
values all you would have to do is pass
a dot values over here and if you
remember from a dictionary video this
a dot values gives us a list of
or it by it gives us the essentially a
list of
the values in our dictionary so when we
pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is it underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location so it's not the dict key as we
saw earlier it's a dict value iterator
so now that we have this dictionary
value iterator now let's print what are
our iterator elements and as you can see
now we are printing values and not um
the keys so this is how to
these this is basically two different
ways of iterating through a dictionary
one through keys and one through values
so this concludes it for our video on
definite iterations in python i hope in
this video you understood and you
learned about the concept of iterables
and iterators and the different
functions associated with it and how
exactly the for loop function works
in python in this video we're going to
learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we're handling large and different types
of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image files video files etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like
xml css html files and so on now there
are four main operations that we can do
on
by in python on files they are open read
write and close
there are certain other operations as
well though like rename delete so some
of the most basic operation that we can
do is obviously creating and opening a
file and the syntax is as you can see
here where we store where we use the
open command and we give a file name and
we give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write only mode which is done by letter
w and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by r plus and we are going to
see them as we encounter them now the
it's important to note that what i just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do
for binary files we're going to do this
file handling then we would be using the
letter b in front of whatever we were
using in the case of text files so if we
were doing a read-only mode for opening
a binary file we would be using rb and
if we were doing read and write mode
read or write only mode for a binary
file we would be using rb plus
so basically just adding the b in the
case of binary files let's look at a
basic example when we want to open a
particular file we are going to like in
this example i'm going to open some file
called
filehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and i'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if i wanted to do it
for the binary file since i'm using a
binary file i will use the letter b as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters is denoted by n over here
and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of
where i'm going to print something
called
so i'm going to take this and i'm going
to do a print on top of this so i have
done first i've opened it and i've
stored it in my file and then i'm going
to do a
a method or a function called read and
i'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that i have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically now what if i wanted to
open only the first five characters of
this file which is basically this well
in that case let's open this once again
now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when i do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off in our from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how
python handles files so if i wanted to
again take the cursor back in such an
example i will have to open this again
and then i use this read command once
again to get back to where i started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again open this
over here and now we're going to use the
read line command
over here so what redline command is
going to do is going to each time we use
this command it's going to go one by one
and read each particular line from this
file so in first case it will take
artificial intelligence then data
science big data and so on so as you can
see if i execute this it first takes
artificial intelligence now if i did
this command again it will say data
science next time if i do it it should
say big data as you can see here okay so
this is the read line command now within
the readline command also we can enter
characters and that will tell us
basically
that we want these number of characters
from the next line so if i want the
first six characters of the next line i
will say six i will enter six here and
it will give me the first six characters
of this particular line which is the
next line that is to come as you can see
here now another way in which we can
print whatever is there in our file line
by line is by using a for loop so again
i'm going to open this file i'm going to
store it here now i'm going to use a for
loop saying that well for line in my
file and what this does is basically at
each each iteration it's going to take
each line and store it in this variable
that we end over here which is called
line itself and we're going to print
that at the end of the loop what we'll
have is all of the lines have been
printed one by one and another thing
that we can do right now is um say we
want to read a particular line say i
wanted you to read the fifth line of my
file i can use this technique where um i
just say okay i'm gonna store five in
this variable called line number and i
have this um another variable called
current line which i'm going to
initialize with one and i'm going to any
i'm gonna what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
do the same loop where i'm going to say
four line in my line but i'm going to
add a condition saying that only if
current line when it's equal to line
number am i going to print the line and
then i'm going to break out of this
whole thing and at the end of each
loop i'm going to say current line is
going to be incremented by one until
basically these two variables are equal
so when i do this i get my result which
is uh machine learning which is the
fifth line of um
my which is the fifth line of or
whatever file i had now we're going to
move on to the topic of um image file
handling so we we saw how we handled and
we we saw certain operations around
text files um and text files obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's uh look
at certain examples and certain
use cases around image file handling so
my first step is going to be importing a
bunch of modules and packages now the
details of these modules and these
packages are not important as of right
now because they will be covered in a
future video but just keep a note of
some of these packages such as
they say numpy and
image the image
package so once i've done this let's
move on to my example so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings i've attached the
of this prefix r to say that this is a
read-only uh sort of a prefix so the
next topic that we're going to be
handling is image file handling now we
have already seen many examples
pertaining to text files so text files
are obviously something that we're going
to be using a lot but image file
handling is something very important as
well and we're going to see certain
operations that we can do around image
file handling so starting off i'm going
to import a bunch of
packages and modules what these packages
exactly are and what these modules
exactly are are right now not of that
important i'm not not that important to
you right now but it's something that
will be covered in a future or in future
videos uh it's important to just keep
note of what these are such as numpy and
image so once i've done that what i'm
going to store is i'm going to store two
particular file locations in two
variables location one and location two
and i've prefixed them with r just to
say that these are raw strings so once
i've done that i'm going to use the
image
from the image package i'm going to say
open and i'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and i'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we have done this
we can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file
it attributes the it identifies the
source of an image and if the image is
not read from a file it is set to none
we can also see the size of the file
using the size attribute and we can see
the mode which basically defines the
number and names of the bands in the
image and also contains the pixel type
and depth certain common modes are like
l for luminescence rgb for true color
images and cmyk for prepress images so
let's look at them so when i
access this you can see my first file is
of jpeg of this size and an rgb format
image and my second image is another
jpeg slightly bigger image and again rgb
now we
can also of course display these images
and to do that we can use the plt um
again plt is the is supposed to stand
for a matte plot lip dot pie plot it's a
particular for a particular package um
that again you don't need to know the
details of right now but this is how we
would um do this so i'm going to use a
bunch of
commands and methods such as figure and
subplot and then i am sure so once i
have done this as you can see both of my
images with this being im1 this being
im2 have
been produced on the screen as you can
see i can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now
i can obviously
save a particular image using the save
function which is as simple as doing
this so i'm going to save the image as i
am underscore save dot jpg over here now
if i wanted to crop an image i can do
that as well so i initially i stored the
dimensions that i want cropped in the
form of a tuple as you can see here and
i'm going to pass that tuple to the crop
function and i'm going to apply that on
top of im1 and i'm going to store that
to region once i've done that as you can
see so basically what i've done is i've
cropped this image based on whatever
passed here and i've stored it into
region and now if i wanted to see what
was actually in that crop i can just
do the i am show function and i am going
to pass the particular cropped image
which is denoted by region as you can
see here and you can see my cropped
image is basically a certain a left
portion of this whole image has been
cropped out and i have produced it over
here now i can also use the copy
function using it's a simple basically
copy base you use the copy function and
it copies an image onto another um
variable that you have assigned and when
i use the i am show function i am going
to show you the copied image which is
basically the same now we can do the
transpose operation as well so let's see
some of the
let's see what we've done here so in
this transpose opposite operation so in
this basically i've done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once i'm done with all
of these multiple operations i am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever i have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling
i have shown you two slightly more
comprehensive examples on um text files
and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling in
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for audio files and even for
like stuff like pdf files and
this is like this is just only the
beginning and i'm sure you will
encounter a lot of different use cases
different examples as you continue
learning
python programming this video is going
to be the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
object-oriented programming well as the
name suggests object-oriented
programming is all about creating
objects an object is a group of
interrelated variables and functions
variables can be referred to as the
properties of the object whereas the
functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
its behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change breaking similarly if i gave you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and define certain
functions called methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form of a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own
unique set of information that is one
way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and an instance now for our first
example on classes i will be taking you
through a class where i've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circle such as its
radius and this area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here a bunch of def
keywords followed by so something that
you might not be familiar with and i
will try to get you through this so if
you see here you have a def keyword
followed by init and this init is
prefixed by a double underscore and it's
suffixed by a double underscore and you
can see the same thing for str and repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called dunder methods um these dunder
methods are or can be thought of like
predefined or built in methods for
any class that you define so these we
have like a three dunder methods over
here and uh we have one user defined
method that we will get to so this first
method that you see here is the init
method or the initialization method and
this is invoked or called whenever we
create an instance of this class circle
and what we do here is basically we pass
um when we create this instant circle uh
we are what what happens is that we are
we get an option to pass and a value for
a
what what is this
keyword or variable radius so if i pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where
i will be passing a value and that value
is basically stored as the radius and by
default the
radius that will be passed whenever we
create an instance for this uh class is
one um the str method is basically used
to return a descriptive string for the
the instance of
class um our api is not something that
you have to bother with right now and uh
now get area is something that you
should follow because if you see here i
have not used any double underscores so
this is a user
user defined method uh user-defined
methods are it's a method that we define
and these are like tasks that we define
on our own so in my user-defined method
called get area i will be returning the
area of this circle based on the radius
that i passed to it now if you notice
here the before every
in every method i have the self keyword
before any other attribute so
like this herself this herself even the
get area herself now what this means
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically um
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
i'm going to use getarea function i am
going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on only the
current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is
is basically the is basically what the
map is is the instance that um the
method is invoked upon so if i say self
i'm telling
this particular function that okay all
the value that you're going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that particular
instance where you have been invoked
itself now don't worry if all this is
very confusing um this might be in the
beginning but just try to understand
that this is something that we do for
good practice and you will understand
when 20 yourself or when not to yourself
as you learn about object oriented
programming so if you see here my get
area function is supposed to return the
value radius times radius f dot radius
is basically telling um whatever value
i've passed for radius for that
particular instance you can read this as
radius times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi r squared which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where i'm going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line i have created
an instance of the class circle where
i've passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable c1 now the print
c1 function invokes the str self-defined
or predefined function now if you
remember str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we define on
our own in our example str will return
the
string saying this is a circle with
radius off and then it will return the
radius that we passed so in this case it
should say this is the circle of radius
2.1 as you can see over here so if i
execute this you can notice this line
this is a circle with radius 2.1 and
this is invoked by the print function
the print basically invokes the dunder
str function which does all of this now
in the next line we say print c1 dot get
area so this is going to print the value
of the what what gets returned when we
invoke the method get area for this
particular instance c1 so obviously in
this particular instance our radius is
2.1 so the get area function should do
pi times 2.1 square and the value is as
you can see here is some 13.85 so that
is the area that we got now if we want
to print a particular radius um we just
say print c1.radius so this will print
the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well anytime that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name c1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say c1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1.radius now before we
move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is
for example
like for example if it's camel case well
each word that is part of this class has
its first letter capitalized variables
and method names are in lower class so
if my class was called circle we say
class circle with c being in capital now
moving on let's talk about how we
initialize or define instance variables
now instance variables are declared
within the init method if you remember
from the earlier example of circle init
is a dunder method it's followed and
it's preceded by double underscore as
you can see here now if you see in this
particular
case i have again used the self keyword
and as i mentioned earlier the self
keyword is the first parameter of all
member methods um
and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
the init function basically initializes
each and every new instance of
whatever of our class so we can give
init any number of parameters but the
first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value uh of for radius in our variable
radius now instance uh the i mean the
init function is not a constructor but
it is an initializer to create instance
variables the init function also will
never return a value and it is optional
and can be omitted if there are no
instance variables now let's move on to
um class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are talking talking about or
basically which instance of the dog are
we talking about now class attributes
are attributes that have the same value
for all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called circle and we have this
initializer again where we have a class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object which
stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance of
the class circle and unlike the
uh variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance okay now let's talk
about instantiating an object and let's
see what happens when we create two
different instances of the same class so
as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle and i'm
going to check its id well if you see
the id is something like this now if i
created another instance over here
called c2 and if i check its id well
it's something different now so if you
see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our
memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on
the introduction into oop let's talk
about class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
the class as its first argument so in
this case i am going to say i'm going to
define a class called myclass i'm going
to use this at class method decorator to
say that whatever follows here is going
to be a class method and i've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a um that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
whatever i have passed to it in the form
of hello from
self.name now what this this is going to
do is basically it's going to give out a
string saying hello from
name of the whatever class we have and
whatever we pass the attribute name so
oh in this my particular in this case
i'm going to invoke this method using
the class name itself i'm not going to
use an instance name because i have no
instance in this particular example and
since this is a class method it can be
invoked using the class name itself so
i'm going to pass rakesh and let's see
what happens when we do this as you can
see the first print will basically
give us the information of the class
itself it's saying that the class is
called myclass and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from the string name my class with
a
comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if i say class dot
class if i define a class myclass in
this example
and i'm going to define another function
called hello as you can see i have not
used any decorator like at
class method so this is going to be an
instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so i create my
instance called my instance1 and it's an
instance of this class and then i'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this.operator and the instance
name and the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method which is
declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
i have defined a static method i've
defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here i've created my instance and
i'm going to say dot hello it should
basically pre-print print hello world
that's all so um guys this was
this was it for the introduction on oop
in this video we will be covering the
topic of iterators now an iterator in
python is an object that contains a
countable number of values or it's a
larger object that contains a countable
number of sub-objects an iterator is an
object that can be iterated upon and
what that means is we can traverse from
each value and we can manipulate or
perform certain functions or operations
and tasks using each of the
sub-objects or values within this larger
collection called iterator now um when
we're looking at it technically an
iterator is an object which implements
the iterator protocol in python which
consists of the methods iter and the
method next so to begin with let's look
at a simple iterator we're going to see
the example of a list where we're going
to traverse through
the objects of a list using the for loop
so we have objects one two three four
and i'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here
another example of
an iterable in python is the dictionary
so let's say i have a dictionary where i
have two values two key value pairs uh
key x which contains a value one and key
y which corresponds to the value two now
when i'm going to do a for loop through
this by default i will be traversing
through the keys x and y as you can see
over here and of course uh the other
types of weight trebles in python are
like sets and tuples as well all right
now let's look at um
what this iterating protocol is in
python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects that
contain sub objects and when we use the
eater function it creates an iterator
out of it so we can one by one we can
traverse through um each of the objects
and we can manipulate each of the
objects that is contained in this and uh
anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we encountered the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh
iterated upon so and as an example i
will create a list
where i will store the values uh some
simple values integers one two three
four one three four five okay um i'm
going to create an iterator out of this
where i will use the iter function and
i'm going to say this is let's say this
is called my
my editor okay
and
i'm going to use iter function as i had
mentioned and i'm going to pass my list
in this
now if you see what is myattor
it should say it should be a list
iterator at a particular memory location
now let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see
now when i look at the next it should be
3 then i should get 4 and now i should
get 5 as i use the next successively now
since i've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time i use this next function i should
get a stop
stop iteration exception that is raised
as you can see here so this is the basic
um iteration protocol in python now you
might have uh already gone through the
for loop video and in that i have spoken
in quite a bit of detail as to how a for
loop performs this
this iterator protocol and how it
creates an iterative iterable object out
of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it
breaks out of the for loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for loops are like they're very very
uh similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now
let's do a basic comparison of what is a
a basic comparison between a generator
and an iterator in python so in
generator
we use a function we use like we define
it using the def keyword and we define
it under one function to create a
generator whereas in the case of
iterators we use two separate functions
the iter function and the next function
the generator makes use of the yield
keyword whereas the python iterator does
not
in generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any trouble like a list
to iterate upon
we may use any number of yield
statements in generators and we do not
use yield statements initiators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas
iterators are very memory efficient so
this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in python
now a module in python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files or several modules
now modular programming is the process
of breaking a large
a large event or task into smaller and
more manageable subtasks and we call
these subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger optic application there are
several advantages to modulizing code in
a large application and we will be going
through them right now so first of all
there is simplicity because instead of
focusing on a big big problem a big task
we can break down the problem into
smaller smaller portions of modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains
there is usability usability in the
sense that once we create a module we
can use it in different parts of the
code or even different different
applications itself there is also
scoping and what this means is modules
typically define a separate namespace
and this helps us avoid collisions
between identifiers in different areas
of a program functions modules and
packages are basically all constructs in
python that promote code module
modularization
you might have already come across a
gordon intro into functions in this
video we will be going through modules
in another video we will also cover the
topic of packages to import a module we
use the import keyword and in this
example what i'm going to show you is a
simple function or a simple operation of
importing the os module
this is short for operating system and
as the name suggests we can perform
system tasks through the functions and
methods that are part of this os module
so simply executing the statement will
import this module onto our program for
us to use now if we wanted to see all
the functions that are present in a
module what we have to do is use the dir
function so if we print the dir os
function it will print us basically a
directory of all the functions that are
present in the os module as you can see
here that like all of these are
basically uh names to different
functions that are part of the os module
finally moving on another function
commonly used with modules is the getcwd
function and what this does is it will
give us the current working uh directory
that we are working upon right now so if
i execute this it will tell me what is
the directory that i am currently
working upon right now as you can see
seed notebook dir
10. if we wanted to see all the files in
a particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if i were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that i am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
whatever module and saving it with a dot
py extension um so in in my example what
i'm going to do is i have already
created a script in notepad and i've
stored it with a dot py extension that
contains these four functions add
subtract product and division um i have
basically copied i basically used this
code and i've stored it in a dot py
script and i'm going to be using this as
my uh as as a test module for this
particular example now how do we import
a module now once that i have created a
script uh in my example will be called
my calc dot py and we've stated stored
it in our directory to import the module
all we have to do is use the import
statement so if i have to import my calc
all i have to do is say import my
underscore calc and now my calc has been
imported um so we can use the import
statement or if we want to import
something particular from mycalc we can
do from my calc import now we can
whatever like for example if we wanted
the add uh the add function we can
basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract uh for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything
we can also use from mycalc import and
we can say asterix to basically say uh
import everything that exists in mycalc
right now so this is another way of
importing something from a module now to
access contents in a module we have to
use the dot operator and i will show you
how right now so what i'm going to do is
in my example i'm going to import my
calc as calc so now what this since this
is the original folder or the original
module but i'm going to give it a
shorthand name so that i can easily use
it in my code and i don't have to type
out my underscore calc every time so now
i'm going to import this as calc so
anytime i have to refer to a particular
method or function inside this script or
this module i will just use this uh this
placeholder this variable name so now i
have two variables a and b and i'm
storing 20 and 30 in them so my first
func what i'm going to do is basically
four operations i'm going to print the
addition of a and b then the subtraction
multiplication and the division of these
two numbers and each time to do this
operation i am going to use the add
function that is present in the my calc
module so to do that i have already
imported my characters calc all i am
going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with so i'm going
to say calc dot add and then i'm going
to pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that i want to add
these two and similarly i'm going to do
it for subtraction
multiplication and division as you can
see these are the results of my tasks
now if i had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt uh
or dunder methods that are already a
part of any uh python script by default
such as built-ins so if i execute this
just to show you what happens when i use
the dir function it will basically give
me all the functions that are part of
this python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division fraud and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
in more detail into what happens when we
do a module search um let's let's
actually look at what happens so what
happens is when for example we execute
the statement import mycalc as calc as
we did over here so the first the steps
that actually take place are the
interpreter executes the above statement
and it searches for this python script
in a list of directories assembled from
these following sources that you see
here so it takes the directory from
which the input script was run or the
current directory if the interpreter is
being run interactively which is the
case right now uh secondly it will list
all the directories contained in the
python path environment that you set up
that you can set up or you can change
later on as well and this format for
python path is os dependent of course
but it should mimic the path environment
variable that we see in
windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search path that is accessible in the
python variable system.path
and this is basically obtained from a
module named sys so if i imported this
this and i did sys.path now these are
all the directories that we are going to
look for when we want to search for any
particular module so if i i'm doing uh
import my kayak or import os it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that i am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as
you could say directories or
paths in the system.path in this video
we will be covering the topic of
packages now what if we developed a very
large application in python that
contains many different modules and we
have so many different modules that have
similar names and functionalities and
they're all kept in like or dumped in
the same location then it becomes very
difficult to track these modules what if
there was a way to organize and access
these in a much simpler and more
organized manner well packages allow us
to do just that packages are a
hierarchical structuring of the module
name space using dot notation and this
is the same dot notation that we use
when we want to access methods or
functions that are part of other classes
or modules so let's try to
let's look at certain examples to
understand what we mean so i have a
directory called pkg this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod one dot py and mod two dot p
by and what we're going to store in mod
one and mod two dot py are the followers
so i'm going to define a function called
foo and i'm going to print
this particular statement mod 1 and then
i'm going to basically say foo
and then i'm going to say in class 4 i'm
going to
have an empty pass command similarly i'm
going to define a function called bar in
mod 2 dot py where i'm going to print
this statement so basically mod 1 dot py
has a simple function where i'm going to
print this statement and mod 2 dot py
has a simple function then i'm going to
print this statement
and i'm going to store them in mod 1 and
mod 2. py respectively and these two
modules i'm going to store in the
directory pkg in my local folder now
i've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if i wanted
to access these particular modules from
the pkg folder i can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so i can say pkg.mod1 so this will
inward this will
import the mod1 module from pkg folder
similarly i can do the same thing for
the mod 2
module from the pkg folder in the same
line so now that it's been imported just
simply execute this and this imports
whatever you needed now if we wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod one dot py we can just extend the
dot uh notation and use the function as
over here as you can see it performs
this print command whatever it was
supposed to do similarly i can invoke
the function uh that was part of the mod
2 module
by extending the dot notation to it in
the same way now another way that i can
invoke
i can import a package is by directly
importing the package itself by using
import pkg and
not accessing any of the specific
modules within it now let's see what
happens when we do this so just for this
example what i'm going to do is i'm
going to restart the kernel so that the
pkg
modules that were already imported get
cleaned away so we see what happens when
we execute this on its own now if you
see i haven't imported this now let's
see if i can access
my mod 1 and mod 2. if you see here it's
throwing me an error and this is because
using simply using the import command on
a particular package only imports um you
could say the package name space but it
does not actually import any of the
modules and files that were part of this
package so if i wanted mod 1
from this package i would have to
actually say import pkg.mod1 directly
and i cannot simply say import pkg and
python will not import everything that
is part of a package on its own i have
to specify it myself
specifically now i'm going to create and
i'm going gonna i mean i'm going to show
you another type of importing from a
package using the star operator so i
have this package pkg once again now i'm
going to store um three i mean four
different modules within this package
mod one one one dot p by mod two two two
dot p by and i've already done this so
you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
i've already created these files and
what i've done is within mod one one one
dot py i've defined i've
written this statement and i've stored
it in the python script similarly i've
created another python script script
called mod 222 dot py and i have
basically written this in the code and
i've simply done this for mod 333 dot py
and i've done another for mod 4 dot py
now once i have done this i've stored
these python scripts into my uh into my
package or pkg
package so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create i'm going to execute
this command if you see this from pkg
dot mod 333 import start so once i
execute this now i'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if i change
this and if i imported mod111 and if i
did the same thing you will see foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all uh
functions that are part of these
different modules where i'm importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is synced from pkg.mod111
so it's saying that um okay look into
this directory or this uh package and
find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application
and these modules can be accessed using
the familiar dot notation that we have
used in other examples such as methods
when we were working with classes and
objects in this video we will be taking
an introduction into the concept of
generators so python provides a
generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions so let's look at a simple
generator first of all so out here i
have defined
a generator called my generator where
i'm doing uh like there are three uh
like three
functions or three tasks that i'm doing
uh first one is when i'm printing the
first item and i'm yielding a value 10
then i'm printing second item yielding
20 then i'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator as the
function it uses the yield keyword
every time we use the next keyword we
will keep getting what is next in this
function
so let's store
the generator in my gen
so now
we have stored the iterator in this
function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first
task is performed or the first
iteration is performed where we get this
the first yield command is done all
right let's see what happens when we do
next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20.
let's do it for the next let's do it
once more since there is one more task
there's one more iterable inside
you can see this now our valley question
is what will happen if we do next gen
again since
there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error
as you can see stop iteration error this
is another
built-in
exception
that happens when we
have
like reached the last
object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so
now a key difference between a generator
and a function is that when we execute a
function the moment we hit the return
statement in a function or any execute a
function like whatever variables that
were stored inside are lost and they're
destroyed unless they were defined as
global
and the function is completely done
executing and we leave the function
completely whereas when it comes to a
generator
when we hit the yield function we don't
actually completely leave this function
so the first time the yield is found we
get 10
but
the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next iterable so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in python
so to understand a what the difference
between the yield command and the return
command does let's take the same
function
all right
and let's put a return over here
after this particular
the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to
my
generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what is there
so the first deal will be standard first
item 10
the next one is again is going to say
second item and then 20 but now if you
notice there was a return i put over
here
so
technically when i did the second next
it's not only yielded 20 but it's also
executed this return function or this
return statement so let's see what
happens if i do next again
as you see i have gotten the stop
iteration
seemingly earlier than i did before and
that's because i have used the return
function and our in return statement and
what that's done is that um
if we've completely left this function
so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between
yield and return
now in the next example i'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for loop or for a for
loop so let's take this whatever over
here
and i have defined a function called get
sequence up to x and
what this will do is basically
it will keep printing the
printing numbers
up until whatever we have entered in
place of x over here so if i said
say sequence is equal to
let's uh
copy this
all right
and say i want
i want sequentially i want every number
up until 10 well not including 10 of
course because python starts with zero
right
so let's do this
and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield zero and now if i
did this again
it should give me 1
2 and i can keep going
until
i
will stop at the value 9
as you can see here
so 8
9
now i should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator
is
in the case of fibonacci numbers so
let's use it
let's
see how we can generate a fibonacci
series using um generator so i've
defined a fibonacci function called
fibonacci where i'm passing max so max
is basically the max value that i want
um
like up until where i want the sequence
right so
this is basically the code which will
give you returned me the subsequent
values of my fibonacci sequence
so
let's
pass this to fib
and see i want all the fibonacci numbers
until 10
so and i will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero
then when we
do this again we get 1
then we do 0 plus 1 it should be 1
next number should be 1 plus 1 which is
2 then we should have 2 plus 1
3
and then 3 plus 2 5 then 3 plus 5 should
be 8. now 8 plus 5 is 13 and since 13 is
greater than what we passed for our max
value here now when we try this
we should get the stop iteration error
as you can see in this video we will be
learning about the concept of list
comprehension now list comprehension is
it's a neat way of creating a new list
based on values that are already there
in an existing list so you can think of
it like
creating a new list
using a much shorter and cleaner syntax
compared to what you might traditionally
be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes
creating these new lists much simpler
much easier for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list
which will contain fruits that contain
the letter a in their name so we already
have a list of
fruits over here as you can see
it has apple it has banana cherry kiwi
and mango now we want to create a new
list which has only the fruits that have
the letter a inside them so apple would
be one of them banana would be one of
them and mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few
extra lines
but yeah it does it does do what we want
to do now what if there was a way of
doing the same thing by just writing one
simple line of code and that exists as
you can see here
so i take the same
list
now
this is where you need to follow so now
my new list is equal to so i'm creating
a list over here as you can see now
within this list you have this line this
is what we call a list comprehension so
as you can see it says each fruit for
each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a
inside
each fruit and what this each fruit is
that we're checking each
object in this list one by one so first
in the first iteration each fruit will
contain the string apple then in the
next iteration it will contain banana
and in each
each iteration we are going to check if
it contains the character a and if it
does then we store that each fruit in
the new list
as you can see here
so if i execute this line you see
my my result is the same i have my
whatever i wanted and this was a much
cleaner way of writing
or creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what i'm going to do
is i am going to iterate through a
string so i have a string it can be
anything in this case i am using a
string called human
all right so i have a string called
human right now i want to store each
character of this string into a
list that we call h underscore letters
so if i use the for loop this is how we
would do it if i execute this as you can
see the list contains h and then u m a
and then n now what if i wanted to do
the same thing but uh by using list
comprehension
so what i would do is
let's create
a list over here let's underscore
letters
and
um
so as we know let's com so a list
comprehension will uh it's it's a so you
just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when i check what's in
edge letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see i have
the output as uh what i needed so this
is a much cleaner way let's go through
some more examples now now we can do
more list comprehensions um we can even
use so we've already seen uh
one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
went through where we we did a sort of a
loop through a string we can also use
this comprehensions in conditionals so
let's uh look at an example where we use
the
this comprehension with an if statement
so what if i wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would so this is
an example that i'll be using
so in my list i want to store the first
10 even numbers so this would be a way
to do
it so i have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is x is going to take the
value of one two three four and so on
until 90 either actually take it from 0
1 2 3 4 until 19. so when we do range 20
we're creating an iterate in iterable
where uh
we're going to
loop through our iterate through the
value of 0 to 19. so
if i if i do this and this what this
statement does is basically it checks if
it's divisible by 2.
so
if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number
and if this condition is met if this
condition is met that means we store
the x into our number list so let's see
what happens when we execute this
it should contain
uh 0 2 4 6 until 18 so this is the first
and even numbers as you can see
so this is a neat way of using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if five i'm checking um
each
okay so i'm going to create another list
and in this list i'm going to basically
see if um
each of my uh num numbers are the even
or odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so i want it to be even
in case
the i that i'm checking
i being every number between so like say
the first 10 natural numbers as i said
let's check if um
if it is divisible by 2
well if it divides by 2 of course it's
going to be even right
else
we say that it is odd
and then we check for i in say the first
let's say the first 20
okay
so now when we do this let me check
oh we check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even not is basically saying the number
uh 0 is even then the number 1 is odd
then number 2 is even and so on and so
forth so this is uh an example where we
used the
list comprehension with if-else
statements
so another neat thing that we can do
with the
list comprehensions is that we can use
it along with functions so let's look at
this function
in this example we have a function
called double x where we define this
double x uh this double function to take
an input uh to take an argument x and
what we return is the square of the
argument so
let's use this in our lifts this
comprehension so what we do over here is
that we are
we're checking what we're doing is for
every x um between range 10 so we're
taking the value of 0 1 2 3 until 9 and
we're passing it to this function double
x and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list
uh x let's just call this list uh let's
call it y so now let's see what's in y
and we check uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and
so on so wait this let's check again
does this square no this is actually 2
times so let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see 0 1 4 9
for the first
10 numbers 10 natural numbers now what
i've shown you is obviously list
comprehension
but we can also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as
list comprehensions the only difference
is the
set comprehension will make sure that
there are no duplicates inside the set
so you can't have like duplicate items
which you can in the case of list
comprehensions so let's uh let's just
take a look at an example so here in
this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text and the string is uh
something like life finds a way so
whatever this is
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
uh in iterate through this string
character by character and we're going
to check if
uh there are we're going to check for
wobbles essentially so
uh we're going to see if the character a
e i o or u is present in the string and
if it is we will pass it into our set
now if you if you look you will find
there are multiple eyes right and there
are multiple a's as well so
if we did this through a list
comprehension each time that we
found find a vowel it would be added to
our list but since this is a set and
sets do not allow duplicates so you will
only have one copy or one particular
object for each of the uh wobbles so
uh of course now
set comprehension is defined using curly
braces so let's keep that in mind so now
if i check what's in this i will see a e
i and u even though there are multiple
a's or multiple e's or i's and u's since
this is a set we don't have duplicate
copies of any copies of any of these uh
so this was just a small example for
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and we
call the discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing that we
have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is
again dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except
in this case we will define a key and
that separates it from a set
comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
i'm checking
i'm going through the a list of numbers
from 0 to 9 right this is what the range
10 function does
and
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create a key which is going
to be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be its square as you can see
here
i'm doing i times i
or just to
make a little more clearer
as you can see i'm doing i square over
here for every value from 0 to 9 so what
i should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is 0 and the value of that
key should be 0 as well because 0
square is 0 then for 1 it will be 1 and
then for 2 4 and then 3 9 4 16. so let's
see what happens
as you can see here
this is the
result that i wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to
list comprehensions um so it's obviously
an elegant way uh to define and create
lists based on existing lists
it's more compact and faster than normal
functions and loops but we should also
keep in mind that we shouldn't write
like very complicated
list comprehensions because
the idea of a list comprehension is to
be user friendly and also it's important
to note that every list comprehension
can be written in the form of a loop but
every loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember so
yeah that's it uh this for this video on
list comprehension set comprehension
dictionary comprehensions i hope you
learned a new
a neat new technique or trick
when it comes to creating your new list
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example
if you see this example here you can see
a symbol called the carrot followed by p
and then five periods
then an n and a dollar sign and what
this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with p ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now
this is a regex pattern that is looking
for a five character string that starts
with a ends with s and has three
characters in between
now if we had to match this with this
string with these strings as in as i or
test strings the first one would not
match because it's a three letter string
and we're looking for a five character
string the second one would match
because it's a five character string
that ends with an s starts with an a and
has three characters in between this
will not match because whatever pattern
would do is it would find the first s
and it would find that it the string
itself starts with an a and it would say
okay there are only two characters
between this first s
and this a and it would assume that this
is actually just a four character string
to actually
identify two consecutive s's we would
have to do something special and what we
would have to do is what we will see
later on
so again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a
is perfectly fine when we're searching
for this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python can be
imported using this statement import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use
our regular expression tools and methods
to do
pattern recognition character
recognitions and to identify different
sequence of characters in our strings
let's try to understand
a bit more in depth about regular
expressions now so what you're seeing
here is one variable called pattern
which stores
something that looks like a regex
and another variable that stores our
test string called abyss
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method of this
module re and we're going to check
whether this pattern
or whatever we are trying to search
using this regex is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what i just showed
you a five character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if i execute
this and this is what it does
now if i change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with uh a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here
now let's try to understand what exactly
do we mean by uh when we use these
different certain these special symbols
like for example this carrot or this
dollar symbol um these are by the way
known as meta characters and now we're
going to look into all the uh or most of
the different meta characters that are
used in like x
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's a list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square bracket
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match
some combination of a b and c it can be
one a two a's three b's four c's we are
not looking at a specific pattern we
just want to know if a b and c exists in
any form in our string so if we used it
on a the string a simply we would find
one match because the letter a is found
here ac would match twice because we
have a and c
present here in this string hey jude we
will have no matches because a b and c
none of them are found here and in this
weird string we will have actually one
two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re.match to do
to actually search for this and to see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
i'm going to test this i'm going to
match whether my pattern that
any of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when i
use re.match for this
so the the format the syntax is simply
the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like i can see an a
over here i can see a c over here
re.match actually gives us the result
none
now
if i
try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least in 1998
what i'm saying here is all film titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match
works or not
as you can see it actually does return
when i execute this it returns us an
object called re.match object with a
span01 the span zero one is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a
uh from amongst these options so what
this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the
re.match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
uh it will return us the first instance
where it finds a match now let's see
this is the test string now and now
we're searching again for our uh we're
searching for a b and c any any of these
in our test string but we're going to
use re.search and not match so now if
you see it returns us when i execute
this it returns us a match object again
but this time it's saying the span of 9
and 10. now the spine panel 9 and 10
actually exists over here
this is the ninth character and a itself
is the 10th character over here so what
this basically is telling us that the
tenth character is where we found a
match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a or b or c in
this whole string and this is basically
how re.search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance or wherever
we find now what if we wanted to find
out all the instances wherever a b and c
were found and not just the first
instance but in that case we would be
using the method find all over here so
when we use find all it will actually
return us each and every case where it
found a b or c and uh you might not it
won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like um so if i
execute this you can see it gives us a a
list with a c a and a and what this
basically means is it was looking for
the characters a or b or c and it found
a first and hence this for the first
item the list and then it found a c and
then it found two is successfully so
this is exact this is actually how find
all works where it will actually find
all the instances of our x pattern now
that you've seen how the square brackets
work and how the re dot search and re
dot
match and re dot find all methods work
now we're going to go through all the
other meta characters that we saw above
so the period now period matches any
single character except the new line new
line is basically slash n or a break now
if you look at this picture what it's
going to do is um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have
two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically asking us
do we have two characters present in our
string so if i had to match it with this
a it will obviously be a no match
because a is one character if we checked
it with ac it is a match because a and c
are two characters a c and d will also
give us only one match because it will
find a c and then it will leave d as a
single character but when we check a c d
and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because it will
consider a and c as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches so
below is basically what we are doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd dot search for each of these
different examples
so if i if you see when i use find all
on acde and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me a c and d e as you can
see here and similarly for something
like this it will return me again uh
whatever like two character patterns it
finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the carrick
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the
one is checking if a
is the beginning of a string and the
other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's only the character a and it
will match here as well because this
string starts with a but it will not
match here because this string starts
with b now if i look at this
particular expression
you can see that um
this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
a because it's not followed by a b
so out here is basically us using the
ie.search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples
so this is going to check basically if
so this expression will check if the
string ends with a so this this string
is basically the character a so it will
match this also ends with a so it will
match and this particular string does
not end with a so it will not match and
we are going to do that using the re dot
search over here so as you can see it
finds a match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns us a none another example
is
of the meta characters is star so this
is the symbol for star and this what the
star basically is used is for checking
if there are zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it so now if
you see here
what this will check for is
um is there any form of
m and a that occurs before n and it's
very important to note that
the n has to follow the a in this case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen so if i checked it with m
and n this is actually a match because
n is followed by zero occurrences of m
and a which is if it might seem a little
weird but it is technically the truth
because
uh the the star symbol checks for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for if n
occurs it must occur after an a
or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine m a uh m
triple a n is also fine because n
follows an a and there's an m here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have m and a and we have
an n you see the n is immediately
followed by an i
is n follows an i immediately or the n
is preceded by an i immediately and this
is a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must
proceed an a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the id dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the re dot search as you
can see here finally we have the next
meta character which is the plus symbol
yes so the plus symbol matches
one or more occurrences of the pattern
left to it now this is very similar to
what we saw earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences instead of
zero or more occurrences that we were
looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now
we need what is there to the left of the
plus sign at zero no occurrence of it
will not be allowed or will not cause a
match
so let's see now what we're going to do
here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign so now what
we're going to say is okay we need m and
a at least one occurrence followed by an
n the all of these conditions have to be
met so again if you took the first
example m and n this time it will be a
no match because there is no occurrence
of an a over here for preceding the n so
it's a no match m a and n is a match
because well this is this is perfectly
fine m triple a and n is also perfectly
fine but if you look at m a i and n much
like earlier the n
is
preceded by an i and not an a so there
is no match and again women is perfectly
fine and we basically execute the same
thing through the search function in
this piece of code the next meta
character is the question mark the
question mark symbol matches zero or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
so
let's see what this does so now
we saw the star
the star which was zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it we saw the plus which is one or
more occurrences of the pattern to the
left of it now we will see the question
mark which is zero or one only zero or
only one and not zero or more of one or
more which was the previous cases only
zero and one or 1 occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it again we're
going to see the same expression except
we're going to replace the meta
character with the question mark so now
let's see what what happens when we
match
so if you see here m and n is a match
because there is zero occurrence of a
and one occurrence of m preceding n so
this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
eight currents of a and m and then it's
followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a which is
followed by an n we're only looking for
zero or one
this again main will be a no match for
the same reasons that we have already
gone through and women will be a match
again for the same reasons
and we do the same things using the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do is we're going to see if there are
so uh that is the typical syntax for the
braces is an uh brace followed by some
integer n comma integer m and then close
braces so what this means is we're
looking for at least n
and at most m repetitions
of the pattern left of the braces let's
see through an example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least two
and at most three occurrences of this
the character a in our test strings so
let's see what happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a and even this part of the string
only contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three
this part will contain one match the
second the second example because the
second part of the string actually
contains
two a's for one uh two uh repetitions of
ace con consecutively
but this uh in the end and in the third
example you can see both the strings
actually contain matches so we get two
matches because as you can see here
there's two a's here followed by three
a's here now when we look at this
particular string let's look at what
happens now so what we're going to find
is that this thing is perfectly fine so
we have two occurrences of a but now we
have four occurrences of a but what the
search engine is going to recognize is
these first three is and is going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and i already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a and the
search it will just look at the first
three and say okay there are
three a's and my my match is fine so
again there are two matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is
0-9 now a dash symbol is valid in python
using regex because what this basically
tells it is that it's looking for either
zero one two three four so on until nine
basically any of the digits we're
looking for any of the digits from zero
to nine
and we're going to uh check if at least
two and at most four occurrences of
digits if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it'll find one match
this basically this particular part of
the string where it says one two three
so this is uh three occurrences of
digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and whatever this is
you will see this will not find a match
here this obviously will not because
these are characters but if you look at
over at this part it will find matches
in the in terms of the first four and
then seven and three the next two
one and two again there are no matches
because there's only single occurrences
of digits we're looking for it at at
least two and at most four so if i use a
find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me one two and three as you can
see here but now if you look at this
test string it's going to return me 12
it's going to return me 3 4 5 and 6 is
going to return me 3 4 1 and 2 but not 7
because we're looking for at least 2 and
then it's going to return me 4 5 6 and 7
followed by 8 and 8 as you can see in
this list over here
now if we use curly braces with only one
digit it's basically telling the search
engine that
we want exactly so many repetitions of
the preceding uh whatever kind of
expression that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we are basically saying that we
want uh x
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again which
will not match in this case because
there are only two dashes and it will
match in this case because there are
exactly three dashes and it will again
not not match in this case because there
are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation um
the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b so a should be followed
by a b and uh basically this pattern has
to keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here uh we will
have a match because we at least find an
a even though there is no b
but this is to consider match because we
did find an a at least over here we'll
have uh three matches because we have a
followed by a b followed by an a again
so if we did a reg expression for this
we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that i want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what i want is some form
of a
following b following c
some sort of alternation between a b and
c so this part as you can see here is
kept in a parenthesis because i want
this whole condition to basically occur
before i find in x and z so let's look
at what happens here
in the first case we don't have a match
because uh there this basically this
parenthesis condition is not being met
the x and z is preceded by a space
or basically the a and b is preceded is
followed by a space so if this space
didn't occur we would actually find a
match as you can see in the next example
here you can see a and b occur basically
this uh initial condition is met
followed by x and z so there is a one
match so it's fine for us now if you
look at this slightly more a trickier
one what you can see is we have two
matches in this case first in a followed
by x and z and then we have
c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get b followed by an x
and z so you'll get two matches in this
case now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works let's look at grouping
constructs so grouping constructs break
up a regex in python into sub
expressions or groups and this serves
two purposes one is a grouping part
which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional matter characters apply
to the entire group as a unit and then
there's the capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for uh as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the character r only
because there's no parenthesis as in
this example so this plus is
next to an r and it's going to check for
basically
whether one or more occurrence of r
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put b a and r in a parent
thesis followed by plus it will actually
check for the entire string bar and it
will check one or more occurrences of
bar together so if you look at these two
examples when we use this uh on these
examples you can see that these are fine
like these matches are fine but if i
used this
parenthesis then these would be the
acceptable matches and like ba triple r
would not be a match if i use
parenthesis uh as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parenthesis work so let's look
at some other examples so what this will
do is f-o-o has to be optionally
followed by
b-a-r and b-a-r must exist together
and
this is because we have a question mark
here this question mark symbol tells us
that there should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular complicated
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing
is followed by a plus so we're looking
for this whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it cow is simply just cow
we're looking for this pattern and this
is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of c or w
because of the existence of the question
mark for uh preceded by the parenthesis
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you